Hättest du gedacht, dass wir in einer Zeit leben, in der man darüber diskutiert,
ob Elon Musk einen Hitlergruß gemacht hat, wo alles so offensichtlich ist und
zugleich die Ambivalenz natürlich
von ihm noch da ist, dass er gewisse Grußformeln dabei weggelassen hat,
dass man darüber noch diskutiert und in der Welt Rechtfertigungen erscheinen?
Ja, ich habe gleich Clips dazu, aber wir haben ja aus eigener Kraft Argumentation in diesem Podcast,
denn wir haben ja Röttger Brechmann, der ja die Frage stellte,
was ist mit diesen Politikern, die sich auf großer Bühne immer Unerhörtes trauen,
von dem wir wissen, im sozialen Nahfeld geht das irgendwie nicht.
Also irgendwie mit einem Kanzler zusammensitzen und sagen, ja,
ja, Herr Kanzler, Ihre Agenda ist genau richtig. Ich bin gerne Ihr Finanzminister,
Sie sind der beste Typ der Welt.
Dieser Kanzler hat gezeigt, dass was möglich ist. Und dann verlässt du den Raum,
Ronsheimer ruft an und er fragt, haben Sie eine Meinung zum Kanzler?
Und du sagst, das ist das größte Arschloch der Welt, der verrät uns alle und
Deutschland geht den Bach runter.
Muss man sich ja trauen. Und manche Menschen trauen sich etwas auf großer Bühne,
was sie sich in Angesicht des Kanzlers nicht trauen.
So, und Elon Musk hat sich da etwas getraut, das nun interessanterweise,
du hast es gesagt, von der Welt verteidigt wird.
Ja.
Jetzt fragen wir uns natürlich, wenn die in der Welt angestellt werden,
ihren komischen Springer-Kodex unterschreiben, Israel, Amerika,
Transatlantik und so weiter und so fort, begrüßen sie sich dann mit Hitlergrüßen?
Ich glaube, nein. Und das ist ja ganz lustig, auch dann zu sehen,
dass Elon Musk ja nochmal zugeschaltet war beim AfD-Parteitag Und dort gesagt hat,
um das jetzt ganz kurz zu halten, lass das mal mit diesem Schuldkult sein, warum immer Holocaust,
denk nicht immer über die Geschichte nach.
Und da hat jetzt Döpfner einen Meinungsbeitrag geschrieben, so ginge es ja nun
nicht. Und das war ja dann ganz lustig, dass da also Döpfner plötzlich eine
Kritik an Elon Musk formuliert.
Natürlich ist dieser Text auch sehr amüsant zu lesen, denn eigentlich müsste
der natürlich so lauten,
lieber Elon Musk, alles gut und schön, dass du dich für den Rechtsruck einsetzt,
das tun wir ja auch, aber wir wollen schon auch noch, wenn es uns passt,
den Holocaust instrumentalisieren für unsere Zwecke.
Deswegen können wir das jetzt natürlich nicht ganz so machen, wie du das vorschlägst.
Da müssen wir dich mal ins Gebet nehmen und dir zeigen, wie wir hier schon seit
vielen Jahrzehnten Politik machen.
Also es ist wirklich ein Zusammentreffen der Multimilliardäre,
die sich noch nicht ganz fein abgestimmt haben.
Genau und das ist doch toll, weil wir in diesen aufgeregten Zeiten jetzt eine
Problemlage haben, die offensives und etwas ehrlicheres, authentischeres Sprechen verlangt, ermöglicht.
Also, während sich Döpfner im Hintergrund hält und glaubt, er zieht hier Stricken,
indem er Elon Musk in den Gastbeitrag genehmigt und dann im Spiegel gerätselt
wird, ob das jetzt Döpfner eingefädelt hat oder nicht und wir uns alle denken,
ja genau, das sind die wichtigen Fragen,
haben wir doch jetzt so einen Moment, wo alle so ein bisschen ehrlicher damit umgehen.
Und Döpfner sich denkt, nee, ich rufe heute doch mal in der Redaktion an,
statt direkt auf den Golfplatz oder ins Museum zu gehen, um kurz der Öffentlichkeit zu vermitteln,
Hitlergrüße gehen doch zu weit. Das ist nicht ganz vereinbar.
Ja, beziehungsweise das, was er da sagte mit der deutschen Schuld bei dem Parteitag,
bei den Hitlergrüßen war ja interessant,
dass zugleich davor in der Welt ja Rechtfertigungen schrieben,
dass jetzt irgendwie die linke Woke Bubble da Hitlergrüße oder was erkennen will.
Also das war ja auch Tenor dann auf Twitter von vielen, nennen wir sie mal rechten
Journalisten, dass sie die ganze Zeit so getan haben, als sei das einfach nur
ein Winken, irgendetwas.
My heart goes out to you. Ich brauche mich nicht mal hier am Tisch.
Ja, bitte nicht, dass wir hier noch gewandt werden.
Geht das auch im Sitzen?
Ja, das wäre auch eine interessante Frage.
Ich dachte, die Deutschen stehen anständig. Wir kommen nachher drauf zurück.
Also zu diesem Moment des ehrlichen Sprechens.
Wir haben gestern am 30.
Im Deutschlandfunk, der macht ja immer eine Tageszusammenfassung,
ein Interview, wir haben ja in dieser Tageszeit immer einen Interviewgast und
es hat sich ein aktiver CDUler aus dem Bundestag, aus der Märzfraktion,
der nicht mitstimmte oder sich enthielt,
also er hat teilgenommen, ich weiß nicht, ob er sich enthalten oder dagegen gestimmt hat.
Im Radio sagt, mein Chef hat den Zauberlehrling gemacht. Es ist die Geister
nicht wieder losgeworden.
Und das fand ich cool.
Ganz seltener Moment, man könnte ja jetzt mal da bleiben, denn das Erfolgsrezept
von Donald Trump war, den Leuten erfolgreich zu vermitteln, dass er selbst glaubt, was er sagt.
Was nicht schwierig ist, denn Donald Trump ist, das kann man jetzt auch mal
ganz ehrlich sagen, doof. Also der ist einfach dumm.
Das Erfolgsrezept von ihm ist ja auch, ich bin so doof, dass alle glauben,
sie könnten mich in ihre Richtung ziehen.
Also hat er jetzt Stephen Miller mit einer harten Einwanderungspolitik und Elon
Musk auf der anderen Seite und dann hat er Steve Bannon auf der einen und die
anderen auf der anderen und alle kämpfen so miteinander, weil sie glauben,
nee, was der Trump da sagte, geht eigentlich in meine Richtung.
Und dann sagen die anderen, nee, das war in meine Richtung ausgelegt. Bist du bescheuert?
Und beide wissen, es macht gar keinen Sinn, jetzt mit Trump darüber zu diskutieren,
weil bei Trump zwei Kilometer vor seinem Schlafzimmer stürzt ein Flugzeug ab
mit 16 Amerikanern drin.
Und seine Botschaft dazu ist, not good.
Also da gibt es nichts zu diskutieren.
Und die woke Ideologie sei auch mit dran schuld.
Das auch natürlich. Da werden wir noch einige zu knuspern haben.
Also es passieren dramatischste Ereignisse.
Und alle wissen, das müssen wir jetzt mit Trump nicht diskutieren.
Das muss jetzt eine Ebene tiefer. Und das hat ihn aber, weil alle glaubten,
und jetzt müssen die das auskämpfen.
Ja, diese Liberalitäten sind ja schon offensichtlich. Trump hat ja jetzt dieses
Stargate-Programm gestartet, von dem man auch jetzt überlegen kann,
wie sinnvoll ist das eigentlich, nicht so wahnsinnig viel Geld draufzuwerfen,
wo man sieht, die Chinesen können das mit Diebseek billiger.
Jedenfalls hat er ja also damit Sam Altman sehr protegiert.
Das ist nun der Erzfeind von Elon Musk, der dann gleichzeitig schon wieder twitterte,
wie furchtbar dieser Sam Altman ist und dass der ja eigentlich ein Demokrat
sei, dass er ja damals Trumps Wahl kritisiert habe etc.
Das heißt also, wir erleben jetzt die Rivalität der Multimilliardäre,
die Milliardäre, die unter Trump sich um Plätze sorgen, kämpfen.
Wir haben bei der Inauguration gesehen, dass dort die Milliardärsklasse schon direkt präsent war.
Und zwar muss man hier auch sagen, die Milliardäre der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt einfach irgendwelche alten Ölbarone
dahingesetzt hat. Die haben natürlich immer lobbyiert.
Die haben immer einen Einfluss gehabt.
Und die haben natürlich dafür gesorgt, Dass der Klimawandel lange Zeit nicht
als Problem erkannt wurde.
Das gab es ja zu allen Zeiten. Ich glaube nur, dass jetzt also diese mediale
Präsenz von Trump und diejenigen, die die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie in ihren Händen
haben, zusammenkommen und dort natürlich jetzt die eigentlichen Kämpfe stattfinden.
Denn es geht diesen Leuten ja nicht mehr dann ums Geld, sondern nur noch um
die Frage, wer steht wie da.
Und deswegen gibt es auch diese geradezu kindischen Tweets dann von Elon Musk
gegen Sam Altman beispielsweise.
Ja, aber viele Clips, die ich jetzt im Hinterkopf habe, ich werde sie spontan nicht rauskramen.
Donald Trump hat ja bei der Amtszeitführung gesagt, ohne diese komische E-Auto-Förderung,
die werden wir streichen.
Ab jetzt darf wieder jeder Amerikaner selbst aussuchen, welches Auto er fährt.
Was natürlich dann kommentiert wurde mit, oh krass, das geht ja voll gegen Tesla,
weil die immer davon profitiert, dass die Teslas billiger sind.
Wozu dann Alex Jones in seinem Infowars-Podcast sagt, da sieht man es,
ein Mann aufrecht stehend nimmt den Hit gegen seine eigenen Unternehmen für die Republik.
So, gleichzeitig wissen wir aber, Elon Musks Meme-Stock-Börsenwert seiner selbst
ist um 60 Milliarden gestiegen, allein in den zwei Wochen seit der Amtseinführung.
Was mehr als ein Jahresumsatz Tesla verkaufend ist.
Also es juckt ihn so im Grunde nicht. Es ist alles absurd. Wir gehen aber gleich,
also wir machen das sehr ausführlich heute.
Wir gehen ins politische Vorfeld und wir blicken ein bisschen in die Zukunft, Österreich.
Mal wieder. Ja, wir machen es immer wie Österreich. Da wir es bisher immer wie
Österreich gemacht haben, nutzen wir die Gelegenheit und gucken uns heute schon
mal den März 2025 mit Friedrich Merz in Deutschland an.
Ja, du hast gesehen, er war beim World Economic Forum zu Gast Friedrich Merz.
Mehr habe ich nicht gesehen. Er hat Strümpfe mit seinen Initialen drauf gehabt.
Mittelschicht.
Da fragt man sich jetzt, wozu braucht man das?
Gar nicht.
Vergisst er morgens seinen Namen?
Oh, das werden wir heute. Wozu braucht man das?
Lebt er im Heim, dass man dann die wieder zuordnen kann, wenn sie in der Wäsche
waren? Also das sind die Fragen, die ich mir gestellt habe.
Jedenfalls war er dort.
Wenn du deine Sachen nur im Hotel wäschen lässt.
Ja.
Oder zu Hause.
Ist das sinnvoll?
Dann ist das sinnvoll, die Namen da drin zu haben. Das ist wie bei den Erstklässlern,
wenn die Lehrerin schreibt,
anders als im Kindergarten können wir die Sachen hier nicht einfach so auseinanderhalten,
denn hier sind ein paar mehr Kinder, bitte schreiben sie mit einem Edding den
Namen in die Jacke. So ist das bei Merz auch.
Ja, es ist entsetzlich, wir lachen jetzt hier gerade, aber was jetzt doch in
den vergangenen Tagen passiert ist, hätte ich so nicht gedacht.
Also meine These war eine Weile die folgende.
Friedrich Merz ist derjenige mit sauerländischem Katholizismus im Hintergrund,
der derjenige sein wird, der noch einmal sagt, die CDU ist die konservativ-rechte
Partei, da darf es daneben eigentlich nichts geben.
Und da schotten wir uns auch nach rechts ab. Er wäre also der Letzte seiner Art.
Danach, das habe ich hier im Podcast auch schon mal betont, habe ich nicht mehr
das irgendwo als Hoffnung gesehen.
Sondern ich würde sagen, die Unterschiede zwischen Alice Weidel und vielen Jüngeren
aus der CDU, Jens Spahn und anderen, sind so marginal, dass wir uns jetzt sehr
vertiefen müssten in Einzelaussagen, um das noch festzustellen,
wo die Unterschiede sind.
Das heißt, dass da Koalitionen möglich sind, war mir sofort klar.
Habe ich gedacht, das ist dann das für 2029.
Ich habe nicht damit gerechnet, dass Friedrich Merz so, ich weiß gar nicht.
Wenig darüber nachdenkt, strategisch, weil er ja immer als sehr große Stratege
beschrieben wird, was das eigentlich bedeutet, was er hier macht und ein rhetorisches Talent.
Natürlich, dass er das macht, ich hätte es ihm nicht zugetraut oder um es anders
zu formulieren, ich hätte ihn für ein wenig klüger gehalten und zu allem,
was wir jetzt gleich sagen werden, will ich in Erinnerung rufen,
ein Kanzler hat ja viel kompliziertere Dinge zu lösen als das,
was Friedrich Merz sich da jetzt selbst eingebrockt hat.
Also fragt man sich wirklich, wenn er das schon jetzt so gegen die Wand fährt
und da sind wir jetzt noch gar nicht bei menschenrechtlichen Fragen und sowas,
sondern einfach nur mal strategisch draufgeblickt.
Wie sieht das jetzt so weltpolitisch aus? Also ist die Option jetzt,
dass entweder Friedrich Merz uns an Trump und Putin gleichzeitig veräußern wird
oder löst einfach den dritten Weltkrieg aus? Also ich glaube,
diese beiden Optionen sind da.
Die Wehrpflicht ist ja dann auch eingeführt. Kämpfen für Friedrich heißt das dann.
Ich würde sagen, man muss Panik schon deshalb bekommen, weil hier ja jemand
strategisch offenbar nichts auf dem Kasten hat.
Ja, ist auch sehr gut, dass du das einführst mit, wir lachen jetzt hier,
jetzt werden wir kurz ernst und fragen uns, ob Friedrich Merz der redliche Konservative
ist, den wir in Deutschland brauchen. Und wir stellen fest, nein.
Du hast einen Clip von Friedrich Merz mitgebracht, der wir zur Einstimmung eines
Rundowns hören können. Ich kenne ihn nicht, ich sehe ihn aber schon.
In den sozialen Medien gepostet, eine Ansprache direkt an uns jetzt,
an uns Wähler und vor allem auch an die, die Kinder haben.
Ich habe Kinder. Okay, dann höre ich mal zu.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger,
Ich habe selbst Kinder. Und ich kann mir trotzdem kaum vorstellen,
wie es sich für eine Mutter oder einen Vater anfühlen muss, ihr Kind morgens
in die Kita oder in die Schule zu bringen und es mittags oder abends nicht mehr
in die Arme schließen zu können.
Meine Damen und Herren, ich weigere mich anzuerkennen, dass die Taten von Mannheim,
Solingen, Magdeburg und jetzt Aschaffenburg, die neue Normalität in unserem Land sein sollen.
Das Maß ist endgültig voll. Wir stehen vor dem Scherbenhaufen einer seit zehn
Jahren fehlgeleiteten Asyl- und Einwanderungspolitik.
Deutschland, unser Land, muss endlich wieder sicher werden. Ich habe daher gestern
einige Vorschläge gemacht.
Und sicher ist, und das möchte ich Ihnen versichern, Sollte ich zum Bundeskanzler
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gewählt werden.
Dann werde ich am ersten Tag meiner Amtszeit das Bundesinnenministerium anweisen,
die deutschen Staatsgrenzen zu allen unseren Nachbarstaaten dauerhaft zu kontrollieren
und ausnahmslos alle Versuche der illegalen Einreise zurückzuweisen.
In diesen Minuten, in denen ich hier spreche, laufen Täter weiter frei in unserem Land herum.
Das ist ein Zustand, den wir beenden müssen und den wir beenden werden.
Die Menschen in Deutschland müssen sich wieder sicher fühlen.
Und dafür werde ich kämpfen, mit aller Entschlossenheit und aller Entschiedenheit.
Und ich möchte Ihnen sagen, darauf können Sie sich wirklich verlassen.
Könnten wir uns darauf verlassen? Nein, könnten wir natürlich nicht.
Interessant ist ja schon, dass er hier Magdeburg mit hinzunimmt,
wo wir es ja mit einem Fall zu tun haben, dass ein Mann, der viele,
viele Jahre hier lebte, als Arzt hier arbeitete, dann durchführt.
Zu solch einer schrecklichen Tat übergeht, wo man aber nicht sagen kann,
da ist die Integration an sich misslungen,
sondern da würde man erstmal sagen, ja das ist ja ein Beispiel für eine gute
Integration gewesen, dass jemand eine solche gute Position in einer Klinik inne hat.
Da ist dann eine private Radikalisierung und vielleicht auch eine Psychose,
wir kennen ja den Täter nicht genau, wir waren nicht bei Gutachten oder so dabei,
entstanden, die dazu geführt hat, dass er so etwas machte.
Es gab vor einigen Jahren in Trier einen Fall von jemandem, der keinen Migrationshintergrund
hatte, dem sein Auto genommen hat und auch dort in die Einkaufsstraße rein ist
und viele Menschen, auch Kinder, tot gefahren hat.
Einfach so, möchte man sagen. Dann spricht er darüber, dass Täter jetzt frei herumlaufen.
Also das klingt ja eher so, als würden wir, als seien Täter schon da,
die jetzt noch nicht gefasst wurden. Das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Täter vor der Tat. kann man nicht sein. Also sagt er, hier laufen also Leute rum.
Und damit meint er dann also alle, die irgendwie migrantisch aussehen könnten,
könnten ihre Kinder rauben oder töten oder sonst was.
Also das heißt, hier wird also ein Generalverdacht ausgesprochen.
Und dann drittens ist interessant, dass er sagt, sobald er Kanzler ist,
am ersten Tag wird er Grenzkontrollen einführen. Die sind ja da.
Ich war jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen in der Schweiz.
Da ist es noch mit dem Zug dann anders. Aber ich war dann in Luxemburg und in Belgien.
Belgien und dann jedes Mal, wenn man aus diesen Ländern wieder zurück nach Deutschland
will, wird man runtergebremst auf 20 kmh, dann stehen dort im Nieselregen ein paar Polizisten rum,
die gucken, wenn man dann so aussieht wie ich, dann kann man durchfahren und
ich sage mal, die haben fast alle durchgewunken, die können ja gar nicht jetzt
jedes einzelne Auto anhalten und da sind ja hunderte im Minutentakt, die da durchfahren, ja.
Die stehen also da, gucken kurz, naja und wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders
auffällig ist, wird man sowieso durchgewunken, wie will er eine solche...
Grenzkontrolle durchführen, wo er genau weiß, also allein Trier-Luxemburg,
halb Trier pendelt morgens um acht nach Luxemburg und kommt wieder dann zurück zum Feierabend.
Wie sollen diese Leute kontrolliert werden?
Zudem, wenn man sich diese Strecken ansieht, das ist Luxemburg-Trier,
ist sehr interessant, man fährt ja über eine Brücke dann, also über die Grenze,
dann über die Brücke und ist dann in Deutschland, dann fährt man an Wäldern
vorbei und irgendwann kommt dann diese Grenzkontrolle.
Wenn man jetzt irgendjemanden da rauswerfen wollte, müsste man also mitten auf
der Straße schon vorher alles blockieren,
damit man nicht vorher anhalten kann und jemand in den Wald flüchtet,
weil natürlich die erste Grenzkontrolle dann erst kommt oder die einzige Grenzkontrolle
dann erst kommt, wenn die erste Ausfahrt kommt.
Also das ist so irrsinnig, das durchzusetzen und zu glauben auch,
dass das jetzt irgendetwas ändert.
Also das ist ja eine interessante Idee, dass er eine Sicherheit verspricht,
wo man sich fragen kann, ist überhaupt eine Sicherheit möglich?
Ja, wir sind noch gar nicht hier bei diesen Anträgen und Koalitionen,
die sich dadurch ergeben.
Da kommen wir heute auch nicht hin.
Da kommen wir quasi, wir kommen da nicht hin, dass wir das jetzt nicht nochmal
alles wiederholen, aber wir können ja mal.
Das ist prüfungsrelevantes Vorwissen, das der Hörer selber mitbringen muss.
Aschaffenburg war der Fall, so, da ist also ein Afghane, der unter anderem ein
zweijähriges Kind töte.
Ja, ein Marokkaner. Also wenn man Afghaner sagt, muss man auch Marokkaner sagen.
Das Kind, ja. Also dann wäre ja schon da interessant, diese Generalisierung,
die da stattfindet, die ist ja schon mal eine grundsätzlich falsche.
Also wenn Mertens angegangen wäre mit, in Deutschland werden wieder Ausländer
getötet, das dulden wir hier nicht, was hätten wir dann gesagt?
Ich habe mal über diesen Fall so nachgedacht, weil zugleich eine Meldung kam,
dass es jetzt hier glaube ich sogar aus der Bild-Zeitung.
Und zwar gab es dann eine Meldung wenige Tage nach Aschaffenburg in Paraguay.
Ein 34 Jahre alter Deutscher soll nahe der Hauptstadt einen Mann im Rollstuhl
erschlagen haben, nackt und mit einem Ziegelstein.
Der Sohn deutscher Auswanderer lebte im selben Wohnviertel wie sein späteres Opfer.
Laut Bild soll er zur Zeit der Tat unter Drogeneinfluss gestanden haben.
Das würde auch erklären, weshalb die Verdächtigen danach blutverschmiert ihn
durch die Straße laufen sahen.
Freunde und Wegbegleiter attestierten dem 34-Jährigen ein ruhiges Wesen.
So Fälle gibt es offenbar. Ich will noch einen weiteren Fall bringen. Ein Fall aus England.
Da ist jemand, der heißt Dylan. Der hat seinen besten Freund mit 37 Stichen ermordet.
Hat seine Großmutter, seine Tante gebeten, nochmal ihn zur Wohnung zu fahren.
Er müsste mit dem Hund Gassi gehen und hat dann,
Und diesen besten Freund aus eigentlich unerfindlichen Gründen,
also er hat gesagt, weil der umziehen wollte, mit 37 Messerstichen erstochen.
Und hier auch interessant, weil wir jetzt die ganze Zeit diese Debatte haben,
warum hat man nicht schon vorher reagiert?
Auch hier ist was interessant, es gab Anzeichen, vor Gericht wurde bekannt,
dass er wenige Monate vor der Tat über einen 14 Meter hohen Zaun des Buckingham
Palastes geklettert war und einen Einbruch versuchte.
Außerdem soll er seinem späteren Opfer schon gesagt haben, dass er überlebt habe, um ihn zu töten.
Was wir also hier schon mal… Die Zäune.
Da sind 14 Meter hoch?
Ja, wohl an manchen Stellen, ja, und da kann man auch drüber klässern, offenbar.
Was ich jetzt hier mit diesen Fällen, und wir könnten jetzt hunderte solcher
Fälle natürlich anführen, was wir also sehen ist, diese absolute Sicherheit,
die da versprochen wird, ist ja erstmal eine völlige Illusion.
Und zweitens ist ja die Frage, wie geht man damit um, wenn Leute sehr deviant
sich verhalten, kann man sie dauerhaft so festnehmen,
dass sie nichts mehr anstellen.
Ich weiß zum Beispiel von einem Fall aus Rheinland-Pfalz, von jemand,
der hat Morddrohungen bekommen, von einer Person.
Auch die Familie wurde bedroht, inklusive Frau und Kinder.
Dieser Mensch, der diese Morddrohungen geschrieben hat, wurde irgendwann von
der Polizei festgenommen, auch hat Widerstand geleistet, war nach wenigen Wochen
aber dann aus der Untersuchungshaft wieder draußen, weil man nichts weiteres feststellen kann.
Wenn da jetzt irgendwann einmal etwas passieren wollte, Gott bewahre.
Dann würde man sagen, na seht ihr, warum hat man da nichts getan?
Und wir können jetzt ganz viel solcher Fälle sehen, da sind wir überhaupt gar
nicht bei einem Migrationsthema, sondern wir sind plötzlich bei einem ganz anderen Thema angelangt.
Warum das aber so charmant ist jetzt für Konservative und Rechte,
das mit Migration zu verbinden ist, dass man wirklich noch Politik simulieren kann.
Denn wenn ich mir die Wahlprogramme ansehe, ich habe jetzt alle durchgelesen,
dann fällt mir auf, bis auf wenige Ausnahmen, dass ja doch der Politik ziemlich
die Hände gebunden sind.
Ja, man ist in diesem Gefüge der Wirtschaftsstandort.
Der Wirtschaftsstandort bedeutet aber auch, naja, höhere Löhne können auch ein
Problem werden und so. Also das ist ja die Denkweise.
Und dann sind die Maßnahmen, die man zur Verbesserung des Lebens aller machen
kann, doch relativ beschränkt häufig.
Es sei denn, man wagt sich jetzt eine sehr linke, progressive Politik,
was aber die meisten nicht vorhaben.
Und eigentlich müsste in vielen Programmen stehen, also wir können ihnen eigentlich
nicht was maßgebliches anbieten.
Politikwechsel oder so, vergessen sie das. Das können die aber nicht da reinschreiben.
Und zugleich wissen die meisten Leute, die sich so empören über die in Berlin
und sonst was, dass eigentlich doch die Möglichkeiten relativ gering sind.
Und das Migrationsthema aber, beziehungsweise Migration und Sicherheitsthema,
wie Friedrich Merz das hier jetzt vorstellt und wie das dann von Alice Weidel
dankbar aufgegriffen wird, ist eines,
das man wunderbar mit vollem Engagement
vorstellen kann, ohne dass etwas passiert. Also ohne dass sich...
In dem Sinne die Sicherheitslage deutlich verbessert und es ist für die Leute,
die jetzt Merz toll finden, Alice Weidel toll finden und so weiter.
Wunderbar, weil man politisch engagiert sein kann, ohne sich engagieren zu müssen.
Man kann sich emotional voll reinlegen und so werden wir nochmal hier abgeholt.
Sie als Vater, Sie als Mutter, können Sie sich das vorstellen?
Ich kann es mir kaum vorstellen.
Also man kann sich richtig nochmal empören, wie kann das alles sein?
Behördenversagen etc. Und es gab ja auch Behördenversagen, das wollen wir ja
gar nicht hier leugnen. Aber man kann sich selbst emotional engagieren,
ohne sich wirklich in irgendeiner Weise politisch engagieren zu müssen.
Denn politisches Engagement würde ja zum Beispiel bedeuten, warum gibt es denn
so wenig Sprachkurse, warum gibt es denn so wenig Unterstützung für Menschen,
die nach Deutschland kommen,
warum unterstützt man nicht auch ganz andere Sachen noch, die politisch wert
wären, dass sich da Leute engagieren.
Das heißt, man kann eigentlich sagen, ich bin total politisch,
bin jetzt die ganze Zeit voll dabei und so ist ja auch diese Aufregung bei Twitter.
Alle sind auf 180, aber man muss gar nichts selbst tun.
Also ich muss nicht einen Schwimmverein leiten, ich muss nicht irgendeinen Kuchen
für die Schule backen, ich muss eigentlich nichts machen. Ich kann mich die
ganze Zeit moralisch empören, so tun, als sei ich wahnsinnig engagiert in der Sache.
Weiß aber, naja, also wenn irgendetwas dort maßgeblich geändert werden muss,
dann ist das irgendwie eine Grenzpolizei, irgendwas in Behörden.
Ich habe damit gar nichts zu tun.
Ja, jetzt sehen wir ja hier ein großes Durcheinander, das wir jetzt aufklären,
denn viele Leute fragen sich ja, was ist denn da los und vielleicht kann man
bei Merz einfach sagen, naja, Merz dachte halt, er spielt den Ball,
aber er wird halt gespielt.
Also Merz hat ja gar nicht den Ball, er ist wie Fußballspieler,
wo er immer hinterher rennt.
So, die Zweikämpfe funktionieren einfach nicht. Er hat keinen Ball,
er kriegt keinen Ball. Und er kommt dann mit zu Sprüchen, die er sich von Trump
anschaut, an Tag 1 und so weiter und so fort.
Gleichzeitig hat er aber vom Gefühl so eine Vorstandsfunktion.
Also er identifiziert so eine Art deutsches Volk, für das man handeln kann.
Wer sollte der? Der Bundeskanzler. Das macht ja schon der Name.
Ich werde ja vielleicht gleich Bundeskanzler. Also ich erzähle euch mal, ich kann handeln. Ja.
Und zieht aber so einen deutschen Rahmen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur aufs Volk
bezogen, sondern auch auf deutschen Strom.
Also wir hören ja immer Jens Spahn, der sich dann fragt, warum wird in Konstanz
Schweizer Strom verbraucht?
Weil wir in Deutschland nicht genug produzieren? Nee, weil das nächste deutsche
Stromkraftwerk ist halt einfach ein paar Kilometer weiter weg und es macht voll
Sinn, das nächstgelegte Stromding anzuzapfen.
Ja.
Ja, also lauter solche Sachen. Du hast es mit den Grenzen überschritten.
Ja, wir haben in Deutschland Gebiete, die sind,
Obwohl auf deutschem Boden viel mehr französisch und viel mehr niederländisch als sächsisch.
Ja.
Also diese deutsche Einheit, so gibt es gar nicht.
Und jetzt ist ja die Frage nicht so sehr, was ist jetzt konkret passiert,
sondern warum sind alle so aufgeregt? Und zwar auch im Publikum.
Also ich meine jetzt auch Hörer der Nachrichten, die dann völlig zu Recht auf
Instagram nochmal schildern, der 29.
Januar wird in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen und so weiter und so fort.
Und das spielt natürlich alles vor so einer Kulisse, Holocaust-Gedenken,
deutsche Geschichte und so weiter statt, kann da problematisiert werden,
wir werden die großen Demos sehen.
Heute im Bundestag geht es ja auch wieder zur Sache, ist quasi der nächste Aufhänger,
Anlass, sich solche Fragen zu stellen.
Nur bei Friedrich Merz ist ja hier so ein implizites Denken dabei,
das ja nicht ausformulieren, weil ausformulieren kann man ja erstmal vieles,
so wie ich eben schon ansprach, das Opfer war ein Marokkaner.
Da könnte man jetzt die ganzen sich neu rechts fühlenden Menschen,
die sich so sehr um die deutsche Seele kümmern, fragen, wie viele deutsche Ressourcen
soll denn der deutsche Staat aufbringen, um Marokkaner in Deutschland zu schützen?
Also diese Argumentation führt ja nirgendwo hin, aus deren Sicht.
Während ich mir denke, ja klar, schützen wir ja auch zweijährige Marokkaner,
ist doch egal, was das für Leute sind.
Wir brauchen sie später in unserem Erwerbspersonen-Potenzial,
ja. Klingt jetzt auch sehr radikal, aber das ist halt Win-Win,
das ist für den Zögling gut und für die Gesellschaft, in der er lebt.
So, also in der Sicht, da gibt es ganz viele offene Fragen, die man sich klären kann.
Und wir machen das, indem wir jetzt ins politische Vorfeld gehen.
Also wir gucken jetzt gleich ganz viel Hoss und Hopf, hören Hoss und Hopf.
Und schauen uns nochmal an, wie auch im deutschen Nachrichten-Mainstream also
die FAZ-Redakteure und Leute von der Ludwig Erhard, vom Ludwig Erhard Forum so über Millet denken,
was wir jetzt so in die Richtung machen und was in Österreich passiert,
ja, also wir umzirkeln jetzt sozusagen, weil wir ja alle die O-Töne kennen.
Ich will nur zum Einstieg, weil du jetzt hier den März so gespielt hast,
es gibt noch einen O-Ton von Söder, den kann man ja nochmal spielen.
Söder ist in der Stimmlage kaum wiederzuerkennen.
Also ich dachte so beim Hören, das soll Söder sein, ich springe nochmal zurück,
ah ja, der Nachrichtenmann sagt, jetzt hören wir Markus Söder.
Also es gibt eine Andacht, Aschaffenburg liegt in Bayern, Markus Söder muss
sich darum kümmern, Ländergerangel, Bund, wer ist jetzt dafür zuständig,
dass hier keine zweijährigen Marokkaner getötet werden?
Inhaltlich, sobald die Diskussion den Horizont übersteigt, kann man sie nicht aufklären.
Also wie sollte eine adäquate Politik aussehen, die sagt, wir wollen nur die richtigen Ausländer.
Das heißt, wir schieben alle ab, außer die Ärzte. Die brauchen wir.
Dann fährt aber genauso ein Arzt ausgerechnet auf den Weihnachtsmarkt und tötet dort Leute.
Es macht ja keinen Sinn. Daraus kann man keine programmatische Politik ableiten,
die irgendeinem Gefühl entspricht, das heute vermutet wird in einem Publikum, das man gar nicht kennt.
Das sagt er ja.
Das Merz glaubt, hier ansprechen zu können.
Er sagt ja sogar, dass sie sich sicher fühlen. Nicht, dass sie sicher sind,
sondern sie sollen sich sicher fühlen. Und da denke ich mir ja viel.
So, jetzt hören wir mal kurz Söder, der auch weiß, hinter dem Horizont politische
Programme, irgendwas Großes, Abstraktes, was irgendwann mal im Bundestag vielleicht,
wenn der Referentenentwurf hinhaut, in einem Jahr mal Gesetz wird und in drei
Jahren stellen wir fest,
das Gesetz war gut, Umsetzung schlecht oder wie auch immer. Also alles Minen fällt.
Versucht Söder eben auch diesen Appell an die Gefühle und ganz nah dran.
Und ich finde das einfach absurd.
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder sprach in seiner Rede den Angehörigen sein Beileid aus.
Das Gute und das Böse sind keine Frage von Herkunft, Nationalität, Ethnie oder Glauben.
Alle Kinder in Bayern sind unsere Kinder. Und alle Kinder dieser Welt haben Schutz verdient.
Alle Kinder der Welt haben Liebe verdient. Und deswegen darf diese Tat nicht
dazu führen, dass Hass von einigen unsere gesamte Gesellschaft erfasst.
Ja, dann erkennt ihr nicht wieder. Was ist denn da los?
Politiker, also Merz hat es noch deutlicher gemacht, also expliziter.
Liebe Menschen, ein Kind ist gestorben. Ich sage Ihnen jetzt,
wie Sie das fühlen müssen.
Offenbar sind Sie zu gar nichts in der Lage. Wir müssen Ihnen schon die Politik
und den Strom liefern. und jetzt muss ich ihnen auch noch sagen, wie sie fühlen sollen.
Wir denken so, nee, Herr Merz, wir können selber fühlen und wissen Sie was,
Herr Merz, ich habe gar keine Kinder und ich kann es trotzdem fühlen.
So, ich bin die Tante, die kinderlos geblieben ist, aber ich habe auch Kinder
in meinem Leben. Irgendwie so, ja.
Also es ist völlig absurd. So, wir steigen jetzt hier also mal ein und wollen erstmal...
Aber lass mich ein Wort noch dazu sagen, es ist ja ganz interessant,
dass Söder hier verspricht, dass es nicht Hass und Hetze geben soll und genau
das aber dann zur CDU-Programmatik wird.
Denn man kann ja jetzt deutlich sagen, dass wer jetzt die CDU wählt,
schon mal eine Stimme mit abgibt für die AfD.
Ja, genau. Das ist die einzige Koalitionsoption, die er hat.
Ja, ich glaube noch nicht unbedingt daran, dass er eine Koalition mit der AfD macht.
Denn Franziska Brandner von den Grünen war sich ja nicht so schade,
gestern nochmal zu betonen, dass sie so offen ist für eine Koalition mit Friedrich Merz.
Aber wir sehen hier ganz klar, jede Stimme, die dahin geht zur CDU,
zählt schon ein auf eine mögliche Koalition.
Dann, auch wenn sie erst 2029 meinetwegen stattfindet, aber zumindest wird man.
Häufiger insofern koalieren, dass man sich bei Anträgen derart verhält,
wie man das jetzt getan hat und sagt,
naja, wir haben jetzt folgende Idee, wenn die AfD da mitmacht und um das nochmal
ganz deutlich zu sagen, weil das auch mal so gesagt wird, ja,
aber irgendwo haben die da mal mitgestimmt, es ist ja ein Antrag,
den Friedrich Merz inhaltlich eingebracht hat, der auch AfD-Inhalt ist.
Es ging ja nicht über einen Antrag um Hochwasser-Auffangbecken,
wo man sagte, naja gut, Hochwasser ist Hochwasser oder sowas,
sondern es war ein Antrag, der inhaltlich deckungsgleich ist.
Das zentrale Thema der AfD. Das Thema, ja.
Und deswegen ist es so absurd, das zu sehen. Und auch nochmal diese interessante
Sache ist ja, warum hyperventilieren bei Aschaffenburg die Leute mehr als bei anderen Taten?
Also ich habe hier, ist ja auch aus demselben Monat noch eine Geschichte.
Am gestrigen Abend gegen 19.30 Uhr kam es in einer Wohnung in Eisenach zu einem Tötungsdelikt.
Hier wurde eine 35-jährige Frau durch massive Gewalt so schwer verletzt,
dass sie in der Nacht starb.
Eine 20-jährige Frau wurde ebenfalls schwer verletzt und in die Klinik eingewiesen.
Die Ermittlungen richten sich gegen einen 37-jährigen Deutschen.
Warum funktioniert das eine? Also Femizide oder so etwas, das geschieht halt
in Deutschland, kommt in den besten Haushalten vor, so nach dem Motto.
Und hier aber Aschaffenburg interessiert so viel mehr.
Warum ist das so? Nun, man sagt natürlich sich, also die,
Die Unterscheidung, die man dann bereit ist zu machen, wir und sie,
also die Morde, die hier stattfinden von unseren Leuten, das ist halt das Normale.
Das ist so wie, naja, es kommt halt vor. Das klären wir unter uns. Es kommt halt vor.
Aber das andere wäre nicht vorgekommen, wenn die nicht hier hingekommen wären.
Was dann aber nur im Umkehrschuss bedeuten kann, da muss man die Grenzen grundsätzlich
für alle dicht machen, nie mehr irgendjemand reinlassen.
Dann hat man nur noch die eigenen Morde zu ermitteln und keine anderen mehr.
Und dieser Wahnsinn, der da drin steckt, zeigt sich ja dann eben besonders darin,
dass natürlich von diesen terroristischen Anschlägen oder Amoknusschägen oder
wie man es auch immer nennen will,
natürlich auch die hier längst Zugewanderten und hier Lebenden gleichermaßen
betroffen sind und gleichermaßen dann mit dem Messer verletzt oder getötet werden.
Und wenn man aber es schafft, wie das Friedrich Merz und Jens Spahn tun,
diese Wir-und-Sie-Unterscheidung wieder so stark zu machen, sagt man sich plötzlich,
naja, das ist also etwas, was nur eine Frage von Import ist.
Hätten wir das nicht, dann hätten wir es nicht.
Und da wäre ja interessant nach einem anderen Ansatz zu fragen,
nämlich wie könnte man tatsächlich etwas verhindern.
Und das ist ja schon doch interessant, dass wir es hier bei diesem Fall in Aschaffenburg
mit einem Afghanen zu tun haben, der ja noch gar nicht so lange in Deutschland war.
Jetzt wissen wir, was in Afghanistan war. Ja, der Westen hat dieses Land in
Schutt und Asche gebombt, hat dann gesagt, nach vielen, vielen Jahren,
nachdem schon vor zehn Jahren Margot Käßmann sagte, hier läuft alles schief
in Afghanistan, wurde dafür ausgeschimpft und so,
hat man dann doch gesagt, wir machen
jetzt den Rückzug und zwar nicht den Geordneten, sondern wir flüchten.
Und hat also Leute mehrmals traumatisiert.
Nimmt dann Leute auch von Afghanistan auf und kümmert sich nicht entsprechend um sie.
Also wir sehen ja hier, dass in relativ normalen Verhältnissen solch abscheuliche
Taten möglich sind, dass Leute solche Psychosen oder was auch immer entwickeln,
dass sie zu bestialischen Mördern werden.
Und dann haben wir Leute, die stark traumatisiert und so, die überhaupt keine Unterstützung haben.
Und dann wundert man sich, dass da jetzt so etwas passiert ist.
Ja, wobei zu diesem ultranationalen Ethnopluralismus schon gehört,
wir wären ja nie nach Afghanistan gegangen, was haben wir uns da eingemischt und so.
Genau, das ist dann das, was so aus dem Kubitschek-Kreis oder so kommen würde.
Also das wird dann schon nachher.
Aber Friedrich Merz ist ja jemand, der wäre wahrscheinlich noch mit in den Irak aufmarscht.
Ja, das ist eben das Interessante, dass Friedrich Merz ein Globalist ist,
Der gerne mit Blackrock und deutschen Personalausweis überall auf der Welt machen
möchte, was er will, aber wehe in Aschaffenburg und so weiter.
Also das ist alles verlogen und wir dröseln das jetzt mal auf,
denn es gibt ja ganz viele Ungereimtheiten.
Es gibt einen Hitlergruß, der nur so, war es wirklich ein Hitlergruß?
Also klares Bekenntnis sozusagen von Musk, dann gibt es aber von Weidel dieses,
Hitler war ja gar keiner von uns, das war ja ein Linker und so.
Dem gehen wir mal nach und zwar im O-Ton, wie es gesagt wurde.
Zum einen Joshua Topolsky, also in dem Fall jetzt ein Amerikaner, kein Deutscher.
Also er kommt jetzt nicht, ja, er ist jüdischer Atheist, also seine Familie
hat schon jüdische Geschichte, aber es ist jetzt sozusagen amerikanisches,
ich will hier irgendwelche Nachrichtenseiten,
ich spiele gerne im Internet rum, wie auch immer. Und er sieht Elon Musk auf der Bühne.
Wenn ich es, wenn ich es, zu mir, es ist die meisten offensivität, hands down.
Ich habe gesehen oder heard von Elon Musk in der entirety von his Das ist disgusting.
Also Elon Musk ist nicht erst seit gestern bekannt,
aber dass ein Hitlergruß zeigt, ist von allem, was man bisher von ihm gesehen hat, das.
Abscheulichste, und zwar in dem Moment, in dem er der reichste Mann der Welt
ist und den mächtigsten Mann der Welt zur Gratulationsparty geht,
um zu sagen, hier, my heart goes out to weil ihr habt ihn gewählt.
So, und das muss man auch genau so, also man kann jetzt nicht mit einer Analyse
beginnen, bei der man dahinter zurückgeht.
Wir können es jetzt nicht auf
Weltspielereien einlassen, war es nur ein Hitlergruß oder wie auch immer.
Lenz Jakobsen hat in der Zeit geschrieben, ein Hitlergruß ist ein Hitlergruß
ist ein Hitlergruß. Das nehmen wir jetzt als gegeben.
Elon Musk, wir kennen ja alle diese Videos, wie er so mit Herzchengeste und
so über die Bühnen rennt und die Leute dann drunter schreiben,
er kennt doch den Unterschied.
Also er weiß genau, was ein Hitlergruß ist. Und wenn sich einer mit Hitler befasst
hat, dann ja wohl Elon Musk mit,
wird jetzt auch interessant, so langsam kommen ja da die Interessen,
also wenn diese Leute jetzt meinen, sie müssten nicht mehr im Hintergrund leben
und die Strüppen ziehen, indem sie irgendwelche Millionäre in den Kongress schicken,
sondern selber Staatsangestellte werden, interessiert man sich natürlich auch
für die Biografie und wenn jemand in Südafrika aufwächst als Sohn eines Apartheid-Profiteurs,
dann vererbt sich halt ein Menschenbild,
das dann irgendwann aktualisiert wird, wenn nur noch Speichellecker und Bittsteller
um einen rumgaukeln die ganze Zeit.
Das Zentrum für politische Schönheit hat ja eine Aktion gemacht in Brandenburg
an dem Tesla-Werk, das hier im Podcast Haken dran nochmal pointiert aufgegriffen wird,
denn es muss ja gar nicht unsere Privatmeinung sein, dass das nur ein eindeutiger Hitlergruß war.
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass der deutsche Staatsschutz das sagt.
Wir haben über die Aktion des Zentrums für politische Schönheit gesprochen,
die nach eigener Angabe eine Projektion des maschischen Hitlergrußes auf die
Gigafactory in Brandenburg geworfen haben.
Daraufhin hat die Polizei zunächst, das war der Stand bei der Aufzeichnung,
gemeldet, es gibt keine Hinweise darauf, dass es echt war, sondern hat wohl
Hinweise darauf eher, dass es eine Fotomontage ist.
Und kurz nach der Aufzeichnung hat dann der Staatsschutz angefangen zu ermitteln,
weil eben diese Projektion wohl doch echt gewesen sei.
Es auch Fotos der Projektoren gibt auf dieses Werk in Grünheide.
Und das Interessante ist aber, dass erst durch diese Ermittlungen des Staatsschutzes
jetzt eigentlich, finde ich, die Aktion überhaupt einen Sinn bekommt.
Weil der Sinn nun ist, also abgesehen davon, dass du Aufmerksamkeit für dieses
Thema generierst, wo Thorsten auch meinte, ja, aber belehrt das Menschen, wir wissen es nicht.
Der Sinn der Aktion ist aber jetzt, wenn der Staatsschutz feststellt,
dass die Projektion dieses Bildes das Darstellen eines verfassungswidrigen Symbols war,
dann haben wir schwarz auf weiß, dass nach deutscher Rechtsprechung diese Geste
von Elon Musk tatsächlich ein Hitlergruß war.
Und das halte ich für einen fantastischen Move.
Ja, das ist doch witzig, oder?
Ja.
Also das ist wirklich sehr gut. Wir haben hier also eine Ausgangslage,
die sagt, nein, alle Fragen, die wir uns jetzt stellen, sind genauso ernst zu
nehmen wie Elon Musk Hitler Gruß.
Wir können jetzt nicht einfach nur wischiwaschi, ja, okay, hat er uns getrollt
oder sowas, sondern nein, es war ein klares Bekenntnis zu einer Ideologie und
wir fragen uns, aber welche denn?
Also jeder, der, klar, den Holocaust muss man schon leugnen,
um ihn sozusagen abzuschwächen.
Jeder, der das anerkennt, sechs Millionen Tote, wie stelle ich sicher,
dass ich es nicht bin, sondern dass sechs Millionen der anderen getötet werden?
Also da tritt man ja auch eine Ideologie los, die am Ende vielleicht einen selber
so ein bisschen in den Arsch tritt.
Was besonders interessant ist, weil wir mit Hoss und Hopf Leute haben,
die diese Ideologie, wie wir gleich hören werden, propagieren,
aber gar nichts mit Deutschland zu tun haben. Der eine lebt in der Schweiz und der andere in Dubai.
Und die ganze Zeit kümmern sie sich um ihr geliebtes Deutschland,
das aber total zu verhassen ist. Ja.
Und wir haben eben Alice Weidel, die als lesbische Frau in der Schweiz lebt
und in Deutschland einen Bundestagswahlkampf anführt mit diesem Ultranationalismus
oder diesen neuen Formen von Rechtsradikalität.
Nichts davon passt zusammen.
Insbesondere nicht, dass Alice Weidel im Gespräch mit Elon Musk plötzlich über Hitler redet.
Wir hören jetzt, wie Ronsheimer und sein Kollege in dem Ronsheimer-Podcast sich
diese Frage stellen, die sie sich nicht beantworten können.
Wir dann aber schon. Also wir nehmen uns das dann mal vor.
Ja, aber genauso verrückt finde ich, wenn sie einfach während des Gesprächs
plötzlich darauf kommt. Also warum?
Also sie war jetzt vorher auch
nicht irgendwie so. Also das macht für mich mindestens genauso wenig Sinn.
Hast du eine Erklärung dafür? Also was bringt ihr das, das in dem Moment anzusprechen?
Ich kann es mir auch nicht richtig erklären. Ich glaube, dass die Menschen in
Deutschland, die Adolf Hitler für einen Linken halten,
Also die gibt es. Die wählen aber eh schon längst AfD. Ganz genau. Die wählen eh schon AfD.
Und vor allem ist die NPD und was es alles gab.
Genau. Also die wählen jetzt AfD oder noch rechtsextremere Parteien.
Und das bekommt immer sowas Schmuddeliges in Deutschland. Ich habe mir nur gedacht, mein Gott.
Komisch. Ja, aber ich denke, jetzt spricht die AfD-Chefin mit dem Gründer von
Tesla und dem Eigentümer von X und dem Gründer von SpaceX und kann jetzt mal so die,
Frau von Welt geben und dann kommt sie mit so einer Hitler-Theorie daher.
Ich kann es mir nicht erklären, aber ich glaube, das dürfte ihr nicht nutzen.
So, eine anfängliche Erklärung von vielen, wenn man nur aufs mediale Geschehen schaut.
Wir haben einen Bundestagswahlkampf, in dem verschiedene Parteien,
manche labeln sich als demokratisch und dann wird eine als nicht demokratisch gelabelt, die AfD.
So, die unterscheiden sich aber nicht nur in dieser ideologischen Ausrichtung,
sondern auch in ihrem medialen Verhalten.
Während nämlich alle demokratischen Parteien anfangen Plakate zu drucken,
auf denen dann irgendwie steht, die Rente, die Wehrpflicht, was auch immer,
jeder hat so ein programmatisches Ding und da sitzt man einfach im Hinterstiebchen
und macht so eine Strategieplanung und sagt…,
Wir könnten noch hier in diese Richtung gehen und dann hoffen,
dass dieses Laufpublikum darauf anspringt und wir die damit überzeugen. Was auch immer.
Und dann hast du so verschiedene Versuche, wie Jens Spahn, der auf der Bühne
vor alten Leuten sagt, ich kümmere mich darum, dass sie alle eine Pflegekraft haben.
Ich war erst gestern als Gesundheitsminister in Bangladesch in so einer Schule,
wo die alle schon Deutsch sprechen. Ich habe die alle eingeladen.
Gleichzeitig wird auf Facebook für das junge Publikum hart abgehatet.
Also der ist sozusagen ideologisch nicht ganz gefestigt, weil er auf der Suche
nach Laufpublikum ist, dass er mit so Wahlkampftricks, ich verschweige den so
ein bisschen und so, da irgendwie einzufangen.
Das machen alle Parteien so und die AfD macht es ganz anders.
Der AfD-Publikum ist das Laufpublikum egal, weil sie wissen,
Alice Weidel überzeugt niemals Egon, der die Straße runter geht mit irgend so einem Spruch.
Aber Alice Weidel überzeugt eben Philipp Hopf.
So, und Philipp Hopf übernimmt dann die Aufgabe, in alle zwei Tage einen Podcast
den Egon zu überzeugen, da in die Wahl einzusteigen.
Also es geht sozusagen, das kennen wir ja auch als Podcastgeschäft.
Die ARD macht eine Tagesthemen-Sendung, wo sie möglichst alles abdecken will.
Und wir sagen einfach, wir bedienen hier einen harten Kern.
Kann sein, dass immer mal jemand reinkommt und denkt, ah, fünf Stunden sind
doch gar nicht so schlecht, ich bleibe mal dran, aber wir senden hier für einen harten Kern.
Wir machen hier Podcasts für Leute, die wir einfach sagen können,
wir hatten doch vor drei Jahren in diesem Buch hinter der Paywall darüber gesprochen
und alle sagen, ja genau, stimmt.
Und wir denken uns, ja genau, also darüber reden wir jetzt. Wir machen jetzt
keine Oma-Erna-Moderation zum nächsten Thema und versuchen es möglichst amüsant zu machen.
Das ist Maria Tasslomkas Aufgabe. Das ist Olaf Scholz' Aufgabe,
das ist Robert Habecks Aufgabe, alle nochmal so und so weiter. Alice Weidel anders.
Da wird ein harter Kern einfach immer fester geschmiedet, in der Hoffnung,
dass Wärme sich ausbreitet. Und es funktioniert ja auch, das sehen wir ja.
Und es gab ja dann auch aus dem, sagen wir, eher gemäßigten konservativen Lager
oder rechten Lager Stimmen, die sagten,
naja, so ganz falsch ist es ja nicht, also Hitler war ja schon auch in dem Sinne
Sozialist und dann gibt es ja gleich so eine Argumentation,
es zieht sich ja durch bis hin zu irgendwelchen Zentren für liberale Moderne
und wie die sich alle nennen, die dann immer sagen, naja,
also die Nazis waren eigentlich schon auch sozialistisch.
Das heißt, das ist ja eine Debatte, die sicherlich in dieser Zugespitzzeit sich
die meisten verbieten würden,
aber die durchaus in gewissen Kreisen gern gesehen ist, nämlich in Kreisen,
die sehr stark gegen alles Linke gerichtet sind.
Und im Übrigen auch häufiger gegen Russland.
Also das ist ja auch interessant, dass man sagt, ja Hitler hatte ja auch die
Bolschewiki da, also das ist ja quasi diese Ernst-Nolte-These,
die dann da zum Teil weitergesponnen wird.
Also man hat hier tatsächlich so etwas, das in dieser Zugespitzzeit selten zu
hören ist, was aber durchaus bei vielen diskursfähig ist.
Hitler als einen Politiker zu bezeichnen, der sozialistische Ziele verfolgt hat.
Das ist eine rechte Strategie schon länger.
Das ist jetzt nicht was Neues bei Alice Weide. Deswegen finde ich es gar nicht
so obskur, dass das dort stattgefunden hat.
Wir müssen aber kurz eine Exkursion machen.
Du hast jetzt wieder von Egon und sogar von Oma Erna gesprochen.
Es gab Zuschriften, in denen sich Menschen beschwert haben, dass du über Oma Erna immer lässt.
Wo kommt der Begriff Oma Erna her?
Also das ZDF, das zweite deutsche Fernsehen.
Macht natürlich Analysen, statistische Erhebung über das eigene Publikum.
Weshalb der große Nachrichtensprecher Klaus Kleber damals bei seiner Antrittsvorlesung
in Tübingen, wo er so einen Lehrstuhl für irgendwas, keine Ahnung,
Sie sind berühmt, machen Sie doch hier mal ein paar Abendveranstaltungen,
sagte, dass am schnellsten wachsende Publikum sind die 60-Jährigen.
Und wir hören ja heute Elmar Falani mit seinem Sammelband über die Kinderrechte.
Wir haben doppelt so viele 60-jährige Geburtstärke wie, und da können wir sie
nehmen, zwischen null und volljährig.
Also wir haben es mit einer relevanten, großen Gruppe zu tun,
bei der wir immer denken, hä, wo sind denn die?
Also auf Twitter, auf Instagram, ich sehe immer nur junge Leute im Fernsehen,
klar, jetzt Friedrich Merz ist diese Altersgruppe, aber so Robert Habeck,
Annalena Baerbock, diese ganzen CDU-Nachwirken, wo sind diese 60-Jährigen?
So und dann stellte sich raus, das sind ganz stille Leute, die einfach Nachrichten
gucken und zwar 60-jährige Frauen.
Also wenn sich das ZDF auf einen was verlassen kann, dann diese Altersklasse 60 bis 80 weiblich. So.
Nicht nur, weil die alle zuschauen, sondern weil die, anders als die Männer,
auch noch das alles annehmen, abhaken und geruhsam ins Bett gehen,
statt wie Egon, der eben erreichbar ist, sich abends denken...
Ich denke da jetzt nochmal selbst drüber nach.
Genau. Ich gucke nochmal nach im Internet. Was ist denn da Sachlage?
Also in der Fall, es ist Oma Erna.
Das CDF sendet für Oma Erna, weil Oma Erna einfach treu ist.
Und der Begriff wurde auch von denen so verwendet?
Ja, es ist Elmar Thewissen. Der zum einen sagte, die Leute fahren Slalom um die Nachrichten.
Und wir haben jetzt diese Podcast-Auswertung von Bloomberg bekommen.
Diese neuen Podcasts, die die da beobachten, 2000 Stunden lang, 1300 Videos.
Oder umgedreht, 1300 Stunden von 2000 Videos, ist auch egal.
Die reden nicht nur über Politik.
Nein, nein.
Aber wenn sie über Politik reden, doppelte Einschaltskosten.
Also 20 Prozent der Gäste sind politisch, aber 30 Prozent des Eyeball-Kontexts
läuft über diese Themen.
Das bedeutet, eigentlich sind wir hochpolitisiert. Nur, die alten Nachrichten
kriegen es nicht hin. Warum? Weil sie Oma Erna-Programm machen.
Und dieser Begriff Oma Erna ist da ein fester Begriff?
Das ist Elmativis selber. Also Elmar Thewissen hat selber schon mehrfach von Oma Erna gesprochen.
Und das ist auch gar nicht so ungewöhnlich. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel auch für
Zeitungen solche Lesewertanalysen, wer liest welche Seite wie lang und dann
bekommen zum Teil auch die Redaktionen den Idealleser vorgestellt.
Dann bekommt beispielsweise eine Kulturredaktion gesagt, dein Durchschnittsleser
ist weiblich und heißt Saskia.
Schreib die Artikel für Saskia. Die Sportabteilung bekommt gesagt,
dein Leser heißt Matthias, ist 37 Jahre alt,
will am liebsten was zum Fußball und noch Handball, aber auf keinen Fall dies.
So und das ist durchaus üblich in solchen Analysen, dass dann so ein Name,
der sinnbildlich für etwas steht, weil natürlich die meisten 19-Jährigen eher nicht Erna heißen.
Ja, wir haben selbst schon Ernas geschrieben, die meinten, ich gehöre aber nicht
dazu, ich bin das nicht angesprochen und ich denke mir, du bist ja auch nicht
Oma Erna, nur weil du Erna heißt. Also Erna ist nur das Label für diese Oma
Erna und nicht der Name. Gut, zurück zum Kern.
Also die AfD kümmert sich um einen Kern, den schmiedet sie, der ist aus Stahl,
der soll fest sein, der soll Jahrtausende
überdauern, es geht hier um die Schaffung eines großen Reiches.
Problem ist nur, der Rechtsradikalismus wurde diskreditiert durch so ein Vogelschiss.
Holocaust, Shoah, Drittes Reich.
Das meinen wir jetzt hier alles in Anführungszeichen. Das ist für die Leute ein Problem.
Dass nachher jemand klippt und sagt, der Stefan Schulz verbreitet war oder es
wird verbreitet und mir dann in die Schuhe geschoben, dass ich es gesagt habe.
Wir kennen das so ein bisschen aus unserer Richtung. Also du bist ein großer Karl-Marx-Leser.
Ja.
So, und dann kommt aber einer, aber der Marxismus, Wolfgang,
der Marxismus, was hat der Stalin gemacht?
Und du denkst dir, ja, ist schon ein bisschen diskreditiert,
aber deswegen ist doch noch lange kein Grund, jetzt Marx nicht zu lesen.
Und so, die haben jetzt keine Ausgangsquelle.
Die haben ja keine Theorie. Aber was sie ja machen müssen ist ja,
das rechte Gedankengut retten und versuchen von Hitler selbst loszulösen.
Und deswegen muss auch Elon Musk nochmal bei dieser Veranstaltung sagen,
ja, lasst euch da mal von eurer deutschen Schuld und so nicht zu sehr auf den Wecker fallen.
Ihr seid schon mit eurem rechten Weg auf dem wirklich richtigen Weg.
Sechs Millionen Tote waren Ausrutscher. Ja, so wird das gekonnt.
Also mehr im Sinne von, eigentlich wollen wir doch anderes, besseres,
wie auch immer. So, wir hören das hier mal von Jens Christian Wagner.
Er ist der Leiter der Gedenkstätten Buchenwald, der im Deutschlandfunk zugeschaltet war.
Tatsächlich ist der Rechtsextremismus in Deutschland ja durch die nationalsozialistischen Verbrechen,
Und wenn Rechtsextreme wie die AfD mehrheitsfähig in Deutschland werden wollen,
dann müssen sie versuchen, sich vom Makel der NS-Verbrechen gewissermaßen zu befreien.
Und dann wird Hitler zum Kommunisten? Das rechte Denken zu entkriminalisieren
und dann redet man entweder wie Gauland davon,
dass die nationalsozialistischen Verbrechen ja nur ein Vogelschiss in der deutschen
Geschichte gewesen seien oder man fordert wie Höcke eine erinnerungspolitische
Wende um 180 Grad oder, Sie haben recht,
man behauptet völlig krude wie Frau Weidel, Hitler sei ja in Wirklichkeit ein Kommunist gewesen.
Das ist natürlich vollkommen lächerlich und unfug, aber etwas,
wenn es nur häufig genug wiederholt wird, was Menschen auch glauben.
Und sie glauben gar nicht, wie häufig entsprechende Kommentare wir unter unseren
Posts in den Social Media finden.
Also das ist tatsächlich ein Mythos mit den linken Nazis, der mittlerweile weit
um sich greift, wie auch andere geschichtskriministische Mythen sich viral verbreiten,
insbesondere natürlich durch die Möglichkeiten des Internets.
Sehr richtig, es geht ja sogar so weit zum Teil, dass in rechtsradikalen Gruppierungen,
es heißt, die Nazis waren nicht das Problem, sondern Hitler.
Warum war Hitler das Problem? Deren Analyse ist dann, ja weil Hitler eigentlich
ja ein Akteur des internationalen Kapitals,
also selbst eigentlich jüdisch infiltriert war und nur Deutschland okkupiert
hat für seine Zwecke und hat deshalb alles in den Untergang geführt.
Also diese Loslösung von Hitler,
um gleich noch sogar die Nazis dadurch freizusprechen, ist auch eine,
die bislang natürlich in ganz marginalen Gruppen präsent war,
die aber jetzt von Alice Weidel auf die große Bühne gehoben wird und dann wird
es dankbar aufgegriffen von anderen.
Also da kann man schon mal drauf achten, es gab jetzt ein wirklich wahnsinnig
interessantes, aber eigentlich kaum klippbares Gespräch, wir hören trotzdem gleich Clips,
Gespräch von Ezra Klein mit James Pogue, der selber knapp unter 40 für den New
York Times Opinion-Seite schreibt und der J.D.
Vance schon begleitet hat, als der damals noch Kongressabgeordneter werden wollte,
also 2016, 17, 18 ist er auf diese Partys mitgegangen und so.
Und da, die haben so eine Theorie vom Regime.
20 Prozent der Gesellschaft ist so eine Gemengelage aus Eliten,
Geld, Politik, akademisches Zeug und so weiter.
Die bringen ihre Kinder immer nach Harvard, die werden danach immer Kongressabgeordnete
und die werden immer Milliardäre.
Und gegen die wird hart gearbeitet.
Die Kathedrale, so nennen die das.
Die Kathedrale, das Regime, wie auch immer, da gibt es verschiedene Begriffe
und jetzt wird das ja ausgelebt.
Also Jane Evans ist ja angetreten umgegen dieses Regime und stellt jetzt fest,
Er ist ja selber von Milliardären umgeben in diesem Kabinett.
Also da sind ja im Dunstkreis jetzt irgendwie 26 Milliardäre,
die so mit echten Tätigkeiten für die Regierung da aufwarten und so.
Was ja bedeutet, ah ja, jetzt passiert ja genau dasselbe wie damals,
als es schon mal hieß, wir haben hier eine echte Ideologie, wir wollen die Deutschen
befreien von was auch immer.
Aber dann kam dieser Hitler und hat mit Milliardären zusammengearbeitet. So.
Nach einer Woche schon, ja, ist das die so langsam aufkommende Kritik in Amerika, dass man dachte,
hey, ihr räumt doch die Milliardäre ab und jetzt noch nie so viele Milliardäre
wie, ja, also die stolpern gerade in dasselbe Hitler 2.0 Problem rein,
aus dieser Beobachtung von außen, dass sich der Einzelkämpfer,
der zu Hause sitzt und dachte, endlich hab ich jemanden, der gegen die Macht,
gegen das Geld, gegen die akademische Prominenz und so weiter antritt.
Und jetzt stelle ich fest, nee, noch nie so viel Macht und Geld bei meinen Leuten,
die ich gerade noch gewählt habe.
Noch nie war es so richtig von Oligarchie zu sprechen.
Genau, und so ist es ja mit Weidel auch, also solange sie noch so Hardcore-Oppositionen
macht, alles vor sich her treibt,
ist jedem egal, dass sie von Goldman 6 kommt und eigentlich in der Schweiz lebt und der ganze Kram, ja,
aber das ist sozusagen, sie ist jetzt schon Hitler 2.0, also sie kann so gar
nicht die Macht ergreifen oder übernehmen oder man kann es ihr gar nicht so
geben, weil sie sofort wieder diese Falle reinstoppert. Das.
Ja, oder man, ich bin da mir ja gar nicht mehr so sicher, also ob das nicht
jetzt Leute auch in einer anderen Weise toll finden, denn es gibt natürlich
da vielleicht von eigenen Leuten bei Republikanern auch Kritik,
was ich aber beobachte ist,
dass es gerade bei diesen Kryptopros, den rechten Kryptopros,
will nicht alle über einen Kamm scheren und bei vielen anderen dieser Leute
eine so hohe Identifizierung mit den Superreichen gibt,
als seien sie es selbst schon, Als könnten sie dadurch auch ihren Reichtum manifestieren,
dass sie sagen, ja ich will beherrscht werden von Superreichen,
nur bitte andere Superreiche als die, die einer beiden Administration gedient haben.
Das heißt, man hat es da wirklich mit dem autoritären Charakter,
da ist das absolut richtig, was Theodor Adorno sagte, zu tun.
Also Leute, die es lieben, in dieser Weise beherrscht zu werden,
nämlich von diesen Strongman, von einer Alice Weidel, die Gift und Galle spuckt
auf der Bühne, die richtig herrschsüchtig ist.
Dass einem diese Art des Beherrschtwerdens offenbar lieber ist,
als ein Beherrschtwerden durch, ja sagen wir, einen linksliberalen Sprech.
Genau und das sehen wir jetzt auch schon, dass es nämlich genau diese Bemühung
gibt zu sagen, wenn schon, denn schon, also wenn dann Elon Musk und nicht Bill
Gates. Aber ich will dann auch, dass Elon Musk Bill Gates besiegt.
Also ich will das ausgekämpft sehen. Ich möchte die Niederlage von Bill Gates sehen.
Also dem Milliardären soll das Geld dann auch weggenommen werden.
Was jetzt zum Beispiel dazu führt, dass wir in Amerika, Trump jetzt schon in
der dritten Woche das Justizministerium angewiesen hat,
mal zu ermitteln, ob das mit dem Sponsoring von NPR und, wie heißt die zweite, NPR und PBS,
also Fernsehen und Radio, das ist öffentlich-rechtlich in Anführungszeichen,
das wird eben so getragen von Stiftungen hier und da, ich habe es ja häufiger im Fernseh-Podcast.
Und das sind wirklich nur noch Schwundstufen.
Absolut, das sieht aus wie Schülerfernsehen, wenn man sich das anschaut.
Und die gehen einfach nur die Nachrichtenlage durch.
Aber die Sendung beginnt eben mit zwei Minuten lang.
Diese Sendung wird ermöglicht von der... Da kommt ein Familienname-Foundation, wie auch immer.
Und das ist genau dieses Regime, gegen das jetzt vorgegangen wird.
Das heißt, Trump wird jetzt ein Jahr lang versuchen, den Leuten zu erklären,
Ja, wir sind Milliardäre. Wir sind die guten Milliardäre. Weil wir haben ja noch die schlechten.
So wie jetzt auch immer noch versucht wird, dieses Flugzeugabsturz,
der ist passiert, weil die beiden Regierungen diese DEI-Programme gemacht hat.
Und das werden wir jetzt ausmerzen.
Einmal mehr sehen wir, das war der falsche Weg. Wir können ja nicht einfach
Frauen einstellen, nur weil es eine Quotenregelung gibt.
Der Pilot muss da aufrechter Mann sein, ausgeschlafen. Das kann man nur dem Stärksten übergeben.
Diese Programmatik, die werden sich da rein radikalisieren.
Ja, das Kapital ist ja dann quasi so ein Schutzraum. Es gibt ja sowieso so eine
Lust daran, man will es ganz sicher haben.
Wir müssen hoch aufrüsten, dann fühle ich mich morgens gut, wenn ich aufstehe,
Weil ich weiß, da stehen hunderte von Panzern irgendwo rum.
Und das geht, glaube ich, dann auch bei vielen Leuten so, dass man sagt,
wir haben dieses ganze Kapital im Hintergrund.
Also man sieht das ja auch, dass doch so manche Springer-Journalisten wahnsinnig
breitschuldrig auftreten, wo die ja auch nur quasi kleine Angestellte sind.
Aber sie haben so diese Milliarden von Friede und Matthias im Hintergrund.
Ich bin eigentlich auch schon so stark wie Matthias selbst.
Das ist Gemütszustands-Tripple-Down. Ich kenne den Milliardären.
Ja, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, schicke ich den zu dir.
Er hat zwar noch nie mit dem gesprochen und kennt ihn auch gar nicht,
aber der ist auf meiner Seite. Ich habe es gestern im Internet gelesen,
so ungefähr. Und dann fühlt man sich irgendwie stark.
So, also Alice Weidel kümmert sich nicht um Laufpublikum.
Die redet über Hitler, die redet über irgendwas.
Die macht eine Partei mit, das war doch nur ein Vogelschiss.
Und das ist deren Ding. Also die machen den festen Kern.
Um die Laufkundschaft kümmern sich jetzt andere Leute. Die Diskurslandschaft
wird nicht von Alice Weidel gepflegt, sondern jetzt von, bei diesem Beispiel
für uns heute, Horst und Hopf.
So, Horst und Hopf ist ein wahnsinnig erfolgreicher Podcast.
Also wir sind auch ein erfolgreicher Podcast, aber die sind fünf,
sechs, siebenmal erfolgreicher als wir.
Das heißt also, jetzt diese Folge überall teilen, damit wir erfolgreicher werden als Horst und Hopf.
Wir können die beiden auch begrüßen, denn wir wissen genau, wenn so wie wir
jetzt gleich über Horst und Hopf reden, mal über einen neuen 20er Podcast irgendwo
gesprochen wird, hören Wolfgang und ich das sofort, wir lassen uns aber nichts anmerken.
Also Grüße an euch beide, nach Dubai in die Schweiz, hoffentlich das Wetter ist so gut wie hier.
Du hast es dir angetan, also erstmal Respekt dafür.
Dass du das… Ich höre jede Folge.
Du hörst jede Folge.
Es kommt aber schon ganz schön auf, jeden zweiten Tag oder so.
Aber man wird ja richtig verrückt dadurch, oder?
Nein.
Nein?
Ich bin ein Klardenker geworden.
Ich mache es ziemlich fertig, aber wir werden diese Clips jetzt gemeinsam hier
durchstehen. Ich bin jetzt ein Ladenger.
Ich könnte sofort dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Funk von Anbogen anbieten.
Was Siedmund Gottlieb nicht gelangen, mache ich den wahren Fleischhauer.
Die Sendung, die redlich konservativ ist, weil ich weiß, wovon ich mich abgrenzen muss.
Das hören wir jetzt, wovon wir uns abgrenzen müssen. Also Hoss und Hopf,
Diskurs, Landschaftspflege für dieses Neurechtedenken, das sich leider mit dem
diskreditierten Hitler nochmal rumschlagen muss,
weshalb wir hier hören, dieses Gespräch von Alice Weidel mit Elon Musk war ganz wichtig.
Der Grund, warum dieses Gespräch so ein großes Ding ist, es gibt eigentlich zwei Gründe.
Der erste Grund, und das ist für mich auch der relevanteste Grund und was ich
auch hier ganz klar hervorgehoben habe,
worauf man sich hier eigentlich stürzen sollte und nicht darauf,
dass es jetzt mit dieser Person, nicht mit der aus meiner Lieblingspartei oder
deiner Lieblingspartei oder der Lieblingspartei von meiner Oma passiert ist, sondern erstens,
hier wurde wirklich auf internationaler Ebene mit dem reichsten Mann des Planeten,
Ein Gespräch über die Probleme, die Deutschland aktuell hat geführt.
Und ich finde gut, dass Aufmerksamkeit auf internationaler Ebene auf die Probleme,
die wir in Deutschland haben, gebracht wird.
Das finde ich erstmal grundsätzlich gut und dafür ganz klar ein Dankeschön an Elon Musk.
Ja, schön, dass der reichste Mann sich so rührend um unser Land kümmert,
dass er da große Sorge hat, dass er auch als Amerikaner das nicht in Konkurrenz
sieht oder so, Sondern wir sind ja alle partnerschaftlich natürlich nur einem
großen Projekt verpflichtet, der Liebe.
Jetzt hören wir natürlich immer in diesen ganzen nachrichtlichen Besprechungen,
Hitler, Hitler, Hitler, sie hat über Hitler geredet, Alice Weidel hat über Hitler
geredet, warum hat sie über Hitler geredet, Philipp, weißt du warum,
nein, Ronsheimer, ich weiß das nicht und so.
Also denen geht es hier darum, dass dort die deutschen Probleme angesprochen wurden.
Ich habe jetzt das Gespräch auch nicht in voller Länge gehört.
Typischerweise mache ich das, aber in dem Fall habe ich mir so gedacht,
ja okay, also die reden halt, ich muss jetzt nicht noch eine weitere vollständige Stunde hören.
Aber ich habe natürlich GPT mal gefragt, ganz neutral, nenn mir nur die Themen.
So, GPT sagt, und ich habe gesagt, nach Priorität geordnet.
Also jetzt von Haus und Topf.
Nein, von Alice Beidel gegen Musk. Wo sie ja sagen, da wurden doch über die
deutschen Probleme gesprochen. Und das stimmt.
Also, wichtigstes Thema Energiepolitik in Deutschland, Klammer auf,
Abschaltung der Kernkraftwerke, erneuerbare Energien, Energieabhängigkeit von
Russland. Wir können uns alle denken, was da besprochen wurde.
So, zweitens, Wirtschaftspolitik und Bürokratie. Hohe Steuern,
übermäßige Regulierung, bürokratische Hürden.
Punkt 3, Migrationspolitik und innere Sicherheit. Illegale Migration,
soziale Auswirkungen, Kriminalität.
Viertens, AfD und ihre politische Positionierung, libertär, konservativ,
Medienberichterstattung über die Partei, Vorwürfe des Extremismus.
Punkt 5 Bildungspolitik und Vogue-Agenda.
Leistungsabfall im deutschen Schulsystem, Gender-Debatte. Punkt 6 Medien,
Zensur und Meinungsfreiheit, also Digital Services Act wurde besprochen,
Vergleiche mit historischen Diktaturen.
Punkt 7 Krieg in der Ukraine und geopolitische Entwicklung, europäische Abhängigkeit
von den USA, mögliche Lösungen für den Konflikt.
Punkt 8 Israel Nahe Osten. Punkt 9 Elon Musk Vision für die Besiedlung des Marses.
10 Glaube und Existenz Gottes.
Ja, da konnte Elon Musk ja nicht so richtig sagen, dass er vom lieben Gott nicht
so viel hält und musste sich dann auch so ein bisschen rauslavieren.
Ja, muss er ja häufiger. Sehr guter Gamer, Herr Musk. Ja, ich bin Top 20.
Ja, er hat ja wohl da jemanden bezahlt, der für ihn spielt.
Damit er als besserer Gamer darstellt.
StephanSchulz.com, ich blocke jetzt wieder. Ich nehme mir jetzt wieder das vor,
von dem alle sagen, interessiert niemanden geschriebener Text,
bist bescheuert auf einer eigenen Webseite.
Aber ich denke mir so, nö, für mich ist es wieder 2008.
Gut.
Und ich habe auch über Elon Musk Gamergate geschrieben. Das ist nämlich sehr
witzig, denn jemand, der Leute bezahlt, damit sie für ihn irgendwelche Dinge entspielen.
Ja, wer baut denn seine Raketen und seine Autos? Also das ist doch was für eine alberne Diskussion.
Natürlich lässt er für sich spielen. Gut, also wir haben hier durchaus Themen,
die in einem Gespräch stattfanden, die uns interessieren.
Das sind die Standard-Nachrichten-Themen. Halt mit einem anderen Einschlag,
aber das sind die Standard-Nachrichten-Themen.
So, wurde über Hitler in dem Gespräch gesprochen? Ja, für ungefähr sieben Minuten.
Es ging um Vergleiche mit der aktuellen Zensurpolitik, Darstellung Hitler als
Sozialisten und sie stellt einen Zusammenhang zwischen Sozialismus,
Neid und Antisemitismus her.
So, der Antisemitismus wird jetzt über Neid den Sozialisten in die Schuhe geschoben.
Ist natürlich ein cleverer Weg. Warum sollte man das nicht machen? Aus dieser Richtung.
So, Elon Musk ergänzt, dass totalitäre Regime oft durch Kontrolle der Wirtschaft
und Bildung Macht gewinnen.
Ja gut, das wäre jetzt so ein interessanter Fall. Da würde ich nochmal nachhören,
um was es da genau geht. Aber gut, muss jetzt hier an dem Punkt nicht interessieren.
Und Antisemitismus und historische Vergleiche. Okay, also,
diese Leute normalisieren uns hier diesen ultranationalen, ethno-pluralistischen,
hartrechten, rechtsradikalen Kern,
indem sie eine Diskurslandschaft mit Themen drumherum, die uns im Übrigen ja
sowieso auch interessieren, gestalten.
Hier kommt also die Radikalität von Weidel nicht zurück.
Nicht zu sprechen, sondern es wird drumrum geredet. Allerdings mit dem klaren
Zug, es gibt da jemanden, den ihr wählen könnt, wenn ihr so denkt wie wir.
So, das ist der Weg. Also andersrum, als wir es bisher denken.
Dass die ganzen Parteien so hier und da mal ein Angebot machen und stundenlange
Reden halten, wie Helmut Kohl, wo alles drin vorkommt und die Journalisten dann
so harte Kerne definieren. Nein, das ist hier genau umgedreht.
So, Hitler war links, wird jetzt hier aufgegriffen, auch bei Hoss und Hopf.
Mit einem uns bekannten, prominenten Leumund an dieser Stelle.
Und ich habe hier auch was gefunden, was man absolut hier nehmen kann als Quelle,
wo man nicht sagen kann, dass die irgendwie im Verdacht stehen,
pro Nationalsozialismus zu sein.
Das, was er jetzt kommt, meine ich noch nicht. Es gibt dann einen anderen Leumund.
Jetzt sagt er uns erstmal den Namen der Zeitung. Es ist ihm so wichtig,
dass er uns dreimal sagt.
Also die Strategie ist sehr übersichtlich und einfach.
Das ist die jüdische Rundschau. Das ist ein deutsches Magazin,
die jüdische Rundschau. Und hier in der jüdischen Rundschau wird… Also wo?
In der jüdischen Rundschau? Im deutschen Magazin der jüdischen Rundschau,
die jüdische Rundschau?
Jetzt werden die meisten Leute sich fragen, jüdisch, hab ich noch nie gehört, was kann das sein?
Und ich habe auch jetzt überlegt, was soll das sein? Naja, meinen sie vielleicht
die jüdische Allgemeine?
Nein, sie meinen die jüdische Rundschau, die gibt es. Wenn man diese Internetseite
einmal öffnet, dann stellt man fest, okay,
die sind jetzt also sehr rechts in allen möglichen Belangen.
Haben wir es etwa in Israel mit einer rechtsradikalen Regierung zu tun und die
jüdische Rundschau kann dementsprechend vielleicht ein Magazin sein,
das in diese Richtung denkt und schreibt?
Völlig ausgeschlossen, ja. Also man geht auf die Seite und weiß seit,
nach 15 Sekunden weiß man genau, was da los ist und denkt, wo ist eigentlich
der Link noch zu Tischis Einblick und was weiß ich alles, ja.
Also es ist, ja, aber es ist so schön.
Dass sie… Mir ging es noch nicht mal um die jüdische Rundschau,
sondern mir geht es ja noch um andere.
Dass Sie das aber dreimal erwähnen, um so zu tun, seht her, wir wissen natürlich
um unsere Geschichte und müssen da gucken.
Auch die Juden sagen Hitler mal nicht.
Irgendwie im Verdacht stehen, pro Nationalsozialismus zu sein und das ist die jüdische Rundschau.
Das ist ein deutsches Magazin, die jüdische Rundschau und hier in der jüdischen
Rundschau wird folgendes geschrieben.
Adolf Hitlers Weltanschauung wird bis heute als rechtsextrem eingestuft,
doch das neu aufgelegte Buch von Dr. Dr.
Rainer Zittelmann widerspricht dieser Einordnung. Die Nationalsozialistische
Deutsche Arbeiterpartei, wie viel mehr Links braucht man eigentlich noch in
seinem Namen, das schreiben die hier,
war zu Beginn eine linke Prekaritätsbewegung und ein Sammelbecken besonders
gegen Juden neiderfüllter und häufig gescheiterter Lebensläufe.
Also gescheiterte Lebensläufe bei den Linken, haben wir sowas schon mal gesehen?
Das haben auch die JR, also die jüdische Rundschau und ihr Herausgeber Dr.
Raphael Korzenzecher schon in der Vergangenheit in klarer Übereinstimmung zu Dr.
Zittelmann festgehalten. In Zitat Hitler selbstverständlich eines Revolutionärs
zeigt Zittelmann überzeugend, dass Hitler sich nicht als Rechter verstand,
sondern als antikapitalistischer Revolutionär.
Das ist das Gegenteil von einem Rechten.
Der konservative Verachtete. Ich bezeichne mich selber als liberal-konservativen.
Das heißt, ich wäre von Hitler verachtet worden, weil man uns ja auch gerne
den Vorwurf macht, rechtsextrem zu sein.
So, also, in einer Ideologie, in der man die alten Institutionen angreift.
Und das hat ja Weidel in dem Gespräch mit Musk auch gemacht.
Unsere Studenten lernen nur noch Vogue Gender Agenda. Und dann muss selbst Musk
mal kurz nachfragen, hey, ich dachte, ihr habt so ein gutes Ausbildungssystem.
Also es wird alles diskreditiert. Es sei denn, Doktor Doktor schreibt ein Buch
und Doktor Herausgeber Jüdischer Allgemeine sagt, dann ist es immer nur noch
der Doktor Doktor Doktor.
Nicht Jüdischer Allgemeine im Moment.
Jüdischer Rundschau. Dann ist es nur noch Doktor Doktor Doktor Doktor.
Doktor, ganz wichtig, Doktor, wer würde denn einem Doktor widersprechen, ne?
So, und dann natürlich die Standardideologie wird dann ausgebreitet.
Hitler war ein Nationalsozialist,
der sich einmal in der Macht angekommen, den Milliardären unterworfen hat,
um deren Kapitalismus-Kruppstahl- Agenda durchzuziehen, ne?
Also, es ist sozusagen, ja, klar. So.
Hopf holt das jetzt in die Gegenwart. Also, Hitler wird jetzt sozusagen in der
Geschichte überlassen. Es wäre doch schön, wenn Politiker ihr Land mal wieder lieben.
Kommt jetzt sozusagen in dieser Diskurs Landschaftspflege daher und ich sage
mir, ja warum, also das kann man doch einfach mal sich so anhören,
wie es da besprochen wird, wir müssen uns natürlich dann weiterführende Gedanken machen.
Die Volksvertreter, ein Teil von Ihnen, Robert Habeck, kann mit Vaterlandsliebe
nichts anfangen, kann mit Deutschland und dem Konzept Volk per se nichts anfangen.
Der ist Minister in unserem Land und er kann mit dem Land per se nichts anfangen,
mit dem Konzept eines Nationalstaates.
Da kann man dann schon von Verachtung und Hass auf das eigene Land sprechen.
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich nichts irgendwie, was da außerhalb der Norm erscheint.
Und wenn man nimmt seine Verantwortung nicht so sehr ernst, was sie da sagt.
Es ist halt wirklich eine sehr wichtige Rolle. Klar, aber wenn du etwas nicht
liebst, wenn du etwas nicht liebst,
dann gibst du auch nicht Acht darauf. Wenn du etwas nicht liebst,
dann kümmerst du dich nicht darum, dann denkst du nicht daran.
Wenn du etwas wirklich liebst, dann ist es dein Wichtigstes, dich darum zu kümmern.
Wer sein Land liebt oder wer sein Auto liebt, der gibt es zur Autowäsche, der poliert es.
Wer sein Zimmer liebt, der hält es in Ordnung, der hält es sauber.
Wer sein Land aber nicht liebt, wer es verachtet,
Der hat das Ergebnis jetzt in Deutschland und das sehen wir,
was hier passiert, an allen Ecken und Enden erodiert es, es fällt auseinander,
wir sehen es, wir sehen Magdeburg und noch hunderte andere Dinge,
Massenvergewaltigungen, Vergewaltiger, die mit Bewährungsstrafen rauskommen,
das kann nur, diese Urteile können nur von Leuten gesprochen werden,
die tiefe Verachtung für das eigene Land und für die Menschen im eigenen Land haben.
Das ist meine persönliche Meinung und meine Erfahrung, die ich in den letzten Jahren gemacht habe.
Also hier muss man jetzt sehen, es wird kritisiert, dass der angesprochene Habeck
immer nur von Deutschland, die Wirtschaft,
von irgendwas spricht, aber nicht die Leute meint, die hier leben,
die Deutschen, die doch dieses Land brauchen. Es geht doch um uns.
Wir müssen doch unser Land lieben und wir müssen doch alle unser Land lieben.
Und das ist eine ganz interessante Gleichsetzung von privatem und öffentlichem Haushalt.
Dunja Hayali, und das muss man jetzt wirklich mal ganz deutlich sagen,
ich eröffne mein Buch mit dieser Pointe, kann ich jetzt schon mal verraten,
kommt erst im März, aber mit dieser Pointe, Dunja Hayali macht Abendnachrichten und sagt,
das genaue Zitat steht im Buch sinngemäß, Wer seinen Haushalt zu Hause führt,
weiß, man darf nicht immer über die Stränge schlagen.
Was ist also mit der Schuldenbremse? Und man denkt sich so, nein,
Dunja, das ist genau das Problem.
Nach dieser Gleichsetzung, dann kannst du dich gleich einsortieren bei Hoss
und Hopf, die genau diese Ideologie auch weitertragen.
Das ist die schwäbische Hausfrau, die kümmert sich nämlich noch.
So, und das ist einfach nicht so. Wir können nicht die ganze Zeit sagen,
ich habe doch auch ein Auto. Also wer seinen Gartenzaun nicht zumacht,
muss sich doch nicht wundern, dass Leute eindringen und so weiter.
Ja, das ist ja übrigens dieser berühmte Roman des Franzosen,
der davon handelt, dass Frankreich von Migranten überflutet wird und ein alter
Herr dann da den Gartenzaun zumacht und sich versucht abzuschotten von der Welt
und das ist genau diese Denkweise.
Genau, also wenn schon das Land vor die Hunde geht, dann muss ich auf meinen
Rasen halt besonders selber achten, also mich selbst ermächtigen,
das haben wir dann auch gleich, wie das dann weitergedacht wird,
aber es ist wirklich sehr dramatisch.
Vor allen Dingen diese Vaterlandsliebe, die da angesprochen wird,
also es ist ja so, dass wir einen neuen Patriotismus schon seit der Zeit,
Sommer-WM haben, seit diesem Sommer-Märchen, das man hatte.
Damit fing das an, wir brauchen so einen fröhlichen Patriotismus,
eine positive Identifizierung mit dem Land, da ging das ja alles so los und
doch mal wieder mit den Fähnchen und dann nahm das immer stärker zu.
Dann in der Hip-Hop-Szene, jetzt hat ja gerade Flair, der sich auch immer als
Patriot bezeichnet hat, irgendwelche Fotos gemacht mit Philipp Amthor.
Das war immer diese Idee, naja, genau der Patriotismus ist ja das,
was alle brauchen und was uns auch alle eint.
Was natürlich da immer verdeckt bleibt ist, dass es Widersprüche gibt,
Klassenwidersprüche nämlich, zum Beispiel zwischen dem Mieter und dem Vermieter
oder dem Angestellten und dem Chef,
da ist nicht irgendein patriotisches Wir und dieses Vaterland,
das da heraufbeschworen wird,
ist jederzeit bereit, wenn du nicht entsprechend die Leistung bringst,
die von dir erfordert wird, dich in Bürgergeld zu drücken und dich mit Sanktionen
zu maltretieren und dass das aber immer wieder jetzt aufgerufen wird als das
Wir, ist etwas, was allgemein verbreitet ist.
Und deswegen ist es auch genau richtig von dir dann auch jetzt mal eine Dunja
Hayali oder wegen mir auch die Grünen mit ins Brot zu nehmen.
Denn das Interessante ist ja, dass ja Robert Habeck tatsächlich patriotisch
dann immer in dieser Weise ist.
Er sagt, ja es geht um das ganze Land und wir und der Wirtschaftsstandort.
Ich habe mit dem Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland nur dann positiv etwas zu tun,
wenn es meinen Lohn erhöht wird.
Sobald ich aber für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland auf einen Lohn Erhöhung
verzichten soll, um das BIP, um die Profite von Herrn Kühne und weiß ich nicht
wem zu steigern, dann ist das nicht mehr mein patriotisches bla bla bla.
Deswegen ist dieses nationale Wir an sich schon ein Irrsinn und der wird natürlich
jetzt hier besonders überspitzt, sodass wir das alle sehr gut erkennen, ins Feld geführt.
Aber generell kann man mal darauf achten, wie sehr diese Art der Denkweise schon
verbreitet ist und dann wird sich nur noch darüber geschritten,
ja wer ist der bessere Patriot?
Und dann gibt es nämlich Ich habe auch von linksliberal dann so eine Argumentation,
ja die AfD, das sind gar nicht die richtigen Patrioten. Wir sind die viel besseren Deutschen.
Also wenn wir jetzt Söder, Dunja Hayali, Merz nehmen, die wissen einfach nicht, wie ihnen geschieht.
Also die greifen so eine Stimmung auf und dann kommt Söder irgendwie mit,
alle Kinder in Bayern sind unsere Kinder. Wir lieben alle unsere Kinder.
Wir möchten, dass alle Eltern ihre Kinder abends in den Arm nehmen.
Man denkt sich so, ne, auch in Bayern leben ein Drittel der Kinder in Armut.
Und auch in Bayern ist es das normale Schicksal für alleinerziehende Eltern,
dass natürlich diese Mütter, weil sie sich um ihre Kinder kümmern, abends arbeiten.
Nach Büroschluss, nach Feierabend, weil der häufigste Beruf unter alleinerziehenden
Frauen ist der Raumpfleger.
Weil man da dem Kind einfach sagen kann, so alles ist erledigt,
du bist gut durch den Schulter gekommen und so weiter, jetzt guck noch Netflix
und geh dann alleine ins Bett, ich hab endlich Zeit zu arbeiten.
Also fährt man dann in diese Büros und so weiter.
Also niemand kümmert sich irgendwie, aber dann kommt diese großen,
dieses Gerede die ganze Zeit.
Es gab eine Studie vom Verbraucherverband in diesem Monat, eine Umfrage,
39 Prozent der Menschen in Deutschland schränken sich beim Lebensmitteleinkauf
ein, müssen sich einschränken, das heißt sie kaufen weniger gesunde Produkte für ihre Kinder.
Das heißt, die Kinder sind schlecht ernährt in Deutschland,
weil ein so liebevolles Land so viele Leute in Armut hält und in Niedriglohnsektoren
steckt, wo sie nicht genügend Geld haben für den Familieneinkauf.
Genau, und jetzt kann man sich überlegen, also ich habe jetzt gesagt,
Merz, Söder, Dunja, Herjali, die wissen nicht, wie ihnen geschieht,
die gehen hier mit so einer Stimmung, mit so einem Vibe,
und merken einfach nicht, wie sie so eine Ideologie bedienen,
indem sie so eine Unverwechselbarkeit von privater und öffentlicher Haushaltsführung
und so weiter herstellen.
Nur, Taka Carlsen, Hoss und Hopf, Alice Weidel, Elon Musk, wenn die irgendwie
auf der Bühne stehen, wir haben ja Taka Carlsen gehört, der sagt,
lieber will ich, dass mein Land abbrennt, bevor sich die Kultur,
mein Haus abbrennt, bevor sich die Kultur meines Landes ändert.
Ich lebe lieber obdachlos, unter meinesgleichen, als jetzt irgendwie von Ausländern überflutet.
Elon Musk, bei dem Alex Jones sagt, oh, er hat einen Hit gegen seine eigene
Company genommen, fürs Land, für die Republik, ja, er verzichtet.
So, und jetzt kommen die Hauser und Hoffen sagt, ja, kümmert euch. Diese Leute,
Die wissen ganz genau, das, was wir hier planen, ist ein Runterfahren der Wirtschaft.
Also wenn wir die Ausländer, wir müssen sie gar nicht vertreiben,
wir müssen einfach nur, sagen wir mal, den Zustrom der nächsten fünf Jahre dämpfen.
Wie so ein Vogel vergrämen am Flughafen, der irgendwie sagt,
ihr kommt hier nicht her und so.
Das bedeutet weniger für alle. Aber nicht ganz für alle. Denn die sind in Sicherheit.
Taka Carlson verzichtet nicht auf sein Haus. Elon Musk verzichtet nicht auf sein Haus.
Die haben ja, die bekommen ja noch mehr, also alle Finanzströme,
die noch da sind, bündeln die auf sich.
Das wäre in etwa so, als würden wir sagen, wir treten jetzt an,
werden die Regierung und sorgen dafür, dass Podcasts verboten werden,
außer unserer. Der soll bleiben.
Genau, wir sind ja im Dunstkreis und wir haben auch nie wie PBS irgendwelche
Stiftungsgelder entgegengenommen.
Wozu auch? Wir brauchen ja kein Budget, um irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
was ist denn hier sonst noch los jenseits meines Dunstkreises und so und so sind die halt nicht.
Und dann bündeln wir einfach alle Finanzströme, die im Podcast-Business sind,
auf uns und sagen, ja, ist doch gut gelaufen.
Was aber eben bedeutet, wenn man hier undurchdacht an die Sache rangeht,
wie Dunja Hayali und viele andere Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, wie Friedrich Merz,
der einfach nicht weiß, wie ihm geschieht, unterstützt man diese Ideologie.
Ja, und ich….
Und die ist eine große Lüge für die einzelnen Leute, die jetzt Horst und Hobbs zuhören und denken.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht heute wieder so sehr die Medien kritisieren,
aber ich komme nicht umhin. Denn als dieses Aschaffenburg war,
haben irgendwelche Funk-Journalisten und so weiter schon bei Twitter geschrieben,
da war das nur die Meldung.
Wenn sich das bewahrheitet, hat dann ein Funk-Heini geschrieben,
dann wird das alles verändern. Und ich dachte so, wieso?
Also entweder gab es schon vorher Probleme mit Migration oder es gab sie nicht
oder es gab sie nur so halb oder was.
Aber das ist ja jetzt ein Fall, der schrecklich ist und der aufgeklärt gehört etc..
Aber warum verändert das jetzt alles? Und das ist aber genau die Logik,
nach der dann die ganzen Medien, uns wirklich alle, darauf gegangen sind.
Und sie haben ja auch nichts geliefert zu den Wahlprogrammen.
Das konnte man doch wunderbar sehen. Es gab diese merkwürdige Äußerung der Grünen,
ja wir müssten bei Kapitalerträgen auch die Krankenversicherung sowas mit einbeziehen,
also die Beitragsbemessungsgrenze muss da angepasst werden mit Kapitalerträgen.
Man hat nicht so richtig rausgefunden, was die Grünen da wollten.
Dann gab es da mal so einen kleinen kurzen Aufschrei, man hat sich aber nicht
die Mühe gemacht, da wirklich eine interessante Debatte draus zu machen.
Man hat sich ja nicht einmal journalistisch die Mühe gemacht,
mal in die anderen Programme reinzuschauen, wie geht man da mit Kapitalerträgen um.
Dann wäre man beispielsweise darauf gestoßen, dass Linke, SPD,
Grüne, BSW, alle sagen, wir müssen die Kapitalerträge wie Einkommen besteuern.
Dann könnte man ja mal überlegen, wäre das eine gute Angelegenheit,
dann könnte man zu der Schlussfolgerung kommen, ja, für etwa 95 Prozent der
Menschen in Deutschland wäre das wunderbar, denn dann gäbe es erhebliche Mehreinnahmen.
Weil die obersten 5 Prozent von Kapitalerträgen leben und die weniger besteuern
müssen als ihr Einkommen.
Und das wäre die große Debatte gewesen.
Da ging es nämlich mal um ganz viele Steuereinnahmen.
Da könnte man sogar noch, wenn man diese Steuereinnahmen hätten,
über Steuernachlässe bei der Einkommenssteuer nachdenken, um Arbeit weniger
zu besteuern. Das wäre die Debatte gewesen, die wollte man nicht führen,
hätte man ja vielleicht mal ein paar Seiten lesen müssen.
Seit dessen hat man gesagt, ach ja, Anstark in Aschaffenburg mit Magdeburg hat
es nicht so richtig funktioniert, weil der Fall ein bisschen kompliziert war.
War doch schon lange da und hat auch AfD-Content geteilt.
Was war denn das für ein komischer Mann? Aber hier ist es jetzt eindeutiger.
Also gehen wir nur auf dieses eine Thema noch.
Und damit haben wir, du hast es ja schon prophezeit, aber auch in dieser Dimension
glaube ich nicht geahnt. So haben wir tatsächlich den dümmsten Wahlkampf aller Zeiten bekommen.
Das Problem ist hier insbesondere, und ich will es ganz deutlich sagen,
weil wir nähern uns auch einem Clip, in dem wir Peter Thiel gegen David Grabber
in ihrer einzigen Auseinandersetzung 2017 hören.
Diese Liste, die Alice Weidel angesprochen hat bei Elon Musk,
diese Themen, die ansonsten noch in diesem Hoss & Hoff Podcast,
der alle zwei Tage kommt, was schon ein bisschen viel ist, finde ich,
thematisiert wird, sind auch alle meine Themen.
Ja.
Ich finde auch, dass die Schule scheiße läuft. Beim Thema Migration,
Deutschland hat keinen Plan von nichts.
Das Institutionelle, die Dummheit ist so groß, ist grenzenlos.
Die politische Programmatik dazu ist nicht der Rede wert.
Also es ist einfach, das ist absurd, was da gerade diskutiert.
Das ist alles scheiße.
Nur, warte, lass mich das sagen.
Die Themen basieren im Kern auf einem Problem, das ich mit Hoss und Hopf teile.
Nur, die gehen den Peter Thiel Weg und wir gehen den David Grapper Weg.
Aber in der Problematisierung und in der Thematisierung liegen alle genau richtig.
Da aber niemand über Lösungen reden möchte, verstricken die sich gleich,
hören wir dann, in so einem Ermächtige-Dich-Selbst-Lise-Unser-Buch-Jeden-Tag-Und-Du-Wirst-Besser-Du-Kannst-Dich-Gegen-Den-Staat-Die-Gesellschaft-Dein-Kanzler-Und-So-
mach dich, ertüchtige dich,
während wir denken, nein, die Lösung muss eine andere sein, nur es wäre schön,
lieber öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk, wenn ihr einmal, eine Minute,
irgendwann mal eine Lösung präsentieren würdet für das ganze Zeug und nicht
immer nur das Problem, das Problem, Herr Söder, wie lösen Sie jetzt das Problem?
Herr Merz, haben Sie eine Lösung?
Warum können die nicht mal aus eigener Kraft eine Lösung präsentieren für diese
Probleme, die sie uns die ganze Zeit erklären?
Ja, und da müsste man auch mal ins Regionale rein. Ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen,
wie in einem Ort in Rheinland-Pfalz dort Container errichtet werden,
in denen zukünftig Flüchtlinge leben sollen.
Diese Container stehen am Rande eines Industriegebiets.
Um in die Stadt zu kommen, muss man über merkwürdige Wege lange mit dem Fahrrad
fahren. Ein Bus fährt von da nicht ab.
Das heißt, man produziert jetzt da gerade einen Hort für unglaublich viele Probleme.
Aber sie hängen nicht in der Turnheile rum. Siehst du, Problem gelöst. So ist die Denkweise.
Nachher sagt man wieder, das haben wir alles wieder nicht gesehen und da wollte
man sich nicht mit beschäftigen. Da wäre die interessante Beschäftigung da.
Da könnte sie medial aufbereitet werden, findet nicht statt.
Also lieber öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk, Hoss und Hopf hassen euch in einem
Ausmaß, das ich teile. Das ich teile.
Nur, wir werden gleich dazu kommen.
In anderer Weise.
Aber glaubt nicht, dass ihr hier irgendwo sicher seid, eure neun Milliarden und so.
Ja, wir sehen jetzt, wie Trump da schon anfängt, das kurz und klein zu schlagen.
Das lässt sich noch verhindern, aber man muss vielleicht den einen oder anderen
Lösungsvorschlag den Leuten, wir kennen ja von Lenin, die große Logik,
Revolution, können überhaupt erst nur angefangen werden, wenn es eine Perspektive gibt.
Wenn nur Probleme im Raum stehen, ja dann geht man den kürzesten Weg und dann
folgt man eben einfach seinen Emotionen und dann landet man schnell bei Horst
und Hopf. Die allerdings sind natürlich klug.
Also die machen ja nicht nur emotional, die machen ja Programmatik,
wozu auch gehört, die andere Seite kurz und klein zu schlagen.
Es gibt doch keine extremistischere Vereinigung in Deutschland,
die noch krasser andere Meinungen unterdrückt und Gewalt anwendet,
um diese anderen Meinungen stillzuhalten, um die Leute zu diffamieren,
um Leute fertig zu machen mit Gewaltanwendung.
Das ist quasi die 1 zu 1 Nachfolgeorganisation der SA, der Sturmabteilung im
Dritten Reich, ist für mich heutzutage die Antifa.
Nicht nur wir haben nichts mit
Hitler zu tun, sondern die Antifa ist die Nachfolgeorganisation der SA.
Das ist so absurd, aber okay, wir wissen jetzt in welchem Rahmen das gedacht
ist und wie das gemeint ist vor allem.
Welche Lösung hier drin stecken soll für welche Problemdefinitionen.
So, jetzt kommt das, worum es hier grundsätzlich geht.
Diskurs Landschaftspflege. Es findet gerade eine Handball-WM statt,
jetzt ohne deutsche Beteiligung, denn sie haben es nicht so richtig geschafft.
Man kann es auch kaum sehen, weil das läuft auf irgendeinem,
keine Ahnung, Spatenprogramm, wenn es nicht in der ARD wird.
So, Hoss und Hopf senden fast jeden Tag.
Und zwar reden die über alles, was junge Menschen bewegt, wie zum Beispiel Handball.
So, das Gespräch läuft dann hier, ein sehr unscheinbarer, unschuldiger Clip,
wir verstehen aber jetzt, ah ja, so ist das gemeint.
Die, die es jetzt wirklich bis hier bis zum Ende anhören, die sind jetzt die
Hossentopf-OGs und zwar will ich die eine Seite vom Buch heute mal vorlesen,
ich hab's hier in der Hand und zwar 11.
Januar. Ich hab's auch gerade bei mir da liegen. Du kannst nicht nach den Sternen
greifen, wenn du denkst, der Himmel ist die Grenze.
Handball ist ein Sport, der uns viel zeigen kann. Der Sport ist schnell.
Man lernt Entscheidungen, Sekundenbruchteilen zu fällen.
Er wird antizipativ ausgeführt. Man muss auf dem Spielfeld vorausdenken. Es geht ruppig zu.
Man setzt sich in harten Situationen durch.
Und gerade den Torhütern sagt man eine positive Verrücktheit nach.
Denn wer lässt sich schon freiwillig aus kurzem Abstand mit einem 120 Quadratmeter
schnellen Lederball bewerfen?
Andreas Wolf gehört zu den erfolgreichsten Handballteutern der Welt mit seinem
Motto, du kannst nicht nach den Sternen greifen, wenn du denkst,
der Himmel ist die Grenze.
Gewann er den Supercup, den DHB-Pokal, den EHF-Pokal, die Europameisterschaft.
Bei den Olympischen Spielen wurde zweimal Deutschlands Handballer des Jahres
und bei der Europameisterschaft 2024 als bester Keeper des Turniers ins All-Star-Team gewählt.
Also denk daran, wenn du nach den Sternen greifst, the sky is not the limit. So ist es.
So, wenn du einmal eine gefestigte Ideologie hast, kannst du thematisch da alles dran kleben.
Deswegen ist es auch kein Problem, 365 Geschichten in ein kleines Buch zu schreiben.
Das war jetzt so eine Seite. Das sind 365 solcher Dinger.
So, so funktioniert das jetzt. Also, das ist diese Ausbreitung,
Einfangen der Laufkundschaft und so weiter und so fort.
Wir müssen nicht Alice Weidel zuhören, liebe Öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Wir müssen jetzt Hoss und Hopf hören. So.
Also, wenn du nach den Sternen greifen willst, the sky is not at the limit.
Du musst jetzt darüber hinaus gehen.
Was bedeutet, du musst an dir arbeiten, Wolfgang. Du arbeitest ja auch schon an dir.
Jetzt gehen wir in deine Richtung.
Das ist die wirkliche Message dieses Podcasts und unseres Wirkens.
Erreicht Freiheit, finanzielle Freiheit, bedeutet Freiheit im Leben,
bedeutet ihr habt Optionen, alle Optionen, die ihr nehmen könnt.
Wenn ihr woanders hingehen wollt, dann macht ihr das.
Wenn ihr irgendwo Urlaub machen wollt, macht ihr das. Wenn ihr euren Mund aufmachen
wollt, dann braucht ihr Geld, dann können sie euch den Mund nicht verbieten.
Das sind die mächtigen Leute, die sagen können, was sie wollen,
nicht die mittellosen Leute. Und deswegen jeden Tag fünf Minuten Zeit investieren, Leute.
Ich finde es ganz toll, wie viele hunderte Menschen uns zuschreiben und anschreiben
jeden Tag, die die Seiten posten, die das durchgehen intensiv.
Lest jeden Tag eine Seite durch und ich sage euch, ihr werdet nach einem Jahr
euer eigenes Leben nicht wiedererkennen, weil ihr solche Fortschritte erzielt habt.
So und damit schließen wir das Ganze. Wir wünschen euch jetzt eine wunderschöne
Woche. Macht's gut. Bis bald.
Man löscht die Gesellschaft aus und hat nur noch das Individuum und den individualistischen...
Ja, man löscht die Gesellschaft nicht ganz aus.
Wenn man mit ihr Geld verdienen kann.
Ja, also man kriegt sie ja nicht los. Es sind ja noch andere Leute da.
Also der Fremde, das Unbekanntes ist ja immer noch da.
Aber es ist eben nicht sehr kompliziert, sich in der Welt durchzusetzen.
Du musst nur der Stärkste sein, der am besten vorbereitet ist.
Wenn du dich jeden Tag vorbereitet hast, dann ist diese Welt für dich.
Denn die Welt, Wolfgang...
Egal, welche Wünsche du hast, die Welt funktioniert, wie sie funktioniert.
Versuch nicht, in die Welt einzugreifen. Die Welt kennt nur ein Gesetz.
Wenn die Zeiten mal hart werden wie jetzt, dann hast du nur noch Versager da,
die nicht in der Lage sind, zu den Herausforderungen zu wachsen.
Sie sind nicht stark genug.
Warum? Weil man Schwäche eingestellt hat. Man hat nicht die Stärksten eingestellt,
wie auch das Gesetz der Natur ist. Nur die Stärksten überleben.
Nein, man hat bewusst die Schwächsten reingeholt. Und ich denke, das regt sich jetzt.
So, das ist eine Standard-Argumentation von dem Horst Hopf, denn es ist völlig
egal, in dem Fall waren es die LA-Fire.
Die Feuerwehr konnte nicht löschen, weil da zu viel schwache Frauen und man
hat Zwerge angestellt. Wie bescheuert ist denn das? Man muss die stärksten Feuerwehrmänner anstellen.
So, das Flugzeugunglück in Washington, genau dasselbe.
Also es ist sozusagen, es wird immer, der Podcast beginnt mit einem Thema,
um dann immer drauf hinauszulaufen, ja, ist doch kein Wunder,
man hat einfach nicht die stärksten eingestellt.
Die Leute machen sich Gedanken über Politik, weißt du, die wollen mit Programm
irgendwas ändern, da weiß doch jeder einfach den stärksten einstellen an den
Posten, wo man ihn am meisten braucht. Fertig.
Dann können alle wieder sich um sich selber kümmern, ins Gym gehen,
eine Seite Hoss und Hopf lesen.
Nicht über Politik nachdenken. Es gibt nur ein Gesetz und es war immer so und es wird immer so sein.
Die Welt ist schon immer so aufgebaut. Die Natur ist so aufgebaut.
Das Gesetz des Stärkeren. Das ist nun mal so.
In der Natur stirbt der Schwache und es überlebt der Stärkere.
Das ist einfach Natur Fakt, seitdem es die Erde gibt.
Das heißt, es gibt keinerlei Solidarität.
Null. Solidarität, Wolfgang.
Nur noch Kampf aller gegen alle und die Stärksten setzen sich durch.
Guck mal, fertig. Was willst du denn? Lange reden über irgendwas.
Es gibt nur einen Maßstab.
Wir sind alle in Eile. Wir wollen, dass Sachen geregelt werden.
Donald Trump findet zum Beispiel Kämpfen ganz gut. Warum?
Wir hören hier der Daily.
Having actually the really interesting level of recall about specific fights
and the history of it, the intricacies of the UFC.
You know, I look at like UFC or boxing or any of these things,
even sports generally. It's sort of a microcosm of life.
It's actually about as close to contemplative as I've heard him get.
He gives this answer talking about fights that it's sort of a microcosm of life.
It's this sort of binary thing. There are winners and losers.
And you can sort of see how that maps onto his political worldview.
You know, it's so interesting, but the nice part, it's over in a period of a
half an hour, 45 minutes.
It's all over and you sort of
see a decision, but it's a little bit like life when you think about it.
And obviously Trump wins the election in November and he and his team are well
aware of how integral that strategy was and White's role in it.
Wir werden ja nachher noch in einem anderen Fall sehen,
wie diese Wettbewerbslogik überall implementiert wird und dass dieser Kampf
dann ja auch verknüpft wird eigentlich mit der Idee, am Ende hat man es auch verdient.
Also der, der gewonnen hat, der hat es verdient, weil er sich entsprechend angestellt
hat oder weil er dann auserwählt ist.
Also das ist ja auch das Interessante, dass wir bei Trump diese Idee haben jetzt,
dass er offenbar auch berufen ist für dieses Amt.
Gott hat ihn verschont.
Ja, Gott hat ihn verschont, er hat diesen Anschlag überlebt und nun ist er derjenige,
der als Strongman alles richten wird.
Und das ist genau dieser autoritäre Charakter, der von der Frankfurter Schule
schon gut beschrieben wurde, dass es also nicht darum geht, um eine wirkliche Selbstermächtigung.
Das tut ja dieser Podcast von Hoss und Hopf immer so, als sei das jetzt an dir auch was zu tun.
Natürlich wollen die jetzt dort ihre Leute ein bisschen motivieren.
Wichtig ist aber, dass die Leute natürlich nicht zum Selbstdenken wirklich kommen.
Dass sie nicht bereit sind, in Konkurrenz zu treten zu Hoss und Hopf,
sondern sie sollen natürlich diese beiden weiter als ihre Gurus annehmen und
sollen dann darunter irgendwo in der Hierarchie,
in diesem Pyramidensystem, das da aufgebaut wird,
sollen sie sich dann auch irgendetwas erkämpfen können, aber mehr dann auch nicht.
Ja, wir haben ja von.
Also es war doch Röttger Brechmann gelernt.
Die Intelligenz, die die Menschheit ausmacht, ist eine soziale Kategorie.
Denn der Neandertaler hatte ein 20% größeres Gehirn, war stärker und klüger,
aber hat eben kein Mitgefühl gehabt, weshalb nie gemeinschaftlich eine Kultur aufgebaut wurde.
Wir haben von Richard David Brecht diese Erzählung vom Tintenfisch gehört,
wahnsinnig intelligent, aber lebt nur zwei Jahre.
In der Zeit kann man natürlich keine Kultur vererben und so richtig kommunizieren konnte er eh nicht.
Das was uns Menschen eigentlich von diesem Naturfakt unterscheidet,
es ist ja nicht mal recht des Stärkeren, es ist ja fit, es geht ja um Anpassung.
Und Anpassung wäre auch sehr viel ehrlicher, denn hier geht es ja wirklich um ordne dich ein.
Finde deinen Platz unten. Du bist im Grunde das, was wir jedem Migranten zugestehen.
Du kommst als Dr. Dr. Arzt, du beginnst als Taxifahrer.
Du kriegst drei Punkte gut geschrieben, den vierten musst du dir erarbeiten.
So, das ist ja die Logik, die hier drin steckt. Bleib klein,
sei zufrieden mit dem, was du hast.
Lies eine Seite Buch, weil mehr können wir dir unglaublich nicht zumuten.
Du schaffst nur eine Seite.
Vielleicht bekommst du mal mehr Bizeps, aber mehr wird es auch nicht sein in deinem Leben.
Mehr als ein Bizeps wird es nicht sein in deinem Leben.
Und das ist es ja auch, wenn man das AfD-Programm sich zum Beispiel durchliest,
es steht ja nirgends etwas drin, wo man sagen kann, ah, das wäre aber mal eine
deutliche Verbesserung.
Also auch nicht für jetzt die, die dort als die Deutschen wirklich angesehen werden oder so.
Und das Versprechen ja hier ist ja auch nur, tja, bist ein bisschen spät dran
mit dem Krypto-Hype, aber probier es mal, investier mal noch weiter.
Und der Witz ist ja, dass diese Leute, die da früh mit Krypto reich geworden
sind, wie das bei Horst und Hopf der Fall ist, dass die ja davon nochmal enorm
profitieren, wenn jetzt nochmal Leute weiter auf diesen Kryptozug aufspringen.
Das macht ja deren Investments sehr viel wertvoller, während die anderen auch
sowieso nur noch kleine Fortschritte da erreichen können, da der Bitcoin jetzt
bei 100.000 Euro nun mal schon steht.
Und das ist genau diese Pyramidenstruktur, die da ist und die ja auch dann so
interessant ist, wenn man sich ansieht, wie denn der Führungsstil dieser Leute ist.
Dieses Gespräch zwischen Elon Musk und Alice Weidel beinhaltete ja auch,
dass Weidel zu Musk sagt, niemand will ja in seiner Umgebung nur Ja-Sage haben.
Und Alice Weidel hat in ihrer Partei nur Ja-Sage um sich herum.
Muske ich, Musk gegenüber nur, ja, ja, ja, absolut, ja, ja, ja, ja gesagt.
Und Musk hat das gesamte Board seines Unternehmens so aufgestellt,
dass da nur noch Knechte sind, die sagen, ja, machen wir genau so.
Genau, ich will hier nur eine kleine Anmerkung machen zum Thema Familie,
denn du hast ja schon häufiger betont, dass auch Margaret Thatcher damals gesagt
hat, es gibt keine Gesellschaft, nur das Individuum und die Familie.
Das heißt, die soziale Intelligenz darf in die Familie. Also die Familie darf für dich da sein.
Wenn du keine Familie hast, hast du nur noch dein Bizeps.
So, das ist also die Logik, die hier diesen jungen Menschen,
die Hossen Hopf hören, die ganze Zeit erzählt wird, ohne jeglichen Widerspruch
von Dunja Herjali und Kollegen.
Die machen das nie. So, Friedrich Merz, ja, wenn ein Kind stirbt,
dann mache ich nochmal eine kurze Sonntagsrede zum Thema, wir lieben doch alle Kinder.
Und alle wissen, ja genau, wir erkennen dich gar nicht wieder,
Markus. Schon der Tonfall ist für dich völlig neben der Spur.
Wir erkennen dich hier nicht wieder.
Vielleicht noch einen Aspekt zum Thema, weil das eben schon mal da aufkam mit Alice Weidel.
Ja, sie kann ja nicht wie Hitler sein. Also das war ja auch das damals,
was Elon Musk in seinem Beitrag geschrieben hat.
Alice Weidel hat mit den Nazis nichts zu tun, denn sie ist ja lesbisch und so weiter.
Das ist ja häufig zu hören auch, dass man sagt, ja, ähm.
Das kann ja nicht so ein schlimmer Rechter sein, weil der ja homosexuell ist
oder so. Das ist ja etwas, was man häufig erfährt.
Und da geht es ja auch wieder um Survival of the fittest, also im Sinne von Anpassung.
Das heißt, du kannst auch als lesbische Frau mit Kindern zur Mehrheitsgesellschaft
gehören, wenn du bereit bist, dich dieser anzupassen.
Also das Interessante ist ja, dass Alice Weidel bei all ihrer Macht,
die sie da jetzt hat, zugleich sich unterwerfen muss.
Also sie muss schon das Paradigma der heteronormativen Familie als das absolut
erstrebenswerte darstellen.
Sie selbst entspricht ihm zwar nicht, deswegen muss sie sich besonders konform
auch dann verhalten in der Ideologie, damit sie in dieser Weise da geduldet
wird. Denn sonst wäre sie ja irgendwie queer oder so und das wäre ja etwas,
was man wieder aussondert.
Und das kann man ja auch bei vielen, vielen rechten, schwulen Politikern erleben,
dass die bereit sind, dann besonders hart die Linie auch durchzusetzen.
Weil sie damit nochmal ihre Anpassungsbereitschaft unter Beweis stellen.
Denn sie sagen dann zwar, dass sie schwul sind und leben das auch öffentlich,
aber zugleich sind sie absolute Hardliner, womit sie sagen,
also das, was ihr als Mehrheitsgesellschaft für akzeptabel und unterstrebenswert
haltet, das ist etwas, dem ich mich unterwerfe und da werde ich auch niemals
euch irgendein Steinchen in den Weg legen.
Also Weidel wird natürlich dankbar in diesem politischen Vorfeld,
das wir betrachten, aufgenommen, weil kann so eine Frau Hitler sein?
Also die Argumentation ist auch explizit. Den Clip habe ich auch da liegen.
Mal gucken, ob wir den nachher noch spielen.
Jetzt haben wir erstmal so eine Problemlage. Die jungen Leute sollen mal gucken,
wo sie bleiben und mehr als eine Seite Hoss und Hopf am Tag.
Nein, lesen ist nicht so. Die Gesellschaft hat nichts für dich im Angebot.
Trifft das auf Resonanz?
Herr Feldenkirchen macht in seinem Podcast mal eine kleine Studienschau.
Fühlen sich online nicht angesprochen. Junge Menschen empfinden Politik als Gegner.
Darüber berichtet das RND. Sie informieren sich vor allem online und stoßen
in den sozialen Netzwerken meist auf die AfD.
Junge Menschen erkennen laut dem Generationenforscher Rüdiger Maas Politiker
nicht als ihre Verbündeten an.
Sie haben sogar das Gefühl, die Politik arbeitet gegen sie oder nimmt sie gar
nicht ernst, sagte Maas im ARD-Morgenmagazin.
Der Forscher beklagte, das Politikverständnis von manchen jungen Befragten sei unterirdisch.
Viele hätten ihr Hauptwissen über die Politik aus sozialen Netzwerken.
Dort spreche fast nur die AfD die Sprache der jungen Menschen,
wodurch ein Ungleichgewicht entstehe.
Andere Parteien müssten dringend Präsenz zeigen, komplexe Themen herunterbrechen, Inhalte beleben.
So, und jetzt wundern wir uns, dass 18-jährige Neuwähler Hitler gar nicht so
wichtig nehmen und sich denken, Ja klar, wie ich AfD, warum denn nicht,
macht doch total Sinn, ich kann das nicht erwähnen. Wie heißt der nochmal? März?
Also es ist doch völlig normal. So, jetzt haben wir ja diese Problemlage,
dass wir unendlich viele Journalisten haben, die unfassbar oft zum selben Thema reden.
Ich glaube, wir werden im März auch mal die Bro-Politik-Landschaft in Deutschland,
Politik-Podcast-Landschaft, also Michael Bröker, Gordon Ripinski,
Robin Alexander und so, das ist ja unerträglich.
Vor allem, wenn sie sich gegenseitig im Podcast besuchen, um sich nochmal zu
erzählen, dass hier diese kleine Nuance in der Meinung zu Merz,
die du hattest, nein, ich sehe das so, zum Glück streiten wir uns mal wieder.
Während gleichzeitig in Amerika Trump anders als Merz weiß, was er tut,
weil er kann sich jetzt zurücklehnen, es ist ja jetzt Stephen Miller und so,
der die Agenda durchfährt also werden da PBS-Hops genommen und die ersten,
Razzien finden irgendwie statt und,
drei Trillionen Dollar werden da blockiert, damit die Länder jetzt mal nicht
finanziert werden, die müssen erstmal Konzessionen machen und so,
ja also die ganze Agenda wird jetzt durchgesetzt,
mindestens in einem kleinen Punkt, Miriam Lau im Zeitpodcast Macht mal kurz
eine Anmerkung, von der wir sagen, so ist jetzt die Ideologie,
sollen sie doch selber gucken, wo sie bleiben.
Die Nachricht, die mich richtig erschrocken hat letzte Woche,
war, dass Donald Trump als eine von diesen Executive Orders den Schutz für einige
Leute, unter anderem John Bolton, aufgehoben hat.
Also Leute, die eigentlich so klassische Republikaner waren.
Und wenn du den Schutz aufhebst und gleichzeitig Leute begnadigst,
die Gewalt gegen das Kapitol und gegen Polizisten und so weiter aussehen,
das ist ja so wie so eine Art vogelfrei, ich erkläre diese Leute für vogelfrei.
Und das hat mich fast noch mehr erschrocken als irgendwelche anderen Dinge.
Also ich glaube, wir machen uns alle noch gar kein Bild davon, was da auf uns zukommt.
Hä, der Staat ist nicht für mich da? Warum soll der für John Bolton da sein?
Soll doch selber gucken, wo bleibt es denn noch alles Millionäre?
Kann sich doch mal jemanden kaufen.
Ach so, der hat dann nur Bizeps, aber keinen Zugang zu Sicherheitsinformationen.
Naja, das schaffen die schon. Bizeps reicht doch aus.
Also es ist ja nicht nur John Bolton, sondern es ist auch hier Mike Pompeo und
so. Also das ganze alte Kabinett ist vogelfrei erklärt worden.
Gleichzeitig ist ja klar, gegen einige von denen läuft ja wirklich so Fatwa-mäßig
vom Iran aus, wir wollen die töten und wir haben hier noch diejenigen,
die damals schon Mike Pence töten wollten und deswegen im Gefängnis gelandet sind.
Zum Teil mehr als zwei Jahrzehnte mit Urteilen, die jetzt wieder auf freiem Fuß sind.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen, könnte man nochmal eine Netflix-Serie zumachen, die alles übersteigt.
Das sind unsere Wertepartner.
Das sind unsere Wertepartner, das ist das transatlantische Bündnis.
Für die gibt es dann bald auch die Wehrpflicht. Also ich sage das auch nochmal,
hier hören ja auch mitunter junge Grüne und sowas zu, die müssen ja auch dann
nachher alle nochmal mit Bauchschmerzen sagen, aber wir brauchen die Wehrpflicht
in der Koalition mit Friedrich Merz.
Wir kämpfen an der Seite der Kapitolstürmer, um Grönland, Kanada oder was auch
immer zu erobern und um unsere Werte auch da zu platzieren.
Also das Aufwachen und diese Erweckungsmomente, die Aufklärung unter deutschen
Journalisten ist so zäh und so lahm, Auschwitz könnte wieder eröffnet werden. Dann würden die sagen.
Ist das jetzt ein Hitler-Fuß? Ich weiß nicht.
Aber es steht nicht der Spruch drüber.
Ich habe diesen Post mitgebracht von Julia Klöckner.
Da postet sie, also vor Aschaffenburg war das noch alles, da postet sie,
für das, was ihr wollt, müsst ihr nicht AfD wählen.
Dafür gibt es eine demokratische Alternative, die CDU.
Guten Morgen, wir machen AfD-Politik.
Die AfD hatte immer recht und jetzt, wo es hart auf hart kommt,
sagen wir, sie hatte immer recht und das muss jetzt auch gemacht werden. Keine Kompromisse.
Und auf sowas kommt dann höchstens eine Journalistenfrage in den Tagesthemen.
Trügt der Eindruck oder rückt die CDU jetzt auch stärker nach rechts?
Nee, die ist da jetzt schon. Die rückt nicht mehr wohin.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns, jetzt hören wir kurz einen Clip, der ist wahnsinnig
interessant, ich empfehle das ganze Gespräch, Esra Klein mit diesem James Porgu oder wie er heißt.
Die reden über Maskulinität, wir sollten uns davon jetzt nicht allzu sehr ablenken
lassen, aber es ist schon ein zentrales Thema und es ist auch für uns ein zentrales
Thema, warum sind es vor allem Männer?
Bei uns im Podcast sind 75% männliche Zuschauer, bei Hoss und Hoff sind es wahrscheinlich 99%.
Frauen hören das typischerweise nicht. Sie können damit nichts anfangen und
zwar völlig zu Recht. Sie sind einfach, muss man jetzt so sagen, soziale Wesen.
Anders als UF 30 Männer. Die glauben, sie können es alleine und wie auch immer.
Irgendwann kommt schon das Aufwachen. Meistens auch mit gigantischen Lebenskrisen
wünschen wir niemanden.
Aber wenn es sein muss, okay, ist irgendwie der Lauf der Dinge.
Aber die unter 30-jährigen Männer sind...
Das ist spezifisch, sagen wir mal so. Wir lassen uns aber nicht allzu sehr ablenken,
denn in diesem Clip wird jetzt auch erinnert an Grabber gegen Thiel und ab hier,
das ist der Clip, den alle deutschen Journalisten jetzt verstehen müssen,
ab hier muss jetzt lösungsorientiert gearbeitet werden.
Der Clip ist nicht allzu gut verstehen, der ist auch viel zu kurz,
um das zu verstehen, aber wir werden den gleich entfalten.
Is by rocket-shipping into the future. And some of that is actually coalition politics.
Some of that is, I think, in my opinion, some people who are more tech-skeptical
just kind of saying, all right, let's try this.
And so you can go back to, for example, I was friends with David Graeber,
you know, the great anarchist philosopher.
And David did a debate with Peter Thiel on tech.
And the critique was technology is not actually benefiting us.
It's become this rent-seeking capitalist kind of evil.
In fact, like, check on human progress.
And this is a bit of a famous moment for some people who follow this stuff,
because Thiel sat down with David and agreed in broad strokes.
If you want to minimize the possibility of unexpected breakthroughs,
take those same people and then tell them they're not going to get any resources
at all unless they spend the majority of their time competing with one another
to prove to you they already know what they're going to create.
Well, that's the system we have. And it's incredibly effective in stifling any
possibility of innovation.
So I'll leave off at that and see what Peter has to say.
Well, there's a disturbing amount I actually agree with David on here.
And, you know, he would have said, well, the way we fix this is by unleashing capitalism, Graeber.
It was by building a more communal society where people had more agency amongst each other.
But the trick here is that when you talk, for example, about masculinity,
there's a really fundamental question that you're seeing even people like Mark
Zuckerberg wrestle with now, where he's saying, you know,
masculine culture has been excluded from American corporate culture and things like this.
And what people are wondering is, you know, do men need violence to feel good?
Like, are men supposed to be ultra-competitive and, you know,
the best men get the best women and the others are sort of shunted aside?
And, you know, that's sort of the Bronze Age pervert kind of thing.
Do men need a physical culture in order to feel good in their lives and progress
and do excellent work in whatever field they've chosen?
So, also, wir haben hier zwei große Denker, die sich nicht unbedingt groß im Hintergrund hielten.
Also David Klapper ist natürlich jetzt leider tot, aber Peter Thiel ist ja noch
da und es ist jetzt auch nicht ungewöhnlich, dass er mal einen Podcast sitzt
und acht Stunden lang erzählt.
Ja, der hat ja ein Buch geschrieben, Zero to One.
Genau, genau. Ja, das ist super interessant, dieses One, also eben diese radikale Monopolisierung.
Sobald eine Idee gut ist, Marktwirtschaft komplett überspringen,
direkt Monopol. Also wir wollen jetzt hier Fortschritt.
So, was hier thematisiert wurde, ist, beide, David Grapper und Peter Thiel,
stimmen überein, 2017, dass es irgendwie keinen richtigen Fortschritt gibt in dieser Gesellschaft.
40 Jahre lang. In Amerika gibt es keine Highspeed-Züge, es fährt kein Transrapid
im Vakuum, im Tunnel irgendwas, alles ist wie früher, nur wir haben jetzt Facebook,
Short-Videos, wie auch immer.
Also wir haben einen Fortschritt bei den Bits, aber nicht bei den Atoms, bei den Atomen.
Und das ist dieser Punkt, wo er sagt, ja genau, wo sind die Breakthroughs, die Unerwarteten?
Wir verstricken uns hier in so einem, keine Ahnung, können Sie bitte mal ein
Programm schreiben, was Sie jetzt wollen und dann, ja, dann machen wir das halt oder so.
Also es ist so, alle sind so im, ich mach mal ein Drehbuch und dann reicht das
ein und dann sagt das Gremium, können wir machen, schaffen Sie es mit einem
halben Budget und dann hat man schon keine Lust mehr und nichts geht vorwärts.
So, und jetzt gibt es zwei Lösungsansätze. Und bei diesem Problem,
ich würde es nochmal sagen, wir stimmen alle überein.
Horst und Hopf sagt, die Bürokratie ist scheiße, die Behörden funktionieren
nicht richtig, das Bildungssystem ist Mist und niemand kommt vorwärts.
Und ich sage, stimmt, absolut, das Bildungssystem ist Mist, niemand kommt vorwärts,
die Behörden sind scheiße, der Staat lässt mich im Stich und so weiter.
Alle stimmen hier überein.
Aber du würdest es ja nicht in dieser Radikalität formulieren,
denn du würdest ja schon sagen, auch dass das Bildungssystem in Deutschland
ja nicht das Schlechteste ist.
Du würdest auch festhalten wollen, dass die Züge zwar spät kommen,
aber es ist ja in anderen Ländern durchaus schlimmer.
Also wenn wir in einen internationalen Vergleich gehen.
Sind wir natürlich ja… Nee, würde ich gerne, würde ich gerne.
Aber an dem Tag, an dem Trump ins Amt eingeführt wird, kriege ich eine Nachricht,
dass die Schule ausfällt, weil die Heizung nicht geht.
Und ich mir Gedanken machen muss, wie ich die nächsten Tage rumkriege,
weil hier wieder Homeoffice, Homeschooling angesagt ist.
So zwei Tage später erfahre ich, dass man jetzt einen Termin hat mit denjenigen,
die das reparieren. In zwei Tagen.
Das sind also schon vier Werktage verstrichen.
Okay, ich nehme alles zurück.
Das ist alles völlig absurd.
Wir sind am Arsch.
Ich reise nicht so gerne, nicht weil ich ungern in fremden Betten schlafe.
Oder ungern vor Publikum auftrete, sondern weil ich mir nicht sicher sein kann,
dass es reicht, 16 Uhr in den Zug
zu steigen, sondern ich am besten 10 Uhr morgens schon in den Zug steige.
Wenn der Zug nicht kommt, okay, nochmal gut gegangen, ich musste nur vier Stunden
am Bahnhof warten, ja, es ist doch alles absurd, es ist wirklich alles absurd.
Ich bin hier, ich will hier nicht zurückstecken in Sachen Radikalität,
Denn in Sachen Peter Thiel, ja, das ist dieser berühmte Spruch,
die haben uns fliegende Autos versprochen und alles, was wir bekommen haben, sind 140 Zeichen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich kann meine Wut rauslassen ins Internet. Und was habe ich dann jemanden,
der mir eine Ideologie erklärt mit, ja, dann geh doch ins Gym.
Ich habe ja anfangs gesagt, als wir über Aschaffenburg sprachen,
alle sind so wahnsinnig emotional involviert und engagiert, weil das die einzige
Möglichkeit ist, noch ein Engagement vorzutäuschen.
Denn sonst haben die Parteien wenig anzubieten und die Parteien,
gerade die Konservativen, sagen, ja sowieso wollen wir den Status quo erhalten.
Wir können nur an dieser einzigen Stellschraube noch Engagement zeigen und sind
dann besonders hart gegen Leute, die hier hinkommen oder die schon da sind.
Und daran kann man eigentlich nochmal so deutlich sehen, wir hatten jetzt jahrelang,
und es ist hier im Podcast ja sehr gut dokumentiert, von der ersten Folge an
eine Diskussion über Schuldenregeln.
Schuldenbremsen etc.
Es ist jetzt in den Wahlprogrammen, außer bei Linke und zum Teil noch bei SPD,
nur sonst zu finden, ja wir müssen die Schuldenbremse reformieren,
um auch mal einen Deutschlandfonds oder was zu machen.
Da stehen keine Zahlen, da stehen nicht die großen Projekte,
die jetzt in Gang gesetzt werden sollen.
Da ist nicht der Green Deal, den die Grünen uns jetzt anzubieten haben,
der ist in dem Programm nicht aufzufinden.
Es ist ein Anschmägen an eine Schuldenbremsenreform, wie sie auch der CDU-Recht wäre.
Es wird nicht so sein, dass diese Parteien die Schuldenregeln so verändern,
dass Investitionen stattfinden, dass du pünktlich bald mit dem Zug fahren wirst.
Und zwar auch nicht in den nächsten fünf Jahren.
Also was man daran sehen kann ist, es tut sich da fast nichts.
Dieser ganze Reformstoff, von dem die Rede ist und all das, das wird nochmal
gesagt, das wird auch nochmal benannt in den Programmen.
Aber du wirst nichts da finden, dass entsprechende Maßnahmen da sind,
die als Lösung begriffen werden können.
Es gibt in keinem Programm ein großes Infrastrukturprojekt. Es ist dort nicht zu finden.
Und das ist ja das Interessante. Das heißt, die Politik ist weitgehend blank.
Die ist weitgehend blank.
Journalismus auch.
Und das, was angeboten wird, ist, wir können jetzt nochmal darüber diskutieren,
ob Hitler ein Kommunist war, wer wirklich deutsch ist und wer ganz deutsch ist.
Das ist die Möglichkeit, die wir haben.
Und dann machen wir 10 Uhr morgens Holocaust-Gedenken und 16 Uhr.
Ja, und wir können es schaffen, nochmal einigen Menschen in Deutschland,
die nicht so aussehen wie Stefan und Wolfgang, das Leben nochmal richtig noch
härter zu machen, als es ohnehin schon ist. Das ist das Angebot.
Dann geht es uns relativ besser. Denn dann geht es uns relativ besser.
Wenn der Nachbar sich auch nur einen Golf leisten kann, dann bin ich mit meinem
kleinen Peugeot ja auch nicht so schlecht dran.
Also das ist die Logik, die jetzt vorherrscht.
Und ja, von daher hast du recht, muss man eigentlich diesen Zorn haben.
Ich will sagen, ja, es gibt natürlich progressivere Ansätze.
Aber die sind in den Parteiprogrammen nicht zu finden, in den Wahlprogrammen nicht zu finden.
Ich würde da mal ausklammern, bei der Linken verhält es sich da ein bisschen
anders, aber sonst ist es wirklich erstaunlich,
trotz all dieser Diskussionen und der Expertisen, also Adam Tues beispielsweise
ist jemand, der die Grünen und die Grünen Spitzen beraten hat,
wie wenig am Ende von all dem in
dem Programm ist, auch will ich das ganz deutlich sagen in Bezug auf BSW.
Da haben ja auch viele gedacht, naja, aber das wird schon jetzt in die linke
Richtung ökonomisch ein Wahnsinnssatz, der da gemacht wird.
Mal von den Migrationsfragen und so abgespalten, wäre das doch was.
Wenn man sich das BSW-Programm ansieht, ist auch da, dass eine Politik der Minischritte,
wo man sagen kann, ja, das trägt sozialdemokratische Züge, aber nicht.
Man das als großen Wurf verkaufen würde, also selbst wenn das BSW die absolute
Mehrheit hätte und dieses Programm eins zu eins zu durchsetzen würde.
Wäre die Situation in Deutschland, was Infrastruktur, was die soziale Frage
anbelangt, nur minimal besser.
Das heißt also, selbst bei den Programmen, die man hier einfach mal so ins Blaue
hinein schreiben kann, was ja auch SPD, Grüne und so weiter machen könnten,
haben sie kein großes Konzept anzubieten.
Die 100 Milliarden, die die CDU da noch nicht finanziert hat,
die Wahlgeschenke, sind einfach nur die Hoss und Hopf Idee von hier Taschengeld, geh ins Gym.
Wir haben kein Angebot, wir geben dir das Geld lieber wieder.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Aber nur wenn du zu den oberen 10% gehörst.
Genau. Und dann ist deren Angebot, ich weiß, wir müssten ja eigentlich Politik
machen, aber hier bitte nimm dein Geld wieder.
Mach es selber. Also das geht einfach nicht.
Und ich würde sogar sagen, für viele der oberen 10 Prozent rechnet sich das nicht.
Also für die Superreichen, da hat Friedrich Merz natürlich dann tolle Lösungen parat.
Aber ich sage mal, jemand, der 6.000, 7.000, 8.000 Netto im Monat verdient,
der könnte vielleicht auch mehr davon profitieren, wenn die Schule,
in die seine Kinder gehen, gut funktioniert, als wenn er 3.000 Euro weniger
im Jahr Steuern zahlen muss, denn davon kann man noch nicht eine Privatschule finanzieren.
Genau, eben. Also es gibt sehr viele Synergieeffekte, die einfach in die Luft geschlagen werden.
Und das ist auch, finde ich, hier muss man jetzt rein, die unterschiedlichen
Lösungsansätze für dasselbe Problem bei Peter Thiel und David Grabber. Also.
Thiel, just do it. Wer macht, hat recht.
Wenn jemand was macht, geh ihm aus dem Weg, lass ihn machen.
Wenn er ein Monopol hat, ja, der ist ja durchgesetzt, ist doch nur ein Erfolgsausweis und so, ja.
Bürokratie, Staat, alles weg, weg, weg, weg, weg. Lass den machen,
frag nach Vergivnis, aber nicht um Erlaubnis fragen, ja, einfach machen, machen, machen.
David Kleber, nein, wir brauchen hier grundlegende strukturelle Veränderungen,
die Finanzialisierung und die Bürokratisierung, also ein Wirtschaftsgebaren,
das sozusagen, ach du hast eine gute Idee, nee,
du brauchst Geld, um Geld zu kriegen, musst du dich uns unterwerfen und so,
ja, das hindert die Kreativität.
Ach, du musst erst sieben Anträge stellen, um was zu machen.
Nee, Bürokratie bitte klüger machen.
Fördernd, Kreativität fördernd. Wir brauchen hier große Gemeinsamkeiten.
Und dann eben dieser grundsätzliche, wir machen es gemeinsam,
wir nutzen die Synergieeffekte, wir gestalten Programme und dann trial and error, probieren wir sie aus.
Aber eben nicht, indem wir uns die ganze Zeit abhaten und gehämisch,
siehst du, hast du eine schlechte Idee gehabt und so, sondern nein,
einfach klug gemeinsam nach vorne gehen. Das sind diese unterschiedlichen Ansätze.
David Kreber will also die kollektive Intelligenz mobilisieren.
Wir sind die Träger dieser Intelligenz, aber eben nur, wenn man es kommunikativ
so gestaltet, dass es zu diesen entsprechenden sozialen Effekten führt.
Oder, Horst und Hopf, Peter Thiel, jeder macht es selbst.
Die Natur hat es so vorgegeben, der Stärkste setzt sich durch,
keine Rücksicht, keine Erlaubnisfragen, vielleicht nochmal sich entschuldigen,
wenn irgendwer so hops gegangen ist dabei. Das sind die unterschiedlichen Ansätze.
Könnte man natürlich jetzt in Tiefe und Breite diskutieren. Ich habe eine Diskussion
gefunden, in der das diskutiert wurde, nämlich Umgang mit dem Staat.
Wir hören erstmal Merz, bevor wir da ins Gespräch mit Rainer Hank,
das ist der, der bei mir mit Lanz im Gespräch saß, Patrick Bernau.
Ich weiß, das geht jetzt ein bisschen drüber in meinem Urteil,
aber wirklich ein vulgär-libertärer FAZ-Redakteur, der sozusagen und so,
und Stefan Kohle, wissenschaftslicher Leiter des Ludwig-Erd-Forums.
Erst mal hören wir aber, wie sich Friedrich Merz aus lauter Blödheit und Verlegenheit
hier schon mal auf eine Seite schlägt.
Er von Altenbock und das andere große Thema.
So, das ist jetzt ein Gespräch in der FAZ. Simon Strauß redet mit Jasper von
Altenbockum darüber, was Friedrich Merz gesagt hat. Den O-Ton hören Sie gleich.
Wundert euch nicht, dieser O-Ton, weil Merz einfach grund, also wirklich unglaublich
bescheuert ist, hat einen entscheidenden Wortfehler. Den muss dann Simon Strauß
erstmal reparieren, bevor dann
Jasper von Altenbock, also man glaubt es nicht, wie blöde das alles ist.
In dieser Woche war Trump, darüber haben sie mit Friedrich Merz auch gesprochen
und hat durchaus ebenfalls Überraschendes, im Sinne von Überraschendes,
Positives über Trump gesagt.
Und mir hat vorgestern eins gut gefallen von Trump, nicht alles,
aber das hat mir gut gefallen, zu sagen, wir treffen jetzt hier in Zukunft in
Amerika keine einzige Entscheidung mehr, die unter der Überschrift steht,
dient sie der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Industrie, ja oder nein?
Und ich glaube, das ist ein Beispiel für Deutschland.
Und Trump wird uns jetzt zwingen, dass wir uns auf die wesentlichen Themen konzentrieren,
die wir in Europa nur zusammen machen können.
Da hat er, glaube ich, ein Nicht-Vergessen-Nicht. Also in Amerika wird keine
einzige Entscheidung mehr getroffen, die nicht unter der Überschrift steht.
Dient sie der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und sein ist zu Ja.
Man kann ja mal ein Wort vergessen. Ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Wird denn ein Bundeskanzler Merz anders auf einen amerikanischen Präsidenten
Trump reagieren als ein Bundeskanzler Scholz?
Was meinen Sie? Ach, in der Praxis würde ich sagen, wir werden die Unterschiede
gar nicht so groß sein, aber vielleicht verbal in der moralischen Bewertung,
da hält sich Merz zurück.
So, in der moralischen Bewertung, ja okay, kann irgendwas sein,
dass man darüber so und so reden kann, aber eigentlich ist es unverwechselbar.
Merz und Trump ist dasselbe.
Und Merz sagt ja auch, also mir hat nicht alles gefallen von Trump,
als er gesagt hat, Primatwirtschaft, Primatdings, Primat der Stärkere.
Er hat ja bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung eine Rede gehalten,
ich habe es mir rausgeschrieben, da sagte er.
Wenn die Bundesjugendspiele nur noch Teilnehmerurkunden ausstellen,
dann kriegen wir bald auch Olympiaden, es müsste ja Olympische Spiele heißen,
dann kriegen wir bald auch Olympiaden nur noch Teilnehmerurkunden.
Ja, ich kenne jetzt keine Olympiade mit Teilnehmerurkunde.
Interessant ist ja hier, dass…,
Es ist ja interessant, dass er hier von den Olympischen Spielen spricht und
den Erfolgen, die er in der Zukunft für Deutschland sehen will.
Wenn man sich mit irgendwelchen Olympioniken unterhält, dann werden die alle
sagen, es hapert an der staatlichen Finanzierung.
Sie werden keine Antwort geben, sie werden nicht sagen, es ist wegen der Teilnehmerurkunden
oder so etwas, sondern es ist,
dass der Sport und zwar nicht nur jetzt die Förderung der Exzellenzen,
sondern dass die Sportförderung, dass die immer mehr nachlässt und dass die
Kinder oft keine Möglichkeit haben,
überhaupt ein sportliches Talent auszubilden.
Das ist die Antwort dieser Sportler und er sagt einfach nur Wettbewerb,
Wettbewerb ist gut, wenn der Wettbewerb da ist bei den Bundesjugendspielen,
dann wird er auch schon zu olympischen Fähigkeiten führen.
Das ist einfach so ein Unsinn.
Ich will dazu eh mal sagen, hier merken wir so an Gefühlslagen,
also die ich einfach in mir spüre.
Wir haben hier drüben eine Schule, in der, wenn man in den Eingangsbereich reingeht,
unseren Olympioniken viel Erfolg gewünscht wird.
Weil das einfach, die sind zu den letzten Olympischen Spielen gefahren.
Was bedeutet, wer diese Art von Sport auf diesem Niveau nicht nur im Fernsehen
sieht, sondern auch persönlich Leute kennt, die das da mitgemacht haben,
da ist einfach völlig klar, eine Goldmedaille ist sozusagen die Landung auf dem Mars.
Die Teilnahme bei solchen Spielen bringt ganze Stadtteile in Wallung.
Und es reicht auch völlig. Mehr ist nicht zu erreichen.
Und wenn man dann als Politiker, der es eigentlich in der Hand hat,
das finanziellen Grund lang zu sorgen, sagt, nee, also wenn du nur teilnimmst
bei Olympischen Spielen,
dann haben deine Eltern, deine Freunde und du selbst noch nicht genug Beitrag
geleistet. Du musst gewinnen.
Das ist einfach absurd. Also das zeigt echte Menschenverachtung eigentlich.
Das ist ein völlig falsches Menschenbild.
Und immer vorgetragen von Leuten, bei denen man sich tatsächlich fragt,
wo ist die Leistung? Also wo ist die Leistung?
Ja, renn du doch mal 100 Meter. Wann hast du es wirklich?
Wo ist die Leistung bei Horst und Hopf, dass sie gut schnell in Krypto investiert haben?
Ist das eine unternehmerische Leistung? Also wir können uns ja wirklich mal
bei Hidden Champions unternehmerische Leistungen ansehen, in denen Leute jahrzehntelang
ein Unternehmen groß aufbauen.
Da sind unternehmerische Leistungen ja durchaus da und die kann man auch wertschätzen.
Da finden wir sie nicht. Finden wir die bei der CDU?
Was wäre Jens Spahn, wenn er nicht jeden Tag irgendwas Neues in den Medien fordern könnte?
Naja, maximal hätte er wohl irgendwo in einem Dorf einen Posten bei einer Sparkasse
bekommen, wenn er Glück hat.
Dann würde es den Kollegen nicht auffallen, dass er nicht der Beste ist.
Das wäre die eigentliche Situation, in der diese Leute sich befinden.
Und das ist das eine, dass Friedrich Merz hier irgendwie sagt,
der Kampf, die Wirtschaft, das Primat, des Ökonomischen ist hier ganz wichtig.
Nicht nur das, sondern es gibt nur einen zweiten O-Ton.
Wir hatten jetzt, also wie er die Politik selbst auch aus dem Spiel nimmt,
wir hatten jetzt 75 Jahre Grundgesetz feiern.
Was bedeutet, es gibt dazu natürlich große Ausstellungen. In Bonn oder in,
ich glaube es war in Bonn, im Deutschen Haus, so wie es heißt,
gab es eine Ausstellung zum Thema, also Grundgesetz war das Thema, der Kompromiss.
Weil das Grundgesetz organisiert Kompromisse. Das organisiert nicht das Recht
des Stärkeren, sondern es ist klug. Die Leute haben sich was dabei gedacht und
sie haben in die Hölle geschaut, als sie es geschrieben haben. Der Kompromiss.
So, jetzt hören wir hier 40 März dieser Tage.
Mir ist es völlig gleichgültig, wer diesen Weg politisch mitgeht.
Ich sage nur, ich gehe keinen anderen.
Und wer ihn mit mir gehen will, muss sich nach diesen fünf Punkten richten.
Kompromisse sind zu diesen Themen nicht mehr möglich.
Also wenn ein Politiker so redet, dann bitte Bundestag abbauen,
Boxring aufbauen, sich durchsetzen, dann tritt Robert Habeck mit in den Ring
und dann schafft man es, die da zu schlagen oder halt nicht.
So, dann klären wir das so. Naja, hören wir mal in dieses Gespräch über Millay, denn,
es gibt ja natürlich nicht nur Hoss und Hopf als Dunstkreis dieser Idiotie, sondern es gibt ja auch,
andere Leute, die FAZ oder was auch immer, genau, die ein bisschen seriöser
aussehen und uns versuchen hier jetzt in dieser großen Gemengelage,
die wir bis hierhin aufgearbeitet haben, Orientierung zu geben.
Und zwar in dieser Stefan hat gesagt, es sind jetzt Lösungen gefordert,
was könnten denn Lösungen sein.
Also Rainer Hank. Und ich will nochmal sagen, also es ist der Typ,
der bei Lanz neben mir saß, ja, also der hier und so, die Vermieter die mieten und so.
So Rainer Hank, was gibt's zu sagen? Was ist hier los?
Und ich darf mal die ehemalige Justiz Oh.
Wir sind noch gar nicht in diesem Forum, das hören wir gleich.
Rainer Hank war bei Corinna Budras im FAZ-Podcast und hat dort,
das Liberale vorgestellt. Also wir haben ja Was liberal ist.
Wir haben ja Lösungsvorschläge von Millet und so, anarcho-kapitalistisches,
wozu den Staat, also so einen ultra-libertären Ansatz, den verteidigt ihr hier.
Die ehemalige Justizministerin Sabine Leuterser-Schnarrenberger an diesem Punkt zitieren,
immerhin ja auch eine große Liberale, die sagt, Deutschland braucht eine starke
liberale Kraft, die einen klaren Gegenpol zu staatlichem Lirigismus bildet und
die Rechts und Freiheiten der Bürger nicht nur wirtschaftlich,
sondern auch in allen Lebensbereichen verteidigt.
Dazu gehört, gegen soziale Ungleichheit vorzugehen, Aufstiegschancen durch Bildung
zu fördern, den Klimawandel zu bekämpfen.
Und die Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Landes zu sichern, eine libertäre Zerstörung
des Staates, wie Millaisi plant, ist damit unvereinbar.
Also da fragen wir erstens, woher weiß sie, dass er eine Zerstörung des Staates plant?
Vielleicht hat sie einfach hingeguckt, Nachrichten.
Hat den mit der Kettensäge gesehen?
Was, den sie dabei sagt, ist mit Verlaub ein bisschen trivial.
Kann jeder unterschreiben, aber kostet einen dann auch nichts, das zu unterschreiben.
Also das ist, denke ich, doch dem Zeitgeist geschuldet, dieses Zitat,
weil sie weiß, dass es nicht gut ist, das wird sie die FDP sicher nicht über
die 5% bringen, wenn sie jetzt sagen, wir machen hier Kettensägenpolitik, verstehe ich schon.
So, und jetzt fügt er noch etwas an, was so in die Märzrichtung geht.
Die Liberalen sind für Institutionen, aber sie sind zugleich staatsskeptisch
und das geht schon zusammen und man kann es sogar härter sagen,
sie sind auch demokratieskeptisch, was ich finde in Zeiten des Populismus kein
schlechter Ansatz ist, weil Demokratie heißt zunächst nur Mehrheiten bestimmen, wer die Macht hat.
Und dagegen würden Liberale immer sagen, wir müssen Institutionen, unabhängige,
staatsferne Institutionen schaffen, die dafür sorgen, dass die Mehrheit nicht
über die Stränge schlägt, die Minderheiten unterdrückt und populistisch versinkt.
So, jetzt haben wir ja thematisiert, die Schuldenbremse ist vor allem deswegen
ein Problem, weil da irgendwer auf die Idee kam zu sagen, nee,
das können wir auf gar keinen Fall der Demokratie und den Demokraten und den
demokratischen Parteien und den Mehrheitsfindungen im Parlament überlassen.
Das muss Politik fern in einer eigenen Institution, an der man nicht rütteln
kann, institutionalisiert werden. Genauso wie die EZB.
Genauso wie die EZB, genau. Also da ist sozusagen der demokratischen Handhabe entzogen.
Jetzt haben wir hier thematisiert, monatelang, dass die Schuldenbremse den Staat
auf so privates Haushaltsniveau runterzieht, wo es einfach heißt,
also wenn du morgens um 8 nicht zur Arbeit gehst, hast du 16 Uhr nichts zu essen.
So, nein, könnte man ja auch mal umgedreht denken oder anders.
Nein, geht nicht, weil Schuldenbremse.
Und jetzt sagt Rainer Hank, ja, und jetzt sehen wir ja auch diesen Populismus,
wir brauchen noch mehr solche Lösungen wie die Schuldenbremse.
Wir müssen noch mehr Fern der Demokratie installieren und diejenigen,
die dann sagen, aber dann funktioniert die Demokratie nicht mehr,
Ja, das ist völlig zu Recht, dass die das sagen. Diese Demokratie-Skepsis ist
schon, das ist gut begründet. Man sieht ja, dass nichts mehr funktioniert.
Ja.
Da denkt man sich so, okay, also ja.
Diese Ideologie hat ja Grégoire Chamayou in seinem Buch Die unregierbare Gesellschaft
sehr gut aufgezeigt, wie eigentlich diese Neoliberalen alle sagen.
Eigentlich ist das Wahlvolk das Problem.
Wir müssen natürlich so tun, als würden wir eine Liberalität in dem Sinne verkaufen,
dass wir demokratisch sind.
Aber eigentlich sehen wir das Wahlvolk als Problem an. Das könnte ja dies und das auch noch wollen.
Und deswegen müssen wir sehen, dass wir sehr viel absichern vor dem Demos.
Und das ist etwas, was natürlich so Institutionen dann hervorgebracht hat wie die EZB.
Insofern ist es auch interessant, dass die Linkspartei die einzige jetzt gerade ist.
Die fordert, dass die EZB demokratisch gewählt wird, also das Gremium und dass
die EZB auch an das EU-Parlament und durch eine gewisse Ausgabenpolitik und
Entscheidungspolitik gebunden sein soll.
Das heißt, es geht also hier um eine Politisierung der EZB, also genau das,
was natürlich für Rainer Hanke und die anderen zum größten Problem wäre.
Und damit greifen sie wirklich diesen MMT-Gedanken von Stephanie Kelton am radikalsten
auf, weil die das ja auch genau sagen.
Sie sagen, dieses Geld des Staates ist ja das Geld der Wähler,
die darüber bestimmen können und es ist eben nicht das, was man vor den Wählern schützen soll.
Was hier eigentlich Rainer Hank sich vorstellt, ist ja eine technokratisch-oligarchisch-organisierte
Gesellschaft und da passt es natürlich sehr gut,
dass man so eine Strongman-Politik hat, denn die Starken, die sich durchgesetzt
haben, die werden ja schon wissen, wofür es gut ist und die anderen haben sich
dann in ihrem Platz einzuordnen.
Stell dir mal vor, die EZB hätte nicht nur ein Mandat 2% Inflation,
sondern auch Arbeitsmarktzahlen oder so.
Steht tatsächlich im Parteiprogramm der Linken drin, dass eigentlich es doch
um Vollbeschäftigung gehen müsste.
Womit die Linke dann sagt, wir möchten uns gerne orientieren an einem Beispiel,
dem hardcore kapitalistisch amerikanischen. Wer kann denn was dagegen haben?
Man fragt sich so, ja genau, wer kann denn da jetzt was dagegen haben?
Wenn schon, dann doch, warum nicht?
So, jetzt zu diesem SWR 2 oder SWR Kulturforum, wie es jetzt heißt.
Stefan Kuliff ist wissenschaftlicher Leiter des Ludwig Erhard Forums. Man redet über Millet.
Und ich widerspreche, dass wir sozusagen von Musk und Millet nichts lernen könnten.
Ich halte die Kettensäge-Metapher für problematisch, aber gleichzeitig auch
für ein Stück weit wegweisend, wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen.
Problematisch, aber wegweisend.
Dass man vielleicht keine Kettensäge
braucht, weil das tatsächlich ein Instrument der Revolution ist.
Das ist eigentlich witzig. Die Kettensäge und die Gießkanne,
das sind ja alles so, wir gehen jetzt mal raus und arbeiten.
Wir erledigen jetzt mal Sachen. Am Ende des Tages wissen wir,
was wir getan haben. Die Blumen gegossen, den Baum geschnitten.
Aber eine Gartenschere oder eine...
Jetzt kommt die Gartenschere.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip diese Idee von der Frau von Robinson Crusoe.
Zum Haushalt gehört den Garten.
Der diesen Garten da pflegt und da seinen Haushalt macht.
Eine Heckenschere.
Ja gut, wenn du alleine auf der Welt bist, ist natürlich der Staat bist du,
weißt du? Dann gilt ja die Logik auch.
Das wäre ja der Wunsch.
Dann musst du mit deinem Bizeps klarkommen.
Das wäre der Wunsch der meisten dort.
Oder eine Heckenschere. Jedenfalls ein reformerisches Instrument. Denn wenn wir sagen...
Die Heckenschere als reformerisches Element.
Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft ist ein Garten. Dann sind wir uns,
glaube ich, momentan alle einig, dass es dem deutschen Garten nicht gut geht.
Und eine schwungvoll, stetig und kontinuierlich geschwungene Garten- oder Heckenschere
ist, glaube ich, durchaus etwas, was wir gebrauchen können.
Disruption, komisches Wort, ist vielleicht nichts anderes als das,
was Bundespräsident Roman Herzog mit seiner Ruckrede meinte.
Und wenn man sich diese Ruckrede ranhört, dann hört man heraus,
dass da ein ähnlicher Wunsch danach ist, dass sehr viel Gartenschere notwendig
ist, damit Deutschland wieder nach vorne kommt.
Die Ruckrede, ganz interessant, Roman Herzog bezog sich ja in dieser Rede auch
auf Bill Gates, der damals als der große disruptive Akteur aufgetreten ist,
in den 90er Jahren war Roman Herzog.
Ja, und dann hat er sich auf Gates bezogen, also dass jemand da in der Garage
und du kennst diese ganzen Silicon Valley Geschichte.
Also das ist eigentlich der Bezug da, dass da plötzlich so viel passiert und
es stimmt, dass das eine disruptive Rede ist.
Also diese Ruckrede sagt ja eigentlich, wir brauchen mehr Privatisierung,
mehr Neoliberalisierung, weniger Staat.
Wir brauchen jetzt diese schlanken
flexiblen Strukturen, was heißt Arbeitsrechte, Schleifen und und und,
tatsächlich hat Roman Herzog hier nicht einfach so eine Aufrüttelrede gehalten,
so eine mentale Sache der Gemütszustand Deutschland passt mir nicht wir brauchen anderen,
sondern es war schon damit ausgesagt wir brauchen jetzt neoliberale Reformen
und da hat er völlig recht, dass das so ist das wurde aber von den meisten nie
so erkannt, sondern man hat einfach nur gedacht, das ist aber gut,
dass da mal einer makrige Worte an den Tag legt.
Okay.
Patrick Bernau findet es natürlich alles grandios.
Also man kann das schaffen. Man kann das auch schaffen, ohne so zu werden wie Musk und Millet.
Aber man muss wirklich jetzt, und ich nehme das Bild von Stefan Kohlöfter auf,
man muss da jetzt wirklich mit der Heckenschere rangehen.
Ja, und ich bin sehr dafür. Wir setzen ja die Heckenschere an bei den Multimillionären
und Milliardären, bei den Vermietern.
Also da müssen wir überall mit der Heckenschere ran.
Ganz genau. Ich finde auch, der Staat ist so aufgebläht. 60 Milliarden für Dienstwagen
und so ein Scheiß, das ist doch alles bescheuert.
Sollen die doch, also der Stärkste bitte, ja.
Bitte aus eigener Kraft. Nicht einfach glauben, mit Geld könnte man sich jetzt
Muskeln kaufen, wie einen großen Motor oder so.
Also die Ideologie, man muss halt mit ihr dann mal ins Gericht gehen und dann
wird es, glaube ich, auch amüsant und spielerisch.
Aber nicht, wenn man Dunia Ali zuschaut, wie sie, ohne es zu merken,
ohne es zu wollen und deswegen besonders wirkmächtig, aus so einer Hauptideologie
macht und dann sitzen alle vorm Fernseher und sagen, Ja, seht ihr? Sie sagt es auch.
Gut, Österreich. Was ist in Österreich passiert? In Österreich ist Deutschlands Zukunft.
Diese Pointe ist nicht ganz falsch. In Österreich passiert es einfach immer
alles nur ein bisschen früher und deswegen gucken wir jetzt in die Zukunft.
Und wir hören uns aber, wir wissen ja, was passiert ist. Nur die Urteile so ein bisschen an.
Vielleicht machen wir kurz einen Hinweis auf den Salon an dieser Stelle und was wir lesen wollen.
Dann möchte ich mir auch noch erlauben zu sagen, weil du schon Österreich jetzt
erwähnst, dass ich bald auch in Wien sein werde.
Oh, ich auch, im April.
Und zwar am 1.3. bin ich in Wien mit Ole und Jean-Philippe zusammen.
Die internationale Tour.
Auf meiner Homepage kann man dann Welttour schauen, wo es Karten gibt.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Wir sind am 11.2. auch in München.
Und am 25.02. bin ich in Berlin und halte dann bei der Böckler Stiftung einen Vortrag.
Alles weitere findet man da auf der Homepage. Wir werden ja jetzt weiter über die Demokratie reden.
Müssen wir sie schützen? Wenn ja, vor wem? Und da passt es natürlich gut,
dass Marc Schieritz, der Zeitredakteur ist, ein Buch geschrieben hat mit dem
Titel Zu dumm für die Demokratie? Fragezeichen.
Wir wollen sehen, ob es ein Ausrufezeichen wird, wenn man das ganze Buch gelesen
hat. Naja, wir müssen schauen.
Kommt ja erst am dritten.
Wir versuchen diese Debatte natürlich wieder aufzugreifen, die wir jetzt schon
hatten mit Veit Selig, Blüter und Mano.
Haben wir eine Demokratiedämmerung? Woran hapert es eigentlich?
Das ist also das Buch eigentlich der Stunde, denn wir können uns diese Frage
zu dumm für die Demokratie von sehr vielen Richtungen ausstellen und werden
sehr häufig den Eindruck haben, ja offenbar sind da viele zu dumm für die Demokratie.
Das ist jedenfalls das Buch, das wir im Salon lesen werden. Für die Leute,
die jetzt zum ersten Mal zuhören oder noch nicht so richtig zugehört haben bei den Folgen davor.
Der Salon ist der Zusatzinhalt der 29er.
Das heißt, manchmal bekomme ich eine E-Mail und werde gefragt,
ja, aber warum gibt es nur den Salonteaser?
Da fehlt da noch irgendwas. Und sage ich, ja, das genau ist hinter der Paywall.
Also es gibt meistens einen Salon oder es gibt immer einen Salonteaser.
Da reden wir aber meistens nochmal über einen eigenes kleines Thema und dann
sprechen wir im Salon über ein Buch gemeinsam, das wir gelesen haben.
Das wird dann in diesem Falle Marc Schieretz sein.
Das war das letzte Mal das neue Buch von Eva Illus und außerdem.
Nachdem wir dann so meistens zwei Stunden darüber diskutiert haben über das
Buch, sprechen wir dann noch jeweils über unsere Empfehlungen.
Jeder bringt fünf Empfehlungen des Monats mit, das können Artikel sein,
ich bring meistens auch noch einen Roman mit.
Das, was wir als wichtig empfinden. Und da sich ja jetzt viele vorgenommen haben,
mehr zu lesen, also das ist ja immer auf diesen...
Nein, nein, das ist ja immer auf diesen Listen, was kann man im neuen Jahr so
machen, dann ist natürlich Sport an erster Stelle,
zweitens vielleicht Ernährung und dann kommt aber meistens schon an dritter,
vierter Stelle Lesen, also wer sich jetzt vielleicht auch vorgenommen hat,
mehr zu lesen, soll jetzt nicht nur den Salon vielleicht nur hören und sagen,
naja, dann brauche ich das alles nicht zu lesen, sondern es kann natürlich auch
der Anlass sein zu sagen,
gut, dann lese ich das Buch auch oder eines der Bücher, die empfohlen werden,
das ist also auch eine Möglichkeit oder auch mal darüber hinaus dann was lesen, was wir so empfehlen.
Der Salon ist wie folgt zu erreichen.
Man geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Button, da steht Salon und der führt zu Steady.
Das ist also dann die Payroll-Seite, da wird man aufgefordert 3 Euro im Monat
zu bezahlen und dann kann man das ganze Archiv hören, weil es einfacher haben will.
Bei Apple Podcasts ist mit einem Klick bezahlt.
Der Salon verfügbar oder bei Patreon, falls jemand schon einen Account dort
hat, kann er dort konsumieren.
Apropos lesen, oder möchtest du noch was sagen?
Nein.
Okay, apropos lesen, also ich blogge jetzt wieder, geht auf meine Webseite, lest meine Texte.
Ich gebe mir sehr viel Mühe mit der Wortwahl, weil das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Selbst typografische Uneinheitlichkeiten kann ich noch mit GPT und Claude und
wie sie alle heißen so weit klären,
dass die Texte, was Grammatik und Textgestaltung, Typografie einfach perfekt
sind. Und ich meine wirklich perfekt.
Also da ist jedes kleine Apostroph, wie macht man das mit diesem Genitiv,
wenn der März mit einem Zischlaut endet und was auch immer. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Das sind einfach so Rundowns in der Post-Production, die man heute so machen kann.
Also falls ihr kleine Konjunktivfehler noch findet, das sind bewusste Sätze.
Alles, was zu lesen ist, ist bewusst gewollt. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Falls ihr Zeitungsredakteure seid und so, schaut euch das mal an,
wie diese Technik da funktioniert.
Also ich meine jetzt hier GPT und Klot und so, wie weit die da einem da helfen
kann. Wirklich erstaunlich. Außerdem,
Du hast mich ja darauf gebracht, eine Signieraktion für die Kinderwüste zu machen.
So langsam wächst der Bestand und ich habe natürlich angekreuzt,
dass ich persönliche Grußworte schreibe, was zu Arbeit führen wird.
Ich will, dass Stefan mal richtig ans Arbeiten kommt. Deswegen ist es wichtig,
das Buch vorzubestellen. Und zwar auf eine Widmung zu bestehen.
Und zwar findet man da dann einen Link in der Folge und dann geht man zur Autorenwelt,
kann da das Buch von Stefan bestellen. Aber dann gibt es da die persönliche Widmung.
Also Grußworte, persönliche Namen und so.
Wir wollen ihn schon hart ans Arbeiten bekommen. Ich bin sehr gespannt,
wie viele Bücher du am Ende dort nicht nur unterzeichnen, sondern auch widmen musst.
Insofern, ja, das ist dann neben der Salonlektüre auch noch vielleicht eine spannende Lektüre.
So, gucken wir uns noch schnell Österreich an zu diesem Themenkomplex.
Vier Clips, alle von Florian Gasser, den ich wirklich grandios finde.
Er macht vor allem den transalpinen Podcast der Zeit mit seinem deutschen und
Schweizer Counterpart, was die Federführung für die politischen Teile angeht, der Zeitung.
Und wir hören ihn hier in seinem eigenen Podcast, Servus heißt er,
oder im Politikteil, wo er nochmal zu Gast ist.
Und er thematisiert mal ein Problem, das wir in Deutschland als allererstes angehen müssen.
Es ist eine Anklage an die Politiker, aber es ist auch eine Anklage an uns selber.
Also meine Behauptung wäre, vielleicht kommen wir noch mal dazu,
dass es vor allem in der ÖVP, in den wirtschaftsnahen Kreisen,
die sehr mächtig dort sind, die Überlegung gibt, es ist uns eigentlich egal,
mit wem wir regieren, Hauptsache unsere Interessen werden umgesetzt und diese
Interessen sind zum Beispiel eben geringere Steuern und so weiter.
Und mit wem wir die umsetzen, ist uns eigentlich wurscht. Das wäre meine Antwort darauf.
Und zurück zu den Wahlkämpfen mit diesen Richtungsentscheidungen und diesem
Ausnahmezustand, die immer ausgerufen wird, was halt dann ist,
wenn die Wahlen vorbei sind,
dann fängt man an, Koalitionsgespräche zu führen in eine Art und Weise,
als sei nichts passiert vorher, als sei das eben keine Zäsur,
die da gerade passiert ist.
Das sind einfach normale Gespräche.
Und am Ende zerkracht man sich wegen Dingen wie der Körperschaftssteuer.
Klar schnell, was das ist.
Körperschaftssteuer. Oder die Bankenabgabe war zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding,
die gibt es in Österreich, ich nenne sie Stabilitätsabgabe, seit 2011,
Banken müsste ab einer gewissen Summe, ab einer Bemessungsgrundlage von einer
Milliarde Euro an 0,0 irgendwas abgeben.
Du hast mir gestern den Betrag zu 150 Millionen geworfen gegeben und ich musste
gut lachen. Also ich meine, das ist ja...
Das ist, und an sowas zerstreitet man sich.
Wegen sowas lässt man was auseinanderfliegen und ebnet Herbert Kickl den Weg
ins Kanzleramt. Das ist eine Form der Unernsthaftigkeit und Unaufrichtigkeit
im Umgang mit autoritären Kräften, dass einem wirklich schlecht werden kann.
Den Transfer kann man ja hier schon leisten. Wir sehen jetzt schon in einem
Video, Friedrich Merz, da stehen, der sagt, der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland ist bedroht.
Alle, die morgens auf die Arbeit gehen oder auch noch wollen,
dass ihre Kinder einen Job haben, müssen verstehen,
dass wir nur mit einer Senkung der Unternehmenssteuer,
wir haben da einen Fünf-Programm-Plan, was wir da vorm stellen.
Nur diese Vision ist die einzige, die wir verfolgen.
Kompromisslos. Egal, wer mitstimmt.
So wird es sein. Man wird sagen, wir sind diejenigen, die,
unseren Wirtschaftsstandort schützen und wer für unseren Wirtschaftsstandort
ist, der stimmt für diese neue Resolution.
Also ganz egal, wer es sein wird, auch die AfD wird gern genommen.
So wird es kommen. Ich sage es dir, denn die Koalition, die wir erst einmal
bekommen, wird nicht eine schwarz-blaue sein,
davon gehen wir jetzt mal nicht aus, aber man wird dann solche Kämpfe dort erleben
und am Ende wird so ein paar Millionen oder vielleicht auch ein paar Milliarden Euro gehen.
Man würde sagen, jetzt ist aber hier Schluss.
Irgendwo müssen wir auch noch vernünftig bleiben. So ist ja immer eine Rede
von Friedrich Merz. Er ist ja der Meister der Vernunft, das heißt meistens der
einfältigen Gedanken und deswegen ist uns jedes Mittel recht.
Also wir haben es jetzt ein bisschen im Blick. Heute ist noch nichts passiert
im Bundestag, aber es ist ja auch noch Mittag.
Aber es ist ja das nächste Gesetz in der Mache, das schon auf diese Art und
Weise noch zur Migration.
Als nächstes dann, naja gut, bei Migration, okay, das war ein Fehler, das tut mir auch leid.
Aber jetzt bei Wirtschaft, also da kann mir jetzt wirklich egal sein,
wer da mitstimmt. Das sind jetzt die vernünftigen Sachen.
Also das AfD-Wirtschaftsprogramm und das CDU-Wirtschaftsprogramm,
wenn man mal diese Währungsidiotie von wir gehen aus dem Euro raus bei der AfD
und so, wenn wir das mal wegnehmen, dann ist das in vielen Punkten sehr deckungsgleich.
Genau.
Das Problem ist eben, dass das, was die Partei eigentlich will,
steht halt nicht im Programm.
Also da kommt es dann halt zu Unschärfen, aber konnte man ja nicht wissen,
war ja nirgendwo zu lesen.
Ja, du sagst da jetzt gerade etwas, Mir ist was aufgefallen.
Es gibt ja immer so eine Steuer, die kann man anheben.
Mit denen kann man ärmere Leute stärker belasten.
Mit der kann man eine Rentenkürzung vollziehen.
Und mit dieser Steuer kann man auch dafür sorgen, dass es den anderen besser
geht und die Staatsannahmen erheblich steigen.
Das wäre die Mehrwertsteuer. die Mehrwertsteuer ist da kein Thema sie ist aber
in Österreich Thema gewesen,
sie steht nirgends drin aber es steht auch nirgends wir schließen eine Mehrwertsteuer aus wenn.
Du es vorher reinschreibst schreibst du 16% rein und dann werden es aber 19% und so.
Und Österreich als ich das mit Österreich mitbekam dachte ich okay achte mal
in den Programmen drauf da kommt es aber nicht vor ja.
Genau, also es steht nicht in dem Programm, aber die Ideologie ist klar.
Also was Mehrwertschauern so angeht, da sind sie sich einig.
Wir hören das jetzt über die ÖVP.
Es gilt wortgleich auch für die CDU.
Also einerseits in der ÖVP hassen weite Teile die Sozialdemokratie.
Also da reden wir wirklich über tiefsitzenden Hass. Aber das hat doch mit der
Frage nichts zu tun. Doch, jetzt warte.
Vor allem gegen Andreas Babler, der die SPÖ nach links gerückt hat,
der so klassenkämpferische Töne anschlägt und so weiter.
Und im FPÖ-Programm steht auch was drinnen, nämlich, dass sie niedrigere Steuern
wollen. So, ist doch cool.
Und was man mit der FPÖ nicht muss, das ist total praktisch,
man muss nicht schauen, dass man die untersten sozialen Schichten in irgendeiner
Weise unterstützt, sondern denen kann man im Zweifel auch noch was wegnehmen.
Das haben sie von 2017 bis 2019 auch schon gemacht.
Und das geht mit der Sozialdemokratie halt zum Beispiel nicht.
Das wäre mit den NEOS übrigens auch nur schwer gegangen.
Es steht natürlich nicht drinnen im FPÖ-Parteiprogramm, wie die irgendwas von
dem finanzieren wollen, was sie da verlangen.
Also auf die ärmsten Bizeps. Der Staat wird mit deren Bizeps verteidigt.
Ihr eigenes Schicksal wird mit ihrem Bizeps, also geh ins Gym.
Warte nicht auf den Staat, er hat ihr nichts im Angebot. Im Politikteil bringt
er das nochmal schön zusammen.
Also man macht dann im Anschluss fantasielose Koalitionsgespräche,
tauscht in alter Manier die Themen ab, obwohl man irgendwann in der Form gesagt
hat, ja, wir haben verstanden, ja.
Man nimmt dem einen was weg in diesen Koalitionsgesprächen, freut sich diebisch
darüber, zieht rote Linien ein, bei denen klar ist, dass der andere nicht drüber kann.
Also das ist eine Form von Unernsthaftigkeit.
Damit ist hier zum Beispiel gemeint, Söder sagt nicht mit den Grünen.
Das ist diese Unernsthaftigkeit.
Im Umgang mit diesem Phänomen von allen anderen Parteien, die wirklich atemberaubend ist.
Und Lenz Jakobsen hat es in unserem Podcast diese Woche eine Form von Arbeitsverweigerung genannt.
Ich finde, das trifft schon ganz gut. Also man muss eine Zäsur schon erstens
erkennen und wenn man sie erkennt, auch Schlüsse daraus ziehen und die ernst nehmen.
Zäsuren erkennen. Wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Er kommt jetzt mit einer Lösung für ein sehr großes Problem es könnte auch für die CDU eine Lösung sein,
Wir kriegen ja wohl jetzt die nächsten Tage erste Hochrechnung,
den es heißt CDU minus zwei Prozent und wie auch immer, denn es gibt ja noch
andere Leute, sind ja nicht nur Rechtsradikale in Deutschland.
Angela Merkel hat sich ja gegen Friedrich Merz geahnt mit einem Statement.
Michel Friedmann nach 40 Jahren aus der CDU ausgetreten.
Der Holocaust überlebende Albrecht Weinberg ist so weit gegangen,
dass er das Bundesverdienstkreuz zurückschickt.
Das sind schon Dinge, die dafür sorgen, dass manche bei der CDU vielleicht einmal nachdenken werden.
Was jetzt bedeutet, März ist verbrannt.
Also es ist einfach sozusagen, der Makel hängt jetzt an ihm,
selbst wenn man so noch Kanzler wird, ist das Biegen und Brechen.
Kommt drauf an bei wem, also bei Leuten, die jetzt noch klar denken können,
aber es war zugleich an dem Tag, hat
unsere geliebte Marion Horn von der Bild-Zeitung, hat dort geschrieben,
das sei ein wunderbares Statement für Klarheit und Entscheidungsfreude und was weiß ich alles.
Das kann man natürlich auch so sehen. Florian Gasser erklärt jetzt hier,
wo noch die Einflugschneise für konservative Kräfte sind, die noch etwas bewegen wollen und,
vielleicht nochmal Lust haben auf ein bisschen mehr politische Unterstützung
als nur so ein 30% Scheiße eigentlich Überlebenskampf.
Oh krass, 28 Scheiße, alle haben schlechte Laune. Das führt ja nirgendwo hin.
Wir brauchen redliche Konservative.
Variiere nochmal meine Frage vom Anfang. Jetzt unseriös. Genau, die prognostische.
Wenn wir jetzt nochmal auf die ÖVP gucken, was müsste die denn jetzt tun oder
was könnte die denn tun, damit es sie jetzt nicht zerbröselt in dieser Gemengelage?
Boah, das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Darf ich die vielleicht ein bisschen anders, also ich komme drauf,
versprochen. Du darfst sie umschreiben, die Frage.
Weil, es ist ja so, es gibt sehr viele Bücher und kluge Texte dazu,
dass es, wenn es um die Frage geht, ob ein Land Richtung autoritär kippt,
es um das Verhalten der konservativen Kraft geht.
Es braucht in einer Demokratie eine redliche konservative Kraft.
Das Problem der ÖVP ist, dass sie unredlich worden ist und zwar spätestens unter Sebastian Kurz.
Sie hat mit Populismus geliebäugelt, sie hat die Justiz angegriffen,
sie hat xenophobe Ressentiments benutzt, all diese Dinge, die man eben auch
von der FPÖ kennt und sie hat es nicht geschafft in dieser nicht sehr langen
Postkurzzeit sich aus diesem politischen Schmuddelgeschäft wieder auszusteigen.
Und das ist doch ein Problem für
sich. Jetzt unabhängig von AfD und Bundestagsdebatten und was auch immer.
Zu behaupten, man könnte Deutschland abschotten. Kein einziger kommt hier mehr rein. Ist unredlich.
Diese Idee von Sicherheit für alle, es wird nichts mehr passieren.
Unredlich. All diese Vorschläge, die da jetzt kommen, sind einfach unredlich.
Also für sich alleine schon.
Dass sie dann noch verkauft werden mit dem Subtext, die AfD hatte immer recht
und jetzt müssen wir es auch kompromisslos umsetzen, liegt ja nur noch sozusagen
ein Schleier drüber, der die Färbung mitgibt.
Aber inhaltlich und intrinsisch ist die Programmatik der CDU absolut unredlich.
Sie läuft auf Lüge hinaus und sie wird unauthentisch vorgetragen.
Wir haben ja jetzt hier nicht so einen Friedrich Merz, der wie Meloni antritt
und am Ende stellt man fest, sie hat es nicht so hingekriegt mit ihren Zielen,
aber wir haben es ihr geglaubt. Sie will es wirklich.
Das ist ja bei Merz nicht so. Bei Merz sehen noch alle, will seine Biografie
veredeln, ihm fehlt noch der letzte Tritt gegen Angela Merkel.
Er möchte, und dass er ausgerechnet jetzt den bekommt, so ist ja natürlich auch absurd.
Ich möchte euch einen Podcast empfehlen, der es ein bisschen richtig macht.
Denn wir haben hier Strongmans, die glauben ihr Bizeps, die diese Ideologie
vertreiben und so weiter und so fort.
Und es gibt einen, den muss man auch so ein bisschen amüsiert gucken, The Midas Touch.
Irgendwie relativ neu, ich kenne den noch gar nicht so lange.
Und mir gefällt einfach der Sing-Sang die ganze Zeit.
Also wer in der Frequenz von Hoss und Hopf jetzt einfach Gegenrede haben will
und zwar inhaltlich auf demselben Niveau, aber auch in einer Art und Weise vorgetragen,
in der nicht die ganze Zeit...
In diesem Podcast nochmals dafür gedankt wird, dass, und bitte lest unsere Bücher,
also so Appellativ und Befehlston, sondern einfach nur so, nee,
wir haben uns das angeguckt, irgendwie blöd, das ist bescheuert,
wir machen uns mal drüber lustig.
Der hört diesen Podcast, wir hören uns das anderthalb Minuten an,
an der Stelle, wo man Trump auch ärgern kann, weil es ihn einfach kränkt.
Einschaltquoten seiner Amtseinführung war bisher gar kein großes Thema. Hier dann doch.
Trumps Inauguration Ratings down bigly from Biden's. It goes on to say how 24.59
million viewers tuned into the Trump inauguration.
That's 27% lower than President Biden's 2021 inauguration, which had 33.76 million
viewers tracked from 17 channels.
Donald Trump also had 19.75% lower viewers than his first pathetic inauguration.
Remember where we had those really small crowd sizes and his press team tried
to act like this was the largest inauguration in history.
You had lower ratings than that, Donald, and President Biden beat you.
Also, this whole inauguration was like probably the weakest,
most pathetic and humiliating inauguration in history, Not just from the perspective
of these very low, small, teeny tiny ratings,
Donald, but also Donald Trump blamed cold weather as the reason why he was bringing
the inauguration from outside, inside, into the rotunda.
Und guess what, Donald, when President Obama had millions of people show up
for his inauguration after the 2008 election, it was basically the same exact weather.
In meinem Podcatcher Hoss und Hopf und Midas Touch, das wechselt sich die ganze
Zeit ab, ich werde hier nur...
Schön. Ja, gratuliere.
Wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen über Wirtschaft geredet, haben aber ein ökonomisches
Feld bislang außer Acht gelassen.
Und zwar… Die Milch.
Nein, die Sammelkarten.
Oh, ey.
Und zwar war es so, ich habe mit Thomas und Michael zusammengesessen,
die von Fatboy-Filmen sind und erwachsen sind und meine Filmanalyse drehen.
Und Thomas erzählte mir dann irgendwann sehr begeistert von seinen Sammelkarten
und von diesem ganzen Hype.
Und er redete immer weiter und dann dachte ich, das ist das Thema.
Das ist das Thema, das wir hier unbedingt verhandeln müssen.
Vielleicht werden sich man es ja erinnern, wir haben mal über...
Über NFT-Karten gesprochen.
Die gibt es auch nach wie vor, aber dieser NFT-Hype ist ja etwas abgeflaut.
Aber dieses Sammelkarten-Ding ist eines, an dem wir ganz viel jetzt lernen können.
Also es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass wir jetzt Expertise nur erwerben in Form
von was muss ich jetzt investieren in Sammelkarten, sondern über die Idee Wirtschaft
oder sagen wir eher wie Leute heute über Wirtschaft denken,
was das eigentlich bedeutet, Wenn jetzt so ein Donald Trump im Amt ist und der
umgibt sich mit lauter Influencern für so Sammelkartenkram und so,
was das eigentlich bedeutet.
Das heißt, da hängt also sehr viel mehr dran. Ich sage hier als Disclaimer ausdrücklich,
ich habe ja jetzt auch Sammelkartenanhänger kennengelernt.
Nicht heißt das Sammelkartensammler sind rechts oder sind irgendwie sonst dubios.
Ich will nur sagen, das gesamte System, das da aufgebaut wird,
das ist eines, das tatsächlich an ein Pyramidensystem erinnert,
das tatsächlich daran erinnert, dass wir es hier mit Strukturen zu tun haben.
Gut, ich sage nämlich schon, alle Achtjährigen, die ich kenne,
werden jetzt plötzlich als Rechts- und Dubios hängt.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das, was da so noch dran hängt an Ökonomie,
was da sich jetzt drum gebaut hat, etwas ist, was uns sehr viel darüber aussagen
kann, wie viele Leute jetzt über Wirtschaft nachdenken.
Und dass es hier auch wieder geht Survival of the fittest,
Oder sagen wir eher, wer zuerst kommt, mal zuerst. Man muss clever sein,
man muss Glück haben, die ganze Glücksspielindustrie.
Wir werden nachher auch Montana Black hören.
All das, was heute so in den Köpfen vieler junger Menschen, aber dann auch älterer
Menschen drin ist, denn dieses Sammelkartenphänomen ist nicht eins von Achtjährigen,
ist auch nicht eins von 18-Jährigen, sondern das geht weit durch alle Alterskohorten hindurch.
Das ist eines, das so dominant ist, dass wir an ihm allegorisch sehen können,
wie Leute eigentlich darüber nachdenken.
Also wer immer so sagt, Squid Game ist ja interessant, das erzählt so viel über
den Kapitalismus, dann würde ich sagen, ja das stimmt.
Aber die Sammelkarten und die Ökonomie, die erzählen auch wahnsinnig viel über den Kapitalismus.
Da habe ich eine Impression schildern. Du erzählst jetzt irgendwas von allegorisch
und ich denke mir nur, Wolfgang, da liegt eine sehr bunte Packung mit Dingern.
Machen wir die jetzt endlich auf oder was ist denn los?
Nein, so schnell geht das ja nicht. Wir machen das spannend. Ich habe mir...
Ich bin auch schon ganz angefixt, Funcht-Karten.
Mein lieber Freund Thomas hat mir eine Packung besorgt, denn ich dachte,
ich kaufe einfach mal Sammelkarten, ich bestelle was im Internet.
Nein, um Gottes Willen, es müssen natürlich bestimmte Sammelkarten sein.
Und ich kann das schon mal ankündigen, wir öffnen nachher Pokémon-Sammelkarten
und zwar aus dieser Reihe prismatische Entwicklungen.
Sehr begehrt, hat man mir gesagt. Und man hat mir auch gesagt,
worauf wir zu achten haben. Also man darf da jetzt auch gleich,
man muss die Finger auch sauber halten und so, man darf da jetzt gleich,
wir fassen hier möglicherweise gleich pures Gold an.
Also das sind wertvolle Sachen. Wir nähern uns dem aber erst einmal über einen Netflix-Trader.
Es gibt eine Serie, die heißt King of Collectibles, die geht jetzt bald wohl
in die dritte Staffel schon, The Golden Touch.
Dieser Golden ist ein Mensch, der nicht nur gerne sammelt, sondern eine Plattform
errichtet hat, auf der alle möglichen Sammlerobjekte versteigert verkauft werden können.
Das fängt an bei Sammelkarten. Eine Börse geht über zu original getragene Trikots
von Michael Jordan und und und. Ja, also alles mögliche kannst du dort,
alles was irgendwelche besonderen Gucci-Taschen.
Alles das, was Trump in seinem Büro aufstapelt, als die Insignien der amerikanischen
Geschichte, die er jetzt weiterschreiben möchte.
Zum Beispiel kannst du noch, gibt es auch eine Folge zu, nicht eine ganze Folge
zu, aber in einer Folge kommt das vor, dort geht es um die amerikanische Verfassung,
da gab es so einen Sammler-Hype im 19.
Jahrhundert, dann hat man die teuer reproduziert oder nochmal abgeschrieben
und so und diese Sammlerstücke sind auch ganz selten und da kannst du dir ja
vorstellen, da scharen sich dann auch viele drum, um da so ein uraltes Stück
Papier in der Hand zu haben.
Wir versuchen uns über diesen Trailer einmal einen Eindruck zu vermitteln, worum es da geht.
Und wir sehen hier Golden schon im Privatschat fliegt er natürlich zu den einzelnen Meetings.
Competition, Ego, Money.
Kommt uns irgendwie alles bekannt vor? Haben wir doch heute schon mal gehört.
People love doing business with me. Golden Auctions is the world's largest collectible marketplace.
We find the greatest collectibles in the world. What do you think? Wow.
Somebody in Japan, Australia, the United States, they can all be bidding against
each other for a rare collectible.
This is hochkompetitiv.
Jeder wettet gegen jeden. Wer macht das beste Offer?
Beyond rare. Hidden treasure exists out there. Das ist das, was ich nicht wirklich?
Es könnte 500,000, 600,000. Wow! Du hast nichts gesehen.
Das ist der Original Apple One Computer. Der Jacky Robinson-Jerzy.
Wenn Ken setzt ein Tast auf dich zu machen, du musst es tun.
Wir sind literally überhört, überhört, oder?
Was können Sie uns jetzt? $1 Million, in der Cash-Up-Front, jetzt.
Wenn ich das nicht so erfolgreich, dann meine competitors will. Du hast ja oder nicht.
Wenn er es nicht erfolgreich machen kann, dann macht das ein Gegner in Wettbewerb.
Das ist diese Welt der Atome, die Graber und Thiel da so interessiert hat.
Nicht die Bits, sondern die Atome. Und wenn schon nichts weitergeht,
dann zumindest nochmal die Geschichte.
Ja und wir sprechen über die materielle Welt jetzt. Das ist das Interessante jetzt hier.
Wir haben es mit einem Business zu tun, das absolut die Digitalisierung braucht
insofern, als dort die Plattformen sind.
Aber es geht jetzt wirklich um die Gegenstände.
Hat dieses Glas vielleicht schon mal Prinz, weiß ich nicht wer.
Angefasst?
Ist dieses alte Trikot noch ungewaschen und sofort wieder verpackt worden?
Ich muss kurz, Chris Christie war bei John Stewart im Podcast und hat dort erzählt,
wie er zu Trump ins Weiße Haus ging und Trump auf den Schreibtisch von Lincoln zeigte und meinte,
dort hat er die Gettysburg-Adress geschrieben und Christie so,
nee, jeder weiß, der saß da im Zug.
Und dann Donald Trump so, aber ich bin der Präsident.
Das ist der Schreibtisch.
Er authentifiziert das und dann ist das so.
Ich hoffe,
es zu brechen den Rekord für den wichtigsten Sport item, die ich ever sold habe.
Wo diese Klocke steckt, und wenn sie nicht ihre Bid in, bevor es zu zählen wird,
sie nie werden die Chance zu haben.
Hier geht's. Wir wissen nie, was der Ende resultat wird.
Oh, hier ist es. Und ich sage, es muss auf die Hüte sein. Die einzige Frage ist...
Wie hoch wird es gehen?
Er hat sich natürlich auch in dieser Serie mit Logan Paul getroffen.
Dort ist es so, dass sie ganz teure Pokémon-Karten-Sets aufmachen.
Das habe ich mal gesehen.
Dort sind dann 80, 90 Pakete drin. Also Logan Paul macht das ja auch zu einem
Dauerprogramm bei sich.
Jedenfalls treffen sie sich und dann fährt Logan Paul nochmal los und sagt,
ja jetzt war das erste nicht gut.
Jetzt machen wir nochmal eins auf, das ist 230.000 Dollar wert und das ist aber
dann auch wieder nichts.
Wir hören da mal kurz rein. Wenigen.
12.000-Dollar-Card und PSA 10. Will McCreasy, kann man einen 3-Pit machen?
Oh mein Gott, du hast den besten Glück! Ein Nine-Tails, oh mein Gott!
Perfekt. Ein schönes Card. Will, du hast es wieder gemacht, irgendwie.
Logan Paul, muss man vielleicht für die Leute, die den nicht so kennen,
erklären, ist ein Influencer, der über Musical.ly berühmt wurde,
dann anfing auch mit solchen MMA der darüber hinaus mit solchen Krypto-Investments
reich geworden ist und auch selber irgendwas auf den Markt geworfen hat,
alles Mögliche tut und auch diese Pokémon-Karten und weitere Karten sammelt.
Und zu seinen Inhalten gehört es auch, dass er besonders teure Sammlerstücke
aufreißt, sie vor der Kamera präsentiert.
Oder er ist auch der Besitzer der teuersten Pokémon-Karte.
Ich bin der Eingang-Adjudicator, und ich kann euch sagen, dass die folgende,
die größte Pokémon-Trading-Karte, sold bei einer Privat-Sale,
ist ein PSA-Grate 10 Pikachu Illustrator-Karte.
$5,275,000 auf Juli 22nd.
Er hat für über 4 Millionen Dollar eine Pokémon-Karte gekauft und bekommt dafür
jetzt von einem Herrn vom Guinness-Buch der Weltrekorde ein Zertifikat,
das noch niemand so blöd vor ihm gewesen ist.
Um dir Geld auszugeben. Wir beschreiben kurz das Bild. Er ist noch in Kampfmontur.
Er fasst die Handschuhe noch an und freut sich aber wie ein Sechsjähriger darüber.
Ja, dass er jetzt eine Urkunde bekommt und keine Teilnehmerurkunde,
sondern er ist wirklich der Sieger.
You are officially amazing. Congratulations. You are. Let's go.
This is the coolest thing ever. But it's even cooler that you,
yes you at home, can own this card with me.
Also er hat diese Karte gekauft, aber du kannst jetzt Teil sein.
Stichwort autoritärer Charakter.
Jetzt musst du natürlich auch eigentlich ein Strongman sein.
Jetzt hast du leider nicht auch 4,5 Millionen, um eine Karte zu kaufen,
aber du kannst mit einem kleinen Investment Teil des Ganzen sein. Wie geht das?
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Zohr Right into the plug So this was a very hard decision to make But yes,
I will be listing this card On a platform that I co-founded Called Liquid Marketplace
It allows co-ownership of top tier ads So instead of one person,
me, owning this card, we as a collective can co-own it together.
I'll also be listing it for $5 million instead of the $5.3 million I bought
it for. So basically I'll be giving you guys $300,000 discounts because everyone likes discounts.
And I should say this, I'll be retaining 49% ownership of the card.
So I won't actually have access to it. It'll be in our vault.
But if I wanna wear it out to fights or a Pokemon box break,
or maybe even put it in a museum one day, the community can decide if we wanna
do that. As a collector, this was a hard decision.
I would love to keep this for myself, to be honest.
Das ist also der Kommunismus.
Der hier noch möglich ist. Man kann also Milliardären das teure Hobby unterstützen.
Ernsthaft, ne? Das ist so blöd. Also wir sind nicht nur für die Demokratie zu
blöd. Das ist einfach so blöd.
Und wie er auch noch dreimal dazu sagt, das wäre das eine Auszeichnung statt
der Hinweis, dass es alles bescheuert ist, dass er die Plattform selbst mitgegründet hat.
Also er verwirklicht sich irgendeinen Unsinn und sagt, hier ist eine Plattform,
da könnt ihr alle auch noch Geld einzahlen und dann hört euch das mit.
Es fällt ihm sehr schwer, die Karte zu teilen.
Also ich kaufe mir jetzt einen Rolls Royce und dann sage ich,
und damit ihr auch alle was davon habt, könnt ihr jetzt da mit rein investieren
und ich fahre damit aber durch die Gegend.
Es tut ihm sehr schwer, dass er jetzt sein Konto öffnen muss für die Einzahlung der Leute zu Hause.
Ja, super. Also auf diesem Niveau reden wir.
Jetzt werden sich manche fragen, Sammelkarten, was ist denn da los?
Also viele werden es vielleicht noch aus Kindheitstagen kennen.
Man kann ja zum Beispiel so Fußballkarten sammeln von Bundesligaspielern oder wenn da eine EM, WM ist.
Es gibt Panini, das ist der ganz große Hersteller da und dann gibt es Tops,
die sind auch ganz relevant für das Sportbusiness.
Tops war ursprünglich ein Kaugummihersteller und hat sich dann aber immer weiter
davon wegbewegt und hat diese Karten dann nicht nur in diese Kaugummis reingelegt,
sondern hat irgendwann gesehen, ach mit den Karten selbst kann man ja enorm
Geld verdienen, wenn man dort ein entsprechendes Sammlergeschäft draus macht.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass man ja erst, wie das so ist, im Kapitalismus mehrere
Mitbewerber hat, die auch alle irgendwelche Karten machen mit Sportlern drauf.
Dann hat man aber durch Lizenzgeschäfte und Exklusivverträge es immer mehr geschafft,
dass sich dieses Geld bündelt bei Topps.
Michael Eisner, der einst Disney leitete, ist dann bei Topps eingestiegen.
Wir hören jetzt von dem YouTube-Kanal Sports Cards Edge eine kleine Geschichte
des Unternehmens Topps.
In 2007, Topps was acquired by Michael Eisner, who was the Disney CEO,
his own private company.
And they were looking at expanding into entertainment and media.
And there was even talk about making a Bazooka Joe movie.
But the Topps purchase was a genius purchase at the time. And I'll show you
why, because Topps is public.
So you can see in 2007, Topps sales were close to $200 million per year.
Ein Riesenbusiness und das hat man dann noch weiter skaliert durch Exklusivität.
So it was a great purchase and a great plan for the new owners of Topps.
And this is where the Topps Monopoly returns.
In 2009, Topps became the first
official baseball card of the Major League Baseball, created a Monopoly.
They boxed out Upper Deck to be in the approved card.
And Topps had exclusivity for the use of Major League Baseball and the team
trademarks and logos on cards, stickers, and other products.
Weißt du, was interessant ist? Hier geht es ja um Anteilnahme.
Ja.
Also Leute möchten gerne nicht einzeln alleine als Zuschauer davor sitzen,
sondern möchten gerne mitmachen, teilhaben, beteiligt sein.
Das sind die Leute.
Die uns erklären, regel es mit deinem Bizeps, geh ins Gym, achte nicht auf die
anderen, sei selbst der Stärkste, die das jetzt ausbeuten, dass die Jungs zu
Hause eigentlich nur beteiligt werden möchten.
Ja, entweder an einer Karte oder dazu gehören, dass sie zum Beispiel dann von
einem Debüt eines Sportlers einen Teil zu Hause haben.
Also es gibt bei Topps zum Beispiel die Rookie-Karte, RC genannt.
Das ist also die Sammelkarte, die kommt dann auf den Markt, wenn ein Athlet
sein Debüt gibt in der höchsten Wettbewerbsstufe des Sports.
Und eine solche Karte ist dann besonders beliebt, kann man sich denken.
Und jetzt ist es ja so, Karten kann man ja eigentlich drucken ohne Ende,
da gibt es ja keine Limitierung, aber man muss natürlich eine künstliche Verknappung
einführen, damit überhaupt diese Karten begehrenswert sind.
Jetzt kann man das zum einen über den Druck regeln, wir werden das gleich noch sehen.
Man kann das zum Beispiel dann so machen, dass man sagt, naja manche Grafiken
sind nur auf manchen Karten anzutreffen.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel die Holos bei den Pokémon-Karten, das sind also die
Karten, die so ein Hologramm haben, aber da gibt es auch verschiedene Holos,
ich habe es mal rausgeschrieben,
Holographic Rare, diese Karten haben ein glänzendes holographisches Design auf
dem Pokémon-Bild, der Rest der Karte ist matt,
Reverse-Holo, bei diesen Karten ist der gesamte Kartenhintergrund holographisch,
während das Pokémon-Bild matt bleibt, Full Art Holo, das sind die besten.
Diese seltenen Karten haben ein vollständig holographisches Design.
Ja, und da gibt es dann natürlich dann Schnellkarten, die 100 und mehr Euros wert sind.
Dann ist es so, dass man bei diesen Sportkarten natürlich noch ganz anders Exklusivität
herstellen kann, nämlich so.
Und Jersey-Patches in Baseball-Cards. Ich liebe es.
Das ist ein tolles Teil des Hobbys und es ist ein lustiges, aber es ist auch
eine große Explosion in den verschiedenen Karten, um zu collectern.
Du kannst also, wenn du so ein Set kaufst, man kann ein Set kaufen,
das kostet vielleicht dann 150 oder 250 Euro,
da sind 180 Karten drin, immer in so einzelnen Packages und dann reißt du die
auf, suchst alles durch und dann hast du vielleicht eine Karte.
Auf der ein Autogramm ist. Da ist das schon mehr wert.
Oder es kann sogar eine Karte sein, da ist ein Zipfel von dem Trikot des Sportlers.
Woran erinnert uns das? Natürlich an die Reliquie. Wenn wir in Dorfkirchen gehen,
werden wir in fast jeder Kirche… Nein.
Nein, wir gehen in den Kölner Dom.
Nein, nein, ich will jetzt nochmal sagen, um das Bild zu machen,
also wenn man jetzt in eine Dorfkirche geht, dann findet man häufig auch dort
Reliquien mit einem Kreuzsplitter von der Kreuzigung Jesu.
Nun ist es aber so, wenn man mal diese ganzen Splitter zusammenwerfen würde,
hätte man vermutlich einen Wald.
Genau, also das ist ja wie in Eisenach, jeder nimmt sich und dann malt irgendwann,
da wird die Tinte einfach nachgemalt, als Luther den Teufel an der Wand sah und so weiter.
In Köln haben sie es ja ganz clever gemacht, da sind ja die Reliquien einfach
versteckt, man sieht sie nicht, also sind halt die Gebeine der Heiligen Drei
Könige, aber halt in diesem Goldsakophag, der für sich schon wieder selber Pilgerstätte geworden ist,
da hat man diese Art von Virtualisierung auch schon geschafft.
Dann kommt es natürlich auch darauf an, was hat man, also bei einer Reliquie.
Es geht ja darum, auch die wertvollsten Stücke zu haben.
Wir sehen uns kurz eine Werbung an von Topps, Werbung für eine Rookie-Card und
wir beschreiben mal, was wir da sehen.
Es gibt nur einen ersten Moment,
die historien marken.
Auf diesem Trikot der, was sind das für Schläger? Das war jetzt Baseball.
Ich habe mich tief eingearbeitet, wie du merkst, wir sind mittendrin.
Auf diesen Trikots der Baseballspieler ist am Arm nochmal der Button des Vereins.
Das ist natürlich was ganz Besonderes, denn ihn gibt es ja nur einmal auf einem
Trikot, das ist ja nicht irgendein Rockfitzel.
Und dieser kann jetzt auch auf dieser einen Karte sein, das heißt auf diese
Karte gibt es nur einmal, ein zu eins ist das.
Das war's Das war's für heute.
Dominguez. In his first big league at bat. This kid is electric. Welcome to the show.
Der ist nur eine. Es ist die Rookie Card. Und es kann sein.
Es kann Du.
Musst also jetzt ganz viele Karten kaufen, investieren und sehen,
dass du vielleicht diese eine bekommst.
Donald Trump hat ja bei seinen 100 Unterschriften auch Stifte mitgehabt,
auf denen seine eigene Unterschrift, mit der er diesen Stift macht,
schon drauf gedruckt ist. Und dann hat ja jeder Executive Order ihren eigenen Stift gehabt.
Und die Stifte werden natürlich dann auch hier und da und so.
Ja, so wird das gemacht. Das sind Reliquien. Das ist eine moderne Form von Reliquien.
Und wenn man sich aber das Business dahinter ansieht, dann geht es da wenig
um Emotionen, Nostalgie und weiß ich nicht was.
Sondern wir haben schon gehört, Topps wurde eine Zeit lang dann dort gekauft von Michael Eisner.
Der hat das dann skaliert und hat es verkauft an Fantastics.
So now in January of 2022, Topps is basically forced to sell to Fanatics for
$500 million, pennies on the dollar compared to what the company is worth.
But without the Major League Baseball Players Association licenses,
Topps itself was probably not worth very much money.
So now we've entered what I call the Fanatics era.
Fanatics ist jetzt die richtige Monopoly. Und die einzige Frage ist,
was wird der Zukunft der Baseball-Karten von hier sein?
Für eine halbe Milliarde hat man das Business jetzt verkauft an Fanatics.
Und Fanatics ist der weltweit größte Anbieter von lizenzierter Sportbekleidung.
Die haben dann auch Marken wie NFL, UEFA, Bundesliga und auch bald die englische Premier League.
Fanatics erzielte im Jahr 2024 einen Umsatz von 8,1 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Und dieses Unternehmen ist also das Führende bei Sport Merchandising.
Wir haben es also mit einem Konzern zu tun, dessen Interesse es ist,
den Gewinn möglichst zu skalieren.
Und wir haben eine Fangemeinde und eine Sammlergemeinde.
Das müssen nicht alles Fans sein. Es können auch ganz viele sein,
die einfach nur investieren wollen,
die man eben mit solchen Systemen, die auf eine künstliche Verknappung hinauslaufen,
dazu lockt immer mehr diese Karten zu kaufen, während die bei der Produktion
halt aufpassen müssen, dass sie den Markt nicht in der Weise überhitzen,
dass die Leute wütend werden.
Aber sie dürfen auch nicht zu viel produzieren, damit die Leute dann nicht sagen,
jetzt ist das ja gar nichts mehr wert.
Ja, kein Wunder, dass überall die Flugzeuge abstürzen und die Wälder brennen,
wenn die Männer in diesem Business hängen.
Könnte man auch so mal sagen, ja. Ja, also das ist ein Riesenhype und zwar global.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht nur auf Amerika bezogen, sondern in asiatischen Ländern
ist das natürlich auch ganz groß.
Oh, das glaube ich.
Und jetzt ist interessant, welche Geschäftsformen da immer noch so angedockt
sind. Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, Fanatics hat jetzt Tops gekauft,
Tops, da werden diese Karten produziert, dann werden die über Händler verkauft.
Aha, dann hat man die oder hat man die nicht. Weit gefehlt.
Es geht natürlich viel weiter. Nehmen wir mal an, du hast jetzt so eine ganz
besondere Karte, so eine Holo weiß ich nicht was oder irgendwas mit einem Autogramm.
Dann kannst du auf Marketplaces nachschauen, wie viel die wert ist. Aber …,
Das ist noch gar nicht sicher, wie viel deine Karte genau wert ist,
denn es kommt auch darauf an, wie der Druck ist, der Karte.
Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel Karten.
Anstatt einfach nur Hologramm und dann verschiedene ist jeder Druck.
Nein, da man, also man produziert natürlich, ich weiß nicht,
was die Produktion kostet. Es wird sehr billig sein, solche Karten zu produzieren.
Man produziert jetzt nicht so hochwertig, dass jede Karte wirklich identisch
ist, sondern manchmal ist die Zentrierung ein bisschen verrückt.
Dann ist der weiße Rand rechts ein bisschen breiter, ein Millimeter breiter
als auf der anderen Seite.
Oder der Druck ist nicht so farbkräftig wie auf anderen Karten.
Und das alles mindert dann den Preis.
Das heißt also, du bist, weil wir eben von kompetitiven Leben sprachen,
von Wettbewerben und all das, wir sind also hier in einer Situation,
wo man nicht nur jetzt so einen Wettbewerb hat um diese Kisten,
wer kommt an die Kisten und wer hat dann die entsprechende Karte drin,
sondern es gibt dann weitere Fragen.
Also der Kampf, ja, der geht noch viel weiter, nämlich du musst natürlich auch
eine Karte haben, die besonders gut zentriert ist, die besonders gut gedruckt
ist und die auch keinerlei Spuren am Rand hat von Gebrauch.
Du willst mir also sagen, die kaufen jetzt Sachen, bei denen die Frage im Raum
steht, wie wurde es denn gelagert?
Beziehungsweise wie wurde es gedruckt? Oder ist es als, also das wird ja maschinell verpackt.
Ja, es wird ja maschinell verpackt und da kann natürlich sein auch,
dass am Rande irgendwo vielleicht, wie man das auch schon mal bei einem Buch
hat, dass da irgendwie was gleich leicht angeschlagen ist.
Deswegen gibt es wiederum ein eigenes Geschäft, das ist PSA.
PSA bewertet,
Pokémon-Karten. PSA heißt Professional
Sports Authenticator und die geben Bewertungen ab von 1 bis 10.
Und wir hören jetzt mal da etwas zu diesem Unternehmen von Bayon Core.
If you're into sports or trading cards, then you're familiar with companies
like PSA. Love or hate them, today they dominate the industry and are trusted
as the gold standard for card grading.
Before these agencies existed, collectors had to rely on their own opinion.
Sure, you might claim you have a mint condition card, but who's confirming that?
Das ist dort PSA in 1991 entstanden, und sie hat die 1-10-Grading-Scale,
die wir heute noch benutzen haben.
Erstens, die Leute nicht lieben die Idee von einem 3rd-Party zu schützen.
Aber, mit dem Rennen in Online-Marketplätzen war, es war eine große große Neue
für Objective-Grading. Und so es war kind of laughed at, bis es nicht.
Over Zeit, die Leute in den Karten waren für Authentication und Grading wurde der King.
Und als die Industrie in den 2000er Jahren in den Jahren, PSA expanded von Sport
zu anderen Trading-Cards und Memorabilia.
Und sie sind heute noch als der Welt der 3rd-Party-Sport-Authentication-Service in der Welt.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt eine besondere Karte hast, dann ist das Beste,
du gehst zu einem lizenzierten Händler.
Von dort aus wird dann die Karte in die USA geschickt, zu PSA.
Die beugen sich über die Karte und bewerten die.
Bares für Rares.
Wenn es richtig, Bares für Rares oder wie früher Kunst und Krempel.
Nur hat man früher natürlich dann irgendein Jugendstilstück oder sowas gehabt
und heute beugt man sich über solche Kerzchen aus Pappe und kann dann möglicherweise
sogar eine Gem-Mint-Bewertung abgeben.
Das ist also eine Karte, die hat dann, heißt es da, absolute Perfektion ohne
jegliche Druckfehler oder Zentrierungsprobleme.
1991 wurde das Unternehmen gegründet, ist jetzt immer wichtiger geworden und
hat jetzt ganz viele verschiedene Kategorien.
Mint, Near Mint, Excellent, Good, Lightly Played, Played, Pure.
Also wenn du eine Pure-Karte hast, das ist natürlich ganz schlecht.
Weißt du, was ich befürchte? Während wir vorhin Hoss und Hopf Clips geguckt
haben und ich wirklich keine Befürchtung hatte, dass irgendeiner von unseren
Hörern denkt, naja, höre ich jetzt auch mal, finde ich gut. Fickst du gerade die Leute an?
Meinst du, dass ich jetzt….
Also ich gehöre ja zu den Leuten, die sagen, gedruckte Bücher,
was für ein Scheiß, ich will es so und so. Und ich bin trotzdem fasziniert.
Du bist davon fasziniert.
Ja.
Wenn du jetzt so eine Karte hast und die wurde bewährt… Mal gucken, was ich gleich habe.
Was meinst du, wie ich die gleich aufmache?
Ja, ja. Da musst du ganz vorsichtig machen. Ich werde dir das genau erklären,
wie das geht. Ich habe schon Taschentücher.
Pass auf, wenn du jetzt so eine Karte hast, die wurde jetzt gut bewertet,
also die ist wirklich was wert, wo verkaufst du sie?
Du kannst sie bei eBay Kleinanzeigen verkaufen, du kannst auf so eine Plattform gehen.
Besser ist aber, vielleicht, wenn du sie direkt in deinem eigenen Home-Shopping-Kanal bewirbst.
Kennst du WhatNot?
Das ist eine Plattform, die gibt es schon ein paar Jahre, die wird aber jetzt immer größer.
Dort verkaufen Leute ihre Karten, aber auch andere Dinge.
Du musst dir das so vorstellen, du meldest dich da an, im Prinzip in so einem
TikTok-Format, du meldest dich da an, bist dann Livestreamer,
präsentierst dann dort deine Produkte, kannst du sagen, ich verkaufe drei alte
Anzüge und dann können die Leute direkt mit einem Wisch das Produkt bei dir kaufen.
Du machst also Home Shopping Europe oder QVC.
Wir haben jetzt hier mal ein Beispiel dafür.
Der YouTuber Harry Tornado macht das im Selbstversuch, erklärt das mit Whatnot.
Today, I want to give you guys my semi-professional opinion on how to get past
that and make Whatnot one of the greatest selling platforms for you and your business.
Whatnot is a super fun online marketplace where you can find deals on all sorts
of crazy stuff, Funko Pops, Action Figures, Sneak.
Sneakers clothing jewelry pretty much anything your heart
desires and you scroll down here a little bit to the popular show
category there'll be a show from event we'll pop in
here to see what the top Funko Pop seller on
the app is doing right now they do stuff really really quickly on the app I
think it's a great example of how to run a fast-paced show all their auctions
are only five seconds long and they start at five dollars so for instance we
got this Funko Pop version of Post Malone hier und ich werde es einfach kurz
kaufen, um euch zu zeigen, wie einfach es ist.
Als sie die Auktion starten, wird es das kleine gelbe Button am Boden des Schraens.
Du kannst klicken und es auf der Seite zu bieten.
Es dauert mir zwei Sekunden. Ich will es einfach so. Und dann wird das Produkt
direkt zu meinem Haus verhoben.
So werden in Holland die Blumen verkauft. Da geht eine Tür auf und dann werden
die Blumen, also so ganze Paletten, hingefahren.
Und dann läuft oben so eine Uhr einfach rückwärts.
Wenn sie durchläuft, dauert auch nur fünf Sekunden, und niemand drückt 0 Euro, nicht verkauft, weg.
Wenn du es kaufen willst, so schnell wie möglich drücken. Also du siehst sie,
du musst sofort drücken, weil der Erste, der drückt, gewinnt,
aber der Erste, der drückt, kriegt auch den höchsten Preis, der langsam runterläuft.
Das ist ein ganz faszinierendes System, weil es einfach komplett die kognitive
Teilnahme ausschaltet im Grunde.
Ja, die Leute sind gehypt, zahlen auch dann zum Teil enorme Preise, dazu kommen wir gleich.
So macht man auch Sportswetten übrigens. Jemand kriegt den Ball,
rennt los und du musst in dem Moment entscheiden, wettest darauf,
schafft er es bis hinten hin oder nicht.
Naja, was stellen wir dann fest? Du hattest im Teaser, glaube ich,
das kurz erwähnt, als wir das Buch von Mark Schieritz angekündigt haben,
dass du NFL guckst und dir sei dort aufgefallen, dass nur noch so virtuelles
Zeugs quasi beworben wird, also nur noch irgendwelche Wetten, Coins, was auch immer.
Wir haben jetzt einen Präsidenten, der einen eigenen Coin rausgegeben hat,
dann sagt die First Lady, die sind ja jetzt dadurch erstmal wirklich in diese
Multimilliarden katapultiert wurden, wie das aussieht.
Buchgeld.
Buchgeld, ja klar.
Sie sagen einfach, alle Coins zusammen sind 10 Milliarden wert und sobald der Erste einen 10.000.
Anteil für den entsprechenden Preis kauft, wird der Ganze hochgewertet,
aber das heißt noch lange nicht.
Dass... Ja, wenn die jetzt auf einmal dazu übergeben würden,
das alles auf einmal zu verkaufen, dann würde natürlich der Wert sofort einbrechen.
Aber wir können daran sehen, dass das etwas ist, was Was momentan überall da
ist und ich habe es jetzt, wenn ich jetzt so durch Deutschland fahre,
um irgendwo einen Vortrag zu halten, doch oft gesehen, man ist manchmal in Käffern,
in denen gibt es nichts, da ist keine Metzgerei, da ist kein Restaurant,
nichts, aber eines ist noch da, eine Spielhalle.
Das ist das Einzige, was da ist. Du findest nichts, alles hat zu.
Du könntest in eine Spielhalle gehen.
Und diese Gamification und diese Spielsucht, die überall verbreitet wird,
die steckt natürlich in solchen Dingen drin.
Und diese App Botnot ist natürlich auch darauf angelegt, dass man dabei bleibt,
dass man jetzt plötzlich toll findet, Home Shopping zu gucken.
Wir hören mal weiter, Harry Tornado.
Matching your sales from your first Whatnot show up to $100.
Als wirst du dann also angelockt, bekommst du deinen Betrag verdoppelt.
Disney-Stuff sells really well. Cute little coffee mugs, little aprons,
little gourmet snacks and candies.
Like all that. Like candies actually do really well. There's a candy category
or snack category on Whatnot.
I bought a ton of stuff from there. That's a really interesting and niche category
that people are really, really willing to impulse purchase. Because it's consumable. It's interesting.
Du kennst vielleicht dieses SWR-Format, in dem Moderatoren Leute zu Hause aufsuchen.
Die Kamera wird positioniert, dann frontal.
Und hinter ihnen sind lauter Gegenstände, die sie verkaufen wollen.
Und dann können Leute anrufen und sagen, ja, hinne der Krug aus dem Kandebäckerland, den hätte ich gern.
Und dann fährt die Kamera auf diesen Krug zu.
Es kann auch sein, dass es nicht mehr kommt.
Öffentlich-rechtliches Zeug.
War vielleicht nicht das tollste Format der Welt. Dann fährt die Kamera auf
diesen Krug zu und ja, was wollen sie denn dafür haben?
Und dann sagt er sieben Euro, ah ja, für sechs würde ich ihn nehmen.
Und das ist im Prinzip, hat es schon WhatNot vorweggenommen.
So was funktioniert natürlich nur da besonders gut, wo von der Regierung nichts mehr zu erwarten ist.
Dir werden nicht höhere Löhne bald zukommen, sondern du hast jetzt die Möglichkeit,
nochmal so eine Mini-Mini-Selbstständigkeit aufzubauen, indem du Poloshirts
für 5 Euro bei WhatNot verkaufst und musst aber selbst die auch noch präsentieren
vor einem Publikum, das dir bis dato nicht bekannt ist.
Harry Tornado probiert es dann auch selbst aus. Er hat dann selbst noch keine
Follower dort und sagt, ich versuche jetzt mal etwas dort zu verkaufen.
Ich schätze euch das nicht, was ich euch sagen würde, wenn ich euch nicht so einfach wie das?
Ich werde es nicht so einfach. Der erste, was ich werde, oder zu versuchen,
das Game Boy Advance SP-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW-SW. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Jetzt probiert er aus, dort etwas zu verkaufen, nämlich so einen Game Boy,
der aber eigentlich kaputt ist.
Er hat dann herausgefunden, er kann bei eBay eigentlich das Doppelte verdienen,
erklärt aber, warum er es trotzdem bei Whatnot versucht.
So I'm going to jump in here for one second, because I'm sure somebody is thinking
like, hey, why would I want to sell this for $30 when obviously I can get $65
for it on eBay? And that's a great question.
And if you're willing to do the eBay work of, you know, taking six,
eight, ten photos of this thing and doing a title and writing a description
to show how it doesn't work und filling out the multiple required item specifics
and then waiting 30 or 45 or 60 days to find the right buyer and answering customer
questions and probably dealing with a return issue because they never read the
descriptions to see that it doesn't work.
If you want to do all that to get your $65, by all means, do it.
But what we're talking about here is the pure essence of the phrase,
the fast nickel or the slow dimes.
Wie war mal rein in diese Verkaufsshow?
I'm happy to answer anything. Es ist nicht auf. Es ist nicht auf.
I think I have a charger for it somewhere, but I don't know exactly where that is.
Oh, Northern Video Games purchased the Game Boy. Northern Video Games.
I'm so excited right now. Northern Video Games, I love you. I love you so much.
Und schon hat er etwas verkauft.
Wir sind alle Ökonomen. Unser Wohnzimmer ist unser Supermarkt.
Ja.
Unser Konto ist unser Geschäft und so weiter.
Du bist ein Unternehmer. Du bist ein Unternehmer, kannst es jeden Abend sein.
Ein Ehepaar, das vorher Karten bei Ebay verkaufte, verabschiedet sich bei YouTube
und sagt, wir sind ab sofort bei WhatNot zu treffen.
So we are trading Patrick Stewart, Jamie Lee Curtis, both autos.
So we recently started trading a lot of our personal collections away in order
to fund our whatnot business. So we picked up about $400 worth of slabs and
we're going to auction them off on whatnot starting at a dollar.
So if you're interested in some slabs, some nice ones, come on in,
check us out at DKTCG Cave.
We run every Monday, Wednesday, Friday and Saturday. See you there.
Trudelmarkt.
Jetzt haben wir hier ein sehr kleines Set. Bevor wir das aber öffnen,
müssen wir erst noch was hören. Ich will es noch spannend machen.
Jetzt kann man häufig sehr große Sets kaufen. Da sind dann so 80 kleine Päckchen
drin. Die sind natürlich sehr teuer.
Das heißt, man muss ja auch erstmal Kapital haben, um das zu machen.
Das ist jetzt für… für Teenager oder so gar nicht so einfach möglich oder Leute,
die ohnehin nicht viel Geld haben.
Da gibt es aber Leute wie Montana Black, die kaufen dann so ein großes Paket,
öffnen das bei WhatNot Live und dann kannst du einzelne Spots kaufen.
Also du kannst sagen, ich kaufe dann so ein Päckchen daraus.
Wir hören mal rein in so ein WhatNot Stream von Montana Black.
Ulag. Zumindest die Indigo.
Also öffnet jetzt, zeigt dann einzelne Karten.
Ist auch so hässlich, Digga. Tangela Merkel. Oh, Dodo hatten wir auch noch nicht. Glaube ich, oder?
Doch, wir hatten einmal Dodo bei Märzpack. Daniela Merkel ist wirklich ein krasser Spruch. Rolltoball.
Da hat er fast alles. Smog on. So. Energy. Oh, wow. Was kommt danach?
Energy. Okay, Hugo.
Ich muss mal kurz sagen, dieser Stream dauert über drei Stunden und so sind
die auch in der Regel immer.
Das Einzige, was die da machen, ist, dass da drei zusammensitzen,
in der Mitte Montana Black, reißen Päckchen auf und lesen die Kartennamen vor.
Also sind wir zu dumm für, ist die grundlegende neue Frage für alles.
Ich würde es auch sagen.
Bist du bereit? Drei, zwei, eins. Oh, Garados. Geil, schöne Karte.
Garados, Mann. GG ist geil. Ich glaube gar nicht, dass so ein dicker Fisch aus
Carpador sich entwickelt.
Carpador eigentlich so der Nichts nutzt Und dann kommt so ein Drachentier. GG.
Und 2.500 Euro wert. Das ist eine sehr schöne Karte. Im besten Rating,
was wäre der? 2.500 im besten Rating, okay.
Diese Karte könnte also im besten Rating 2.500 Euro wert sein.
Bestes Rating bedeutet natürlich, man muss diese Karte jetzt einschicken zu, schon erwähnt, PSA.
Die müssen das dann testen.
Also, hier verpasst man nichts, wenn man daran nicht teilnimmt.
Ich sehe schon wieder irgendwelche Leute, die FOMO haben und so weiter.
Nein, ich will auch um Gottes Willen. Bitcoin-mäßig und so.
Schalte da nicht ein, da wird nichts gefadelt.
Thomas, der mir das ja hier angebracht hat und so, sagt ja auch,
das ist ein bisschen bekloppt und er hat natürlich vollkommen recht damit und
ich will es auch nochmal deutlich unterschreiben, man sollte genau das nicht machen.
Ein Qualitätsmerkmal, wenn jemand sagt, was, ich weiß nicht, worum es da geht.
Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Es zeigt nur sehr viel darüber, über die Manusphäre,
über die wir viel gesprochen haben.
Es zeigt wahnsinnig viel darüber, dass alles Wettbewerb ist.
Und es ist aber auch interessant, dass wir zum einen bei diesen Leuten immer
so einen Leistungsethos haben
und zugleich sitzen sie nur da und reißen Päckchen auf in der Hoffnung,
dass irgendeine Automatisierung dafür gesorgt hat,
dass in diesem einen Päckchen die teure Karte ist.
Und sie das Glück haben, die zu erwischen. Also es ist ja eine künstliche Verknappung.
Allein das ist ja schon eine Blödheit. Wir finden ja immer toll,
wenn etwas nicht künstlich verknappt wird.
Also künstlich was zu verknappen ist ja per se schon eine Idiotie.
Wo man sagt, ja warum denn, wenn man es ja so günstig herstellen kann und wenn
doch jeder gerne eine bunte Karte haben will, dann drückt man sie doch jedem.
Aber nur durch die Verknappung überhaupt kann man natürlich einen solchen Wert erzeugen.
Das ist ja schon eine Absurdität an sich. Und dann noch so weit zu gehen,
zu sagen, wir verknappen noch ein paar mal mehr dadurch,
dass, wenn das schlecht gedruckt ist, also nur weil die zu schlampig waren,
die Karte sauber zu drucken, dass das auch nochmal einen Unterschied macht dann,
ist ja eine Ökonomie, die man da schafft,
die natürlich volkswirtschaftlich die absolute Katastrophe ist.
Mit der man aber die Leute bei der Stange halten kann und jedem so ein bisschen
das Gefühl geben kann, dazuzugehören.
Technologie schafft ja Tatsachen.
Und jetzt hatten wir ja von Apple dieses Angebot, kauf unseren Laptop und da
ist irgendwie so ein Magnet und dann kannst du dein Handy da dranhängen und
dann funktioniert das Handy als Kamera.
Und dann hat der Apple damals neu so ein Desk View.
Also, dass man einfach zeigt, was man gerade in der Hand hat.
Da fragt man sich so, ey, wie ist das gemeint? Ist das jetzt ein Poly-Looks
wie früher, da man schreibt was und die Leute sollen das dann sehen in der Videokonferenz?
Nein, das ist natürlich für diese Situation hier, dass Montana Black da sitzt,
frontal gefilmt wird, gleichzeitig im großen Bild aber in seine Hände gezeigt werden.
Er deckt ja jede Karte einzeln auf und die letzte balanciert er dann auch so
auf den Fingern, um zu zeigen, wir sind jetzt hier nicht irgendwo,
wir müssen das jetzt hier gefühlvoll machen.
Das ist dieser Kameraview, den Apple eingeführt hat. Er macht die natürlich
professionell, aber das können alle zu Hause.
Anschlusstheorie, weil dieses Bild ja gerechnet wird von Apple,
die Kameraposition ist ja völlig ungeeignet, es ist ja kein Top-Down-View,
kann man nicht wirklich darstellen, wie die Karte aussieht, weil das Bild ist
ja verzerrt, deswegen muss man sie nochmal zu dieser Agentur schicken,
die einem sagt, wie viel sie wirklich wert ist, unabhängig davon,
wie gut die Kamera ist, die das Bild zurückrechnet, das auf die Hand geht.
Und wir haben ja so eine interessante Mischung aus Digitalität und Materialität,
denn diese Materialität, die hier so hochgehalten wird, ist ja auch nur eine
Scheinmaterialität durch diese künstliche Verknappung.
Denn eigentlich würde man sagen, man produziert doch so viele Karten, wie gebraucht werden.
Aber nein, nur dadurch geht es und man hat dann,
So eine Situation, in der wir jetzt Deep Seek haben, quasi vielleicht dein neuer
bester Freund nach Claude.
Jedenfalls haben wir jetzt von den Chinesen gezeigt bekommen,
dass man also mit Open Source wahnsinnig viel erreichen kann und damit weit kommt.
Also das ist weniger, das hat ja Facebook auch schon gezeigt.
Genau, Facebook fand ja deswegen jetzt Deep Seek auch gar nicht so schlimm.
Und dann haben wir aber zu klein, also wir haben etwas, dass es eigentlich keine
Beschränkung mehr gibt.
Das Digitale ist eigentlich nicht mehr, dass man irgendwas beschränkt,
aber es gibt offenbar so eine Sehnsucht nach einem,
so etwas wie Eigentum und das kann man nur über eine Materialität wiederherstellen
und es geht dann einmal über verrückte NFT-Codes oder man macht es so,
dass man sagt, ja es gibt da ganz besondere Karten,
die sind sehr selten und wenn da aber ein Kratzer drin ist, dann ist es doch nicht so viel wert.
Ja. Und vielleicht verkauft Montana Black dann auch noch sein Pikachu-Kostüm,
das er anhatte, als er diese Karte aufdeckte.
Ja, oder Einzelteile davon.
Oder die Ohren einzeln, ja.
Das wird natürlich auch kritisiert, was Montana Black da tut,
denn der Hype wird dadurch ja immer größer.
Hier meldet sich jetzt aus YouTube Steve P. Cooking zu Wort,
der sagt, das findet er gar nicht gut.
Und ich bin gerade wirklich, wirklich sauer. Es ist heute der 19.1. Montana Black.
Wir sehen hier einen jungen Mann auf einem Gamer-Stuhl sitzen,
der im Hintergrund in seinem Regal ganz viele Figuren, Fabelwesen und Kärtchen stehen hat.
Kennt, glaube ich, jeder. Ist gerade noch am Streamen auf Whatnot und macht
unter anderem ein Base-Set-Display auf, First Edition auf Deutsch.
Was ja erstmal kein Problem ist, dass Leute, die viel Geld haben,
dann auch so ein Display aufreißen.
Er hat ja auch viel unter seinen Streamer-Kollegen zum Beispiel dann verkauft
oder verschenkt das weiß ich nicht genau ist ja prinzipiell erstmal okay,
Was ich allerdings gar nicht okay finde, dass in dem Stream auch prismatische
Entwicklungen, Booster oder Versteiger, ja, auktioniert wurden und diese Booster
teilweise 100 Euro oder mehr gekostet haben. Ein einziges Booster.
Denn, wie du das eben schon so schön beschrieben hast, da setzt das Hirn aus.
Man sagt, oh, wenn ich jetzt ganz schnell wische, dann bekomme ich das.
Weißt du, was ich da gerade gehört habe?
Und dann zahlt man gerne.
Man muss ja den Clip irgendwie übersetzen. Ich weiß ja nicht,
worüber die da reden, aber ich habe ungefähr gehört.
Ich finde das schon nicht verkehrt, den Kakao dann auch in die Milch reinzumachen,
aber dass man dafür den kurzen Löffel nimmt, obwohl man weiß,
dass die Tasse so lang ist.
Das ist schlechtes Vorbild für die Kinder, deren Eltern zu Hause sauber machen
müssen, was sie beim Umrühren anrichten.
Das ist eine Grenze überschritten, das geht gar nicht.
Andere sehen das anders. Es gibt die YouTuber Hennas und Andreas Wiener,
die sind auch da ganz tief in diesem Kartenbusiness drin.
Die schätzen das Ganze jetzt so ein. Es geht also immer um diese prismatische
Entwicklung, diese Reihe jetzt von Pokémon.
Da musst du halt auch ein bisschen Glück haben, ein bisschen was vorbestellt
haben. Und wenn dich dann einfach warten, es kommt was. Es wird was kommen.
Kein FOMO. Ich hab's reingeschrieben in meinen Titel. Kein FOMO.
Ja, absolut. Gut, also ich finde, das ist hier, also die Geschichte ist natürlich,
was spannend ist, wenn du jetzt schnell öffnest, die nach Tara ziehst und die sofort verkloppt.
Reden wir über die Karten, Hennas. Ich finde das ja viel spannender, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Weil, was sagen wir denn? Wird die nach Tara nochmal einbrechen und dann kauft
man sie oder wird sie jetzt immer so weiterlaufen?
Also ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die geht ja gerade für über 2000 Euro oder sowas raw weg.
Jetzt nochmal bei Nvidia einsteigen oder lieber noch warten.
Das sind die Fragen, die hier auf einer anderen Ebene gestellt werden.
Aber es ist genau das, das Subjekt
als Börsianer ist also auch in dieser Sammelkultur weit verbreitet.
Ich dachte, ich hätte einen Überblick über die Sachen, vor die ich meine Kinder
schützen muss. Aber nein.
Wer weiß. Wahrscheinlich schimpfen sie heute Abend mit dir, dass du irgendeine
Karte hast entgehen lassen. Denn die müssen natürlich wieder an Thomas zurück.
Das habe ich ihm versprochen.
So, wir öffnen jetzt ein Paket. Dieses Paket hat 30 Euro gekostet.
29,99 Euro.
Das ist ein Paket, das sind Sammelkarten. Hier ist eine Broschüre oder ein Poster dabei.
Dort sind die in groß aufgelistet, welche Karten es gibt.
Sehr groß, ja.
Und jetzt haben wir es hier mit, du siehst, da sind manche schon nach vorne
gestellt, manche Karten.
Diese Karten sind auch irgendwie besonders.
Mehr, man kommt nicht ran.
Weil die auch einen Glanz haben oder so.
Vorsichtig soll ich die anfassen, dass ich nichts kaputt mache.
Blitzer ist das und die hat auch so ein bisschen Holo.
Jetzt pass auf, was macht man mit so einer Karte? Ich habe gesagt,
naja, ich stecke die dann einfach, wenn ich die alle ausgepackt habe,
in die Tasche. Nein, auf keinen Fall dürfe ich das tun.
Dafür brauche ich erstmal einen Penny Sleeve.
Das sind solche Hüllen, Glarsichtfolien, in die man diese hineinlegt.
Ich mache das jetzt mal hier beispielhaft, denn das ist auch eine Karte,
die jetzt nicht besonders wertvoll ist, aber doch auch keine schlechte Karte ist.
Jetzt habe ich die also erstmal in dieser Folie drin, muss aufpassen,
dass ich dabei nicht die Ecken bestoße, denn dann ist die PSA-Bewertung ja schlecht.
So, wenn ich die jetzt darin habe, dann ist das aber auch nicht stabil.
Ja, Moment. Jetzt muss diese Karte noch in so einer harte Plastik hinein.
Dieses Ding nennt sich Toploader.
Als der Hype mal so ganz groß war, vor einem Jahr, sagte man,
mir waren diese Toploader ausverkauft und wurden zu enormen Preisen gehandelt.
Jetzt stecke ich also diese Karte in den Toploader, dann ist sie gesichert und
dann kann ich sie dir mal geben, dann kannst du mal drauf schauen.
Also, erinnert mich ein bisschen, wir waren jetzt mit einem Achtjährigen in
der Nähe eines Schallplattenspielers und er wollte, dass da mal was rauskommt.
Nachdem wir ihm erklärt haben, wie das funktioniert.
Weshalb wir ihm gesagt haben, ja, dann such mal eine Schallplatte aus.
Und er so, wie, was, wo, was soll ich aussuchen? Und wir so,
ah ja, stimmt, der ist ja acht.
Dann haben wir ihm gesagt, guck mal her, alles, was du hier siehst, sind Schallplatten.
Ach so. So, und dann geht man die durch.
Die sind genauso eingepackt. Die sind getop-loaded und dann nochmal in so einer
Hülle und dann legt man die da drauf, nur die spielen dann auch Musik. Das hier nicht.
Du hast also jetzt diese Karte. Jetzt zeige ich dir mal, wie man das wohl aufmacht.
Man macht es hier hinten auf und versucht dann zu ziehen.
So macht man das auf. Also man muss vorsichtig sein, dass man nichts kaputt drückt.
Und dann ist das die erste Karte, ich glaube die muss dann nach hinten gelegt
werden, dann dreht man sie um, das ist also eine, jetzt kamen wir hier,
erst eine Basic Energy Karte, dann Miltank,
Terry Robere, FMEM, weiß nicht was das ist, Schwarzgurt Training.
La Shocking, Dicke Freunde Knursp, da steht dann drauf, durchsuche dein Deck
nach bis zu zwei Basis-Pokémon mit 70 oder weniger KP und lege sie auf deine Bank.
Mische anschließend dein Deck. Ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen zu sagen,
man kann mit diesen Karten auch und das tun wohl Kinder auch spielen.
Nee, die tauschen die alle nur. Ich glaube, niemand spielt das.
Okay, aber eigentlich ist es ein Spiel. Und dann kommt man hier weiter und hier
das könnte schon was Besonderes sein.
Die heißt Evoli und die ist das ist Full Art Holo, glaube ich.
Die klitzert doch komplett.
Ja, guck mal.
Was wird das sein? Ist das, ob das was Wertvolles ist? Full Art?
Sagt uns Bescheid, weil es ist mehr als 300 Euro.
Vielleicht das große Los hier gezogen. Ich muss ganz vorsichtig damit umgehen.
Flatterhaar und Eisenfels. die haben auch einen leichten Kanzler,
da bin ich jetzt, da steht aber Basic drauf.
Ich glaube bei, hier steht Item.
Naja, wir werden sehen, jetzt gebe ich dir mal einen.
Also hier sind ja so verschiedene Gefühle, du hast mir jetzt einen in die Hand gegeben.
Wir sind heute Abend wieder in der Oper und wir gehen ja auch gerne in die Oper,
weil es in der Oper so Momente gibt, in denen man weiß, nee,
ich muss jetzt hier nicht nachfragen, ich nutze jetzt mein Handy nicht.
Ja.
So. Und so ist das hier auch. Man sitzt so daneben und man weiß,
nur Montana Black darf diese jetzt anschauen.
Es ist eine Kamera auf seine Hände gerichtet und sobald er hier einen Fehler
macht, ist der Chat voll.
Ja, nur nichts zu knicken.
Das heißt, ich mach die jetzt mal so auf. Ich glaube nämlich,
du hast sie für 30 Euro gekauft und sie sind eigentlich nur 1 Euro wert.
Ja, das glaube ich auch.
Das könnte sein, guck mal, wie ich das mache. So hier, ich hab die Karten Ich
habe die Karten zur Hilfe genommen, um Druck auszuüben.
Ich versuche es nochmal nach der alten Methode, wie man es mir beigebracht hat.
Das heißt, ich lege sie jetzt alle geöffnet vor mich, ohne sie je belästigt zu haben. So, okay, gut.
Wir schauen, was du da hast.
Forschung des Professors. Guck mal, ich balanciere dich schon so auf den Fingern wie Montana Black.
Ja, toll. Also wir müssen das erklären. Wir haben jetzt hier so etwa zehn Karten pro Paket.
Und eine davon könnte irgendetwas wert sein.
Ich gucke nur nach Hologrammen.
Das hier ist wieder eine Evoli-Karte, die hat aber kein Hologramm bei mir.
Ich habe eine.
Ach ja? Und die Frage, die ja eben gestellt wurde von Hennas und Andreas Wiener
ist, wird die Nacht Tara noch so viel wert sein?
Nach was? Die Nacht Tara. Also hätte man die jetzt, dann haben wir das große losgezogen.
Also wir suchen nach der Nacht Tara. Wir hatten die aber bislang noch nicht drin.
Hypotherus, Haspiror, Pinsir, Riesenzahn, Professor Antiquas Vitalität.
Ich hab hier eine. Die ist ganz interessant. Zum einen, die hat nur am Rand Holo.
Und sie heißt stellvertretend für sehr viele Dumm-Mimsel.
Ja. Die mit dem Rand Holo, das ist ja eine, ich glaub das heißt Reverse Holo.
Ja.
Terry Robere, Hasbiro, Benazaro und auch eine Energy-Karte. Ich glaube,
das war jetzt kein gutes Paket.
Nee. Schaumin, Schaumin, Kroldra, Hundemann. Zwirlig.
Also keine Nachthahre dabei.
Eine Donnersichel, das sieht auch gut aus.
Die ist komplett holo. Die ist auch holo. Also es hat sich, glaube ich,
nicht so ganz gelohnt, das Investment von 30 Euro.
Aber wir haben mal wieder damit für mehr Verknappung gesorgt,
was natürlich im Ganzen die Preise steigen lässt. Ja, du hast jetzt welche weggekauft.
Ich habe welche weggekauft, habe also jetzt teilgenommen an diesem Börsenspiel.
Wir hatten noch keine dabei, die heute als knapp gilt. Aber woher weißt du, was nächste Woche ist?
Eben. Da kann natürlich, also wir werden sie hüten.
Guck mal, wie ich die Packung ausgemacht habe. Weißt du noch früher,
als man den Weihnachtsmann aufgemacht hat und danach das Papier so glatt gestrichen,
um zu gucken, es ist unverletzt geblieben.
Ja, toll.
Vielleicht können wir aus dem Ding noch was rausholen.
Ja.
Und jetzt ganz ohne Quatsch. Wir haben die im neuen 20er Podcast aufgemacht. Allein das.
Wir könnten sie vielleicht signieren und dann hat man als Authentifizierung,
dass wir die hier geöffnet haben. Das ist eigentlich das große Ding.
Wir überlegen uns was für März.
Dann versuchen wir, wir werden jetzt immer Karten öffnen. Oder wir können ja
vielleicht auch so ein Kartenprogramm anbieten für unsere Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Das ist das Rookie-Deck. Das erste Deck, das Wolfgang aufgemacht hat im Podcast.
Das stimmt, ja. Das ist eigentlich wertvoller als die Nachthara.
Wir schneiden nachher ein Stück von deinem Anzug ab und kleben das da drauf.
Ja.
Dann packen wir das in den Top-Loader.
Ja, der Top-Loader, wir haben ja noch ganz viele hier.
Und dann fahren wir nach Dubai und machen neues Business.
Und erzählen von dort aus, wie scheiße Deutschland ist. Das ist also die neue Idee.
Ja, also diese Wirtschaftswelt ist eine, wo man jetzt fragen kann,
naja, aber wie dominant ist sie?
Dieser eben genannte Logan Paul, der die teuerste Pokémon-Karte besitzt,
war natürlich auch eingeladen auf der Inauguration von Donald Trump.
Die neue Populärkultur von Trump ist die, solche Kerzchen zu sammeln,
bedeutet irgendwelche alten Baseball-Schläge an die Wand zu hängen,
bedeutet auch, das kann man in dieser Golden-Doku sehen.
Wir müssen das überlegen, das blendet mich, das ist alles so schimmernd.
Dass man das Haus, in dem der Pate gedreht wurde, kauft, um dort dann irgendwelche
Hochzeiten abzufeiern.
Okay.
Ja, das ist die Situation, in der wir uns befinden.
Das ist also die virtuelle und digitale Welt in einem.
Wir raten davon nochmal ganz ausdrücklich ab, auf diesen Hype aufzuspringen.
Aber wir sehen gerade, dass das etwas ist, was sich in den Köpfen so fest setzt.
Und das zeigt natürlich auch sehr viel darüber, dass wir...
Im Prinzip nicht mehr ein Glauben haben an irgendeine Leistungsgesellschaft
oder so etwas, sondern es ist eigentlich eine Gamble-Gesellschaft,
in der man darüber nachdenkt, wie könnte ich es auch noch schaffen, meinen Arsch zu retten.
Ja, absolut.
Ob mit Krypto, mit der Karte oder eine Sportwette, mal sehen.
Ja, das ist die Anlage für den Tag X.
Wir wollen aber noch zu etwas tatsächlich sehr Materiellem gehen,
nämlich du hast vielleicht mitbekommen, was in Südafrika passiert ist.
Man konnte es erfahren, es ist in den Medien vorgekommen.
Wir hören erstmal von der BBC, einen Ausschnitt, den ich mal unkommentiert erst abspiele.
Das war es,
dass ein group von 150 volunteers hier sind, und sie wurden nachdenken,
und sie wurden nachdenken, und sie haben nachdenken, für die letzten 25 bis 30 Minuten,
um zu versuchen, eine body zu retriebe.
Und wir sind gesagt, dass es 45 Minuten bis an Stunde geht, um eine Person aus zu bekommen.
So at this stage, we are not clear in terms of if there is a dead body that
they're taking out or it's people that are alive that they are currently taking out.
Was ist die Nachrichtenlage nochmal?
Ja, was ist die Nachrichtenlage? Das ist ein BBC-Beitrag aus dem November.
Wir hören, da sind irgendwelche Leute in Minen. Es ist unklar, wen sie da rausholen.
Freiwillige machen das interessanterweise. Es sind ja welche in die Minen gefallen.
Wir hören nochmal diesen Beitrag jetzt weiter von BBC.
Weapons that are operating underground as well.
The government has been trying to close that off and shut down all the unsealed
mineshafts to ensure that no one goes underground because it's not just unsafe,
but also the fact that there are so many killings between rival gangs that actually
take place underground.
That is also what is worrying the authorities.
Noch immer ist die Lage unübersichtlich. Wir sind also im November,
springen jetzt aber in den Januar und hören die ZDF-Nachrichten.
Ein Hilferuf aus zwei Kilometern Tiefe. Ein Handy-Video zeigt verzweifelte Bergleute unter Tage.
Seit November sollen sie nicht genügend Nahrung und Wasser erhalten haben.
Viele Männer haben das nicht überlebt.
Sie haben sich von Zahnpasta ernährt, von Kakerlangen. Manche waren wohl so
verzweifelt, dass sie Leichenteile gegessen haben.
Die illegalen Bergleute. In Südafrika nennt man sie die Samasamas,
was so viel heißt wie die, die das Glück suchen.
Seit Montag läuft in Silfontaine eine Rettungsaktion.
Ein Kran bringt die Samasamas ans Tageslicht. Dutzende Leichen werden geborgen.
Die südafrikanischen Behörden gehen seit Monaten hart gegen den illegalen Bergbau im Land vor.
Sie haben Ein- und Ausgänge verschiedener Minen dichtgemacht und die Bergleute
von der Lebensmittelversorgung abgeschnitten, um sie so zu zwingen,
wieder ans Tageslicht zu kommen.
Die Lage war wochenlang bekannt.
Menschenrechtler kritisierten die südafrikanische Regierung massiv.
Die Polizei weist jede Schuld von sich.
Wir haben nie irgendwelche Schächte blockiert oder jemanden daran gehindert, rauszukommen.
Wenn wir aber diesen Menschen Nahrung, Wasser und andere lebensnotwendige Dinge
zur Verfügung stellen würden, dann würde die Polizei damit Kriminalität bestarken.
In der vergangenen Woche verpflichtete ein Gericht, die Behörden sofort mit
der Rettung der Bergleute zu beginnen.
Für viele kam das zu spät.
Das Gambling jetzt nochmal in einer ganz anderen, sehr tödlichen Dimension.
Also wir sind in Südafrika, dem ungleichsten Land der Welt, mit enormen Reichtümern,
mit enormer Armut und Arbeitslosigkeit.
Arbeitslosenquote bei über 30 Prozent, bei jungen Menschen über 40 Prozent.
Südafrika lebte sehr stark davon, dass es dort Minen gab, in denen man beispielsweise Gold schürfte.
Goldminen gab es sehr viele, es gibt inzwischen aber 6000 stillgelegte Minen,
in denen findet sich aber hier und da noch etwas und wir sind da in einer Situation,
in der jetzt die, die arbeitslos sind und sehr viele, die aus dem Außenland
illegal dort einwandern, durch irgendwelche Syndikaten darüber gepaart werden,
in diesen Minen arbeiten und die sehr gerechte Regierung in Südafrika,
Hat diesen jetzt den Kampf angesagt und es gab eben diesen Fall dort in dieser
Mine, von der da die Rede ist, wo dann viele Dutzende Tote herausgeschafft wurden,
dass man sagt, wir geben denen jetzt keine Nahrungsmittel mehr,
wir räuchern die aus, so war die wirkliche Formulierung da.
Und man hatte also dort Menschen verrecken lassen, weil man sagte,
wir greifen jetzt hart durch, damit diese illegalen Minenarbeiten aufhören. Das ist die Situation.
Aber die Minen wurden aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen stillgelegt.
Also da gibt es nicht wirklich mehr was zu holen.
Ja, also es sind schon wirtschaftliche Gründe, insofern als man sagen kann,
die Gewerkschaften haben es auch geschafft höhere Löhne durchzusetzen in den
90er Jahren schon, sie haben dort natürlich auch dafür gesorgt,
dass gewisse Sicherheitsstandards und so weiter eingehalten werden müssen.
Und haben dadurch natürlich auch dieses Mining teuer gemacht,
sodass dann irgendwann die Frage ist, lohnt sich das noch und Südafrika hat
da auch für sich einen anderen politischen Weg, wirtschaftspolitischen Weg gehen wollen.
Und dadurch hat man also ja immer noch sehr viel da im Boden,
aber die Frage ist, wie ertragreich man das da sichern kann und wenn da gewisse
politische Interessen nicht mehr mit dabei sind, dann ist das schwierig,
es sei denn, da setzt sich so etwas illegal durch.
BBC Reuters hat dann auch darüber berichtet. Wir hören da nochmal etwas zu.
Speaking from his makeshift home in Kuma, not far from Stilfontaine,
Maletzi recalled the harrowing situation underground.
Maletzi agreed to speak to Reuters, but requested his face be obscured for his safety.
He consented to using his name. When I'm alone at night, normally I see a lot
of cops and then I end up crying and not believing that I am still alive.
He says that without food, the miners resorted to eating cockroaches and even dead bodies.
Man hat also dort weiter nach Gold gesucht. Wohin geht das Gold?
In die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate meistens.
Dort wird es dann umdeklariert und kann möglicherweise auch an unseren Händen
sein, wenn wir einen goldenen Ring tragen.
Also das ist nicht etwas, was in der Illegalität bleibt. Nein,
ich trage keinen goldenen Ring.
Ich habe auch mit Gold nichts zu tun eigentlich.
Ich habe auch, ich habe darüber nachgedacht, ob ich irgendwas mit Gold habe, ich glaube nicht.
Naja, jedenfalls ist Gold ja verbreitet, wie wir wissen.
In dieser Mine waren zwei bis viertausend Menschen, so genau kann man das gar
nicht sagen, beschäftigt.
Diese Menschen sind dann bis zu einem kompletten Jahr oder sogar manchmal zwei
Jahre unter Tage, kommen gar nicht raus, werden nur von künstlichem Licht bestrahlt.
Sind dort einfach drin, werden eingefärscht, werden in Käfigen darunter geschickt,
vielleicht haben manche mal von Emisolar Germinal gelesen, so in etwa, nur nochmal krasser,
weil diese Minen natürlich von kriminellen Syndikaten überwacht werden und du
musst zum Beispiel auch Geld zahlen, wenn du wieder raus willst.
Das heißt, du musst da so schon etwas gefunden haben an Gold,
um wieder hochbelassen werden zu können.
In einem solchen System. Wir haben mal über Handyspiele gesprochen,
wie man da so Minerarbeiter irgendwo hinschicken kann.
Die Idol Games. Im Prinzip ist das die bittere Realität, von der wir da stehen.
Die Deutsche Welle hat dieses Thema auch aufgegriffen.
High rate of unemployment in the entire country is very alarming and is very concerning.
So whenever our people, they have nothing to eat, nothing to put on the table,
they will go to those halls and try to make a living.
That's why we are calling to our government, let it legalize these things,
you see, so that those people can be employed permanently, legally,
so that there will not be any illegal activity.
Because you must understand, my man, most of the African brothers,
they came a long time ago to come and work in these mines. Sie haben miniert,
warum die Minen immer noch arbeiten.
Aber jetzt die einzige, die sie verstehen, ist das Minen.
Das ist sehr wichtig für unser Regierung, damit sie uns das Thema illegalen Minen geben können.
Damit wir uns das Recht geben, damit wir das Gemeinschaftsrecht minieren können,
damit wir das Gold produzieren können.
Das kann man getestet werden, aber die Menschen am Ende des Tages werden ihre Familien gebeten.
Als man die Minen schloss, hat man sich nicht um die Leute gekümmert,
die alle arbeitslos sind. Es ist der pure Hunger, der die Leute in die Minen treibt.
No, let me call it a statement. That is not an excuse that people go underground
illegally because of hunger. It's a reality fact of a murder.
If you can come to Kuma, Kuma was once a gold town.
But now it just turned to be, it was once a mining town. But now it just turned to a ghost town.
You see, we had a lot of companies. Those people, they mined our city,
they mined our location.
From there, they left Kuma with nothing. So whenever they hunger,
the poverty strikes, you must make ends meet, there's a family,
there's a family man to see how best.
Because if you have seen that whole, my brother, if you have seen that whole,
there is no one who will go out there and risk his life.
That situation is very dangerous. But on the basis of hunger,
they had to go there to provide for their families.
Und man hat jetzt in dieser Situation, wo die Minenarbeiter in dieser einen
Mine waren, die man dann aufgespürt hatte, wusste, dass die da sind,
sich gesagt, wir lassen sie nicht raus.
Und das ist natürlich eine Verletzung der Menschenrechte sondergleichen.
Und man beruft sich dann einfach darauf, dass man sagt, ja, aber wir bekämpfen ja Illegalität.
Ja, also das ist am Ende die Spitze der Entwicklung, die auf deinen Bizeps wird es regeln.
Hier gibt es keine Gesellschaft, geh dahin, wo du dich auskennst,
dann geht man da unter Tago und dann hängt man da hin.
Und dann nochmal die, die aus dem Ausland kommen, sind nochmal schlechter gestellt,
also auch da hat man natürlich wieder eine rassistische Komponente drin in der
Weise, dass man unterscheidet in wir und die anderen und die Illegalen aus den
angrenzenden Ländern kommen nach Südafrika und beuten unseren Boden hier aus.
Dass das natürlich alles Grundlage von strukturelleren Problemen ist,
die man angehen müsste, wird dann einfach wegignoriert und man sagt lieber,
jetzt müssen wir mit harter Hand vorgehen.
Nochmal die deutsche Welle.
But what you get from the mining communities where this is happening,
they are saying, most of them are saying, yes, of course, this is against the law.
But if you take it out, take it away from us, you seal those mines.
So you leave the communities without any other source of living.
How else do you expect them to live except engaging on crime?
So this is the argument that we are hearing from most community members.
We agree with you government, clamp down, seal it down, but provide a solution in the same time.
Because if you take these means which is illegal, that they are using to survive,
and most of these communities are saying it's the only way out,
and the government also agrees to,
Die Menschen.
Die da leiden und sterben, spielen keine Rolle. Es geht hier nur um wirtschaftliche
Kosten und letztlich um das BIP.
Das ist jetzt BBC.
Das ist nicht in der Worte. Viele Menschen sehen sie als kriminelle.
Sie sagen, was sie getan ist illegal.
Und deshalb gibt es nicht vieles Publikum für sie. I mean,
the Minister for Mineral Resources today spoke to the press outside the mine
and he says that these illegal miners cost the South African economy 60 billion
last year, 60 billion rand.
So because they're seen as criminals and because they're seen as taken away
from the economy rather than adding to it, there isn't huge amounts of sympathy for them.
And then there's the added complication that a lot of these miners are in South
Africa illegally. They come from neighbouring countries, countries like Zimbabwe,
Mozambique, whose economies have been doing very poorly.
So sympathy for them isn't huge, but rights groups say that regardless of the
fact that they're criminals or even illegal migrants.
They're Und der Bergbauminister hat dann neben den Leichen stehend gesagt,
das sind Kriminelle und die führen einen Krieg gegen Südafrikas Wirtschaft und
damit ist das alles gerechtfertigt.
Wenn man jetzt sich fragt, wer ist da genau unter Tage, dann bekommen wir von
Bloomberg eine Antwort.
And it happens on a number of levels, because I think the first maybe point
of context is around former miners who themselves were a part of these mines
when they were active and licensed and so on.
And so they have a good sense of how things are underneath.
They know where the sections of the shafts are, where they're likely to get the most minerals from.
Und es gibt noch weitere.
Die dort arbeiten.
Then you have people that have never mined before, but they're hearing,
hey, there's a bit of a gold rush happening underneath the earth.
Go and try your luck. And when you are hungry, the unemployment rate is one
of the highest recorded in the world. It does become a very real option.
And then I think the third category is guttruck. Given this vacuum that is there,
given the lack of formalisation around artisanal mining, if we could call it
that, you have these massive cross-border criminal syndicates that have gotten involved.
And their operations are extensive, they're highly armed, they're very dangerous.
You'll find in these communities where there are these abandoned mines and there
is this activity, particularly where it's driven by these syndicates,
crime tends to skyrocket in the area as well.
We've heard horror stories of mass rapes of women, extreme violence that happens
in people's homes as a result of these syndicates.
The other side of it, and we'll get into this a little bit later on when we
speak about the people that have surfaced from this mine,
is that there is an element that appears to be human trafficking,
where you see people from neighboring countries, Malawi, Mozambique in particular,
that find themselves maybe being called by a relative to say,
hey, so-and-so is in South Africa.
Go and stay with them for a while. They've got a really good opportunity for
you. They make their way across the border, most of the time illegally.
When they arrive, they're told that they need to go underground and mine for
this gold and other precious metals.
And they were essentially held hostage. They're against their will,
they're not allowed to leave and their lives are run exploitatively by these syndicates.
Da hat der Staat noch eine Aufgabe, sich um diese Grenze über Dritte zu kümmeln.
Ja, und dieses Gold landet, wie schon gesagt, in den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten oft und geht von da aus weiter.
Man hat auch, und das schmerzt mich natürlich sehr, dass ich ja ein Fan dieses
Landes bin, einen Weg, der dann in die Schweiz führt, in der Schweiz,
und da sind wir wieder bei so etwas wie dem Lieferkettengesetz.
In der Schweiz ist es so, dass der Herkunftsort des Goldes nicht der Ort ist,
wo das Gold dann tatsächlich aus der Mine geholt wurde, sondern der letzte Ort des Goldes.
Von dieser langen Lieferkette ist einfach dann der Ort, von dem das Gold herstand.
Das heißt, wenn die das dann aus den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten haben,
dann ist das offenbar daher.
Stimmt dann oft nicht, ist dann aus Südafrika.
Also typischerweise ist das so, dass wir Gold als Währung verstehen,
wenn auch im Spezialfall so als Reservewährung oder so.
Und das Prinzip einer Währung ist, dass sie gilt unabhängig davon, wo sie herkommt.
Man kann da noch Labels verteilen, aber solange es Ungerechtigkeit auf der Welt
gibt, in dieser Form, die mit der Schürfung von Gold zu tun hat,
ist Gold grundsätzlich der Gefahr ausgeliefert, dass du als Goldkäufer damit
deine Finger im Spiel hast.
Ja, und es sagt natürlich sehr viel aus über unseren globalen Kapitalismus und
es gibt einen Artikel aus dem New Yorker von 2023,
der heißt The Dystopian Underworld of South Africa's Illegal Gold Mines,
den ich sehr empfehlen kann.
Der ist etwa 15, den er vier Seiten lang, dieser Artikel.
Den werde ich also jetzt nicht komplett vorlesen können, aber wir müssen uns
ein paar Impressionen doch verschaffen, wie es da aussieht.
Es wird dann beschrieben. Die Kamera sinkt mit fünf Fuß pro Sekunde.
Bei etwa 800 Fuß erscheinen in der Ferne bewegliche Figuren,
die sich mit fast der gleichen Geschwindigkeit nach unten bewegen.
Es sind zwei Männer, die an den Trägern hinuntergleiten. Sie tragen weder Helme
noch Seile und ihre Unterarme sind durch abgesägte Gummistiefel geschützt.
Die Kamera fährt weiter hinunter und lässt die Männer in der Dunkelheit zurück.
Um die horizontalen Balken unter ihnen auf 600 Fuß sind Leichen gewunden.«.
Überreste von Männern, die in den Tod gestürzt oder vielleicht geworfen worden sind.
Das untere Drittel des Schachts ist stark beschädigt, sodass die Kamera nicht
weiter vordringen kann.
Wenn es noch weitere Leichen gibt, werden sie vielleicht nie gefunden werden.
Als die Bergbauindustrie in Wellcom in den 90er Jahren zusammenbrach,
entstand an ihrer Stelle eine dystopische kriminelle Wirtschaft,
in der Tausende von Männern in die verlassenen Stollen eindrangen und mit rudimentären
Werkzeugen nach dem verbliebenen Erzgruben.
Da es kaum Gemeinkosten oder Sicherheitsstandards gab, konnten diese illegalen
Bergleute in einigen Fällen reich werden.
Viele andere blieben in Armut und starben unter Tage.
Also das ist genau dieses Survival
of the fittest, das sich dann da in dem scheußlichsten Ausmaß zeigt.
Der Journalist spricht mit einem Sama-Sama, Simon, Er fing an,
an der Oberfläche nach Gold zu graben, 2010, die mit Erzen aus der Blütezeit
der Industrie übersät war.
Es gab Gold neben den Eisenbahnschienen, die einst das Gestein aus den Minen transportiert hatten.
Gold zwischen den Fundamenten der abgerissenen Verarbeitungsanlagen,
Gold in den Betten der vergänglichen Bäche.
Aber Simon verdiente nur etwa 35 Dollar pro Tag. Er strebte danach,
ein Haus zu bauen und ein Geschäft zu eröffnen.
Also genau dieser übliche Traum, Eigenheim, Businessman werden.
Um Gold zu bekommen, müsste er unter die Erde gehen.
Das tut er dann auch. Und zwar geht er unter die Erde in der Hoffnung,
dort auf entsprechende Reichtümer zu treffen. Wir werden ihn dann gleich wiederfinden in diesem Artikel.
Es ist so, dass diese Geschäfte, die dort gemacht werden im Untergrund,
alle kontrolliert werden von Syndikaten aus Südafrika oder aus angrenzenden Ländern.
Man kann sagen, steht hier in dem Artikel, dass jede Handyplatine,
jede Anlagemünze und eigentlich auch jeder Ehering von diesen Samas Samas seien.
Simon taucht dann wieder auf, das Syndikat verlangte von Simon mehr als das
Doppelte für die Ausfahrt aus den Minen.
Er blieb fast ein Jahr lang unter der Erde und ernährte sich von den Lebensmitteln,
dem ihm die Läufer zur Verfügung stellten.
Zu diesen Läufern kommen wir gleich. Als er mit zu wenig Geld zurückkam,
ging er wieder in die Mine und bezahlte dasselbe Syndikat dafür,
dass sie im Seil ihn wieder herunterließen.
Er gewöhnte sich an das Leben unter Tage, die Hitze, den Staub, die Dunkelheit.
Er hatte vor, dort zu bleiben, bis er nicht mehr arm war. Aber am Ende kam er
heraus, weil er hungerte.
Es gab also eine sehr lange Geschichte dieses Untergangs dieser Goldminen oder
warum die sich nicht mehr rentiert haben.
Wir lassen das mal alles außen vor und konzentrieren uns auf David Comby.
Auch One-Eye genannt, weil er
ein Auge weggeschossen bekam in einer Auseinandersetzung da. David Combi.
Er trug eine weiße Weste, zerschlissene abgeschnittene Jeans und Flipflops.
Combi lebte auf dem Gelände, wo er sein Einkommen durch Haareschneiden,
Ausbessern von Schuhen und Schneidern von mosambikanischer Kleidung ausbesserte.
Nicht lange nach der Verhaftung wurde er freigelassen und tauchte in den Untergrund
ab, wo er ein kleines Vermögen verdiente, wie mir ein ehemaliges Mitglied seines
engeren Kreises mitteilte.
Einem Experten für den illegalen Goldhandel zufolge soll Combi 2008 begonnen
haben, sein Imperium aufzubauen.
Er hat eine Pyramidenstruktur dann aufgebaut, die wirklich erstaunlich ist.
Womit hat dieser David Combi sein großes Geld verdient? Erstmal nicht mit Gold,
sondern mit Lebensmittel.
Die Versorgung von tausenden von
Zamasamas unter Tag ist eine komplexe und lukrative logistische Aufgabe.
Zunächst kauften viele illegalen Bergleute Lebensmittel von legalen Minenarbeitern,
die ihre Rationen zu überhöhten Preisen verkauften.
Also auch da nochmal Klassenkampf unter den Arbeitenden.
Doch als die, also das ist so ein bisschen so, wir haben die Leute,
die eine Tarifbindung haben und die, die keine haben und die stehen aber noch nebeneinander.
Ohne Personalakte im Werkvertrag.
Das ist noch 90er Jahre, dann sind die, die eine Tarifbindung haben,
spielen keine Rolle mehr, weil das viel zu teuer wäre, mit denen also schließt
man eigentlich die Minen.
Doch als die Minenarbeiter entlassen wurden und die Zahl der Samer Samers zunahm,
begannen die Syndikate Lebensmittel direkt zu liefern. Es entwickelte sich eine
neue Wirtschaft, die sogar noch profitabler sein konnte als Gold.
Die Männer unter Tage hatten nur eine geringe Verhandlungsmacht und die Preisaufschläge
für Lebensmittel betrugen in der Regel zwischen 500 und 1000 Prozent.
Zigaretten, Waschpulver, alles mögliche konnte man nicht kaufen.
Sie bezahlten mit dem Gold, das sie verdient haben. Kombi.
Hat dann Männer dafür bezahlt, dass sie bei Großhändlern direkt einkaufen.
Die Waren dann umverpacken in Luftpolsterfolie und so weiter und die Einnahmen
stiegen dann entsprechend für Kombi und er begann auch das Gold von den Samasamas dann zu kaufen.
Er baute dann ein sehr großes Haus und tat sich als Philanthrop hervor,
der die Menschen unterstützen will und eigentlich nur Gutes will.
Zugleich musste dieser Kombi aber Schutzgebühren auch zahlen an die Banden,
an die Maraschea heißen die, die diese Minen bewachen.
Also auch die haben wieder eine eigene Wirtschaft darum gebaut.
Das funktionierte aber sehr gut. Diese Banden haben auch so eine eigene Kultur hervorgebracht.
Die kamen immer an mit Akkordeonspieler, die dann auch heroische Lieder schrieben
auf die Banden und so weiter.
Und Kombi selbst fing dann an, auf Instagram seinen Lebensstil zu posten.
Mit schicken Autos, einer hübschen Frau, immer die besten italienischen Anzüge trug er.
Und so ging das immer weiter und weiter, bis dieser Mann dann irgendwann vor
Gericht kam, weil er in einen Mord verwickelt ist und dann auch des Mordes schuldig gesprochen wurde.
Was wir also hieran sehen können ist, dass wir zwar zum einen.
In einer Welt leben, in der wir so eine Virtualität haben, wir haben nur noch
mit Sammelkarten und so weiter zu tun, zugleich ist diese Materialität,
die dann bis hin zu unseren Handys vorhanden ist,
eine, die genau solche Ausbeutungsverhältnisse hervorbringt,
bei denen man einfach so achsezuckend sagt, ja, das scheint wohl jetzt so zu
sein, das gibt es da, es wird mal kurz gemeldet im Fernsehen.
Wenn man Glück hat, hat man es mitbekommen. Und das war es dann wieder.
Aber es zeigt eigentlich sich in dieser Struktur, wo immer noch ein Business
und noch ein Business an etwas drankommt,
etwas so Grundsätzliches daran, dass also diese Verhältnisse,
die da sind, die ja zunächst mal nur Wirtschaftsverhältnisse sind,
das ist einfach nur kompetitiv oder so könnte man sagen,
dass diese von Gewalt durchzogen sind.
Und das haben eigentlich so Leute wie Hoss und Hopf und diese ganzen Rechten
in einer Klarheit begriffen, wie das viele aus dem liberalen Spektrum gar nicht
sehen wollen, weil die natürlich immer sagen, ja, aber die soziale Marktwirtschaft und so weiter.
Ja, es gibt natürlich Rahmensetzungen, die vieles verhindern,
aber dass eigentlich dann doch, wenn es hart auf hart kommt,
genau der Kampf wieder dahin zurückgeht,
dass es da wirklich ein gegenseitiges Erschießen gibt,
ein Fressen und Gefressenwerden, dass das ist, was da eigentlich alles strukturiert,
zeigt in größter Transparenz das, was jetzt von den anderen mit netteren Worten nur beschrieben wird.
Mit Wettbewerb und wir wollen auch keine Gesellschaft, in der es nur noch Teilnehmer urkunden wird.
Hoss und Hopf lieben ja das Land,
meinen die Bevölkerung und sie hassen den Staat und das ist ganz interessant,
weil hier kann man dann auch nachhören, wie die also es einfach nur noch paradox
ist, dass man auf der einen Seite einen Podcast macht, der die ganze Zeit über
den Staat abhätet, insbesondere weil er dir Geld wegnimmt,
dann passiert aber etwas, deine Nachbarschaft brennt ab wie in Los Angeles und
plötzlich heißt es, der Staat hat nur eine Aufgabe, uns zu schützen.
Wo warnen die Feuerwehrleute und so weiter.
Also die pendeln immer so hin und her, wie es ihnen gerade gefällt.
Aber der Staat kommt immer schlecht weg.
Entweder weil er dir alles nimmt oder weil er dir keinen Schutz gibt.
Und diese Reduktion auf, ne der Staat soll nur noch regeln, damit es mir,
ja und dann Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Migration, Grenze, Bevölkerung,
Volk, also die anderen, wir.
Und ja, Merz hat dieses Spiel mitgespielt.
Bist du, weil da sind noch drei Clips, die du aber….
Ich bin im Prinzip durch damit, denn ich glaube, die Sache ist verstanden.
Ich empfehle nochmal sehr, diesen Bericht im New Yorker oder diese Reportage
im New Yorker zu lesen, weil sie uns über unsere globalen Ausbeutungsverhältnisse
wahnsinnig viel erzählt.
Und wenn Leute mit kompetitiven Sachen kommen, dann muss man ihnen immer sagen,
ja genau, wie da in der Mine in Südafrika lest. es euch einfach mal durch.
Und es ist ja wirklich genau wie dieses Computerspiel, nur das sieht halt schön
aus, ist ja so bunt und gezeichnet.
Aber man schickt da ja Meiner für sich rein, die für einen arbeiten und kann
wiederum Manager einstellen, die für sich was tun, also es wird ja immer noch
so etwas angedockt, also es gibt immer noch eine weitere Möglichkeit,
und diese Einführung von Intermediären, das ist ja eigentlich das Interessante,
dass ja sehr viele dieser Libertären und Rechten kämpfen ja und das macht sie
ja dann manchmal so sympathisch für viele, die da gar nicht ideologisch mit
einer Meinung sind, gegen vorhandene Intermediäre.
Die sagen, das finde ich aber scheiße, warum muss denn eigentlich da immer noch
ein Sender was beschließen? Warum muss denn da noch der dazwischen gescheitert sein?
Können wir das nicht einfach versteigern?
Können wir das nicht einfach so machen, genau. Und dann bauen sie aber natürlich,
sobald sie die Macht haben, wieder neue Intermediäre auf.
Das ist ja das Interessante. Also warum brauche ich jetzt noch mal eine Plattform
von Logan Paul, um meine Kärtchen zu verkaufen?
Warum muss er jetzt ein neuer Intermediär werden, den ich mit meinem Geld dann
unterstütze, der sich auch mal noch was einlädt?
PayPal ist ja auch ein Intermediär, der mit jeder Zahlung noch mal extra verdient.
Und dadurch ist Elon Musk reich geworden.
Also diese ganzen Intermediäre und diejenigen, die dagegen kämpfen,
Ist nur immer jeweils die andere Seite derselben Medaille.
Jede Bauernregel, insbesondere die, die uns besonders plausibel erscheinen,
gibt es auch mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen. Und wenn wir die hören,
ist es genauso plausibel.
Es war ja auch so amüsant, die sagen ja zum einen, die sind gegen Free Speech
und gegen woke Meinungszensur.
Also erst mal PBS abschaffen. Und dann würde ich erst mal sagen,
ja, ich bin auch gegen Zensur, ich bin für Free Speech, aha,
dann bin ich also bei denen.
Dann sind die aber zugleich für Zensur, wenn es dann darum geht,
irgendwelche linken Meinungen zu beschneiden.
Oder ja auch interessant bei Twitter war das ja zu erleben, dass als dieser
TikTok-Bann, Kurzbann, wie immer man das nennen möchte, kam,
dann, Selbstbann müsste man es eigentlich nennen, Ulf Posch hat gesagt,
dass er sehr dafür ist, TikTok zu verbannen.
Also da dann plötzlich nicht mehr Free Speech, das ist dann nicht gut.
Ja, ihr Verhältnis zu China müssen sie eh noch strukturieren, alle.
Ja.
Gut, ich möchte eine Wahlempfehlung abgeben, weil es steht ja eine Wahl an und
wir haben heute schon ausführlich darüber gesprochen, was zur Wahl steht.
Das hatten wir noch nie, dass hier eine Wahlempfehlung ausgesprochen wurde.
No, aber es fanden ja auch eine Bundestagswahl bisher statt.
Und eine Europawahl.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Ja, aber ich bin natürlich getriggert, ich habe jetzt Hoss und Hopf gehört und
ich werde die Vorzeichen umdrehen. Bei Hoss und Hopf klingt es ja so.
Wie immer Leute, wir geben hier keine Wahlempfehlung raus. Ihr wählt nachher,
was ihr für richtig haltet. Das ist der einzige Weg, das ist der demokratische Weg.
Ihr wählt, was ihr für richtig haltet und das wird nachher Konsequenzen geben.
Und diese Konsequenzen müssen wir alle tragen. So ist das Leben nun mal.
Deswegen ist Eigenverantwortung und Selbstverantwortung so wichtig.
Ja, so ist das Leben nun. Mit den Konsequenzen müssen wir leben und deswegen
ist es ja so wichtig, dass wir unseren Bizeps stärken.
Er vertieft es.
Und weder Kian noch ich haben uns jemals, auch wenn es uns schon oft als Vorwurf
gemacht wurde, uns für eine Partei in diesem Land ausgesprochen.
Weder Kian noch ich haben jemals gesagt, ich wähle die Partei A oder ich wähle die Partei B.
Es wird weiterhin auch so sein. Wir nehmen hier, wir können auch unsere Meinungen
kundtun und das ist auch wichtig, aber ich sage nicht, Leute,
ihr sollt das und das wählen.
Ich wähle meine Partei, ich spreche aber auch nicht drüber, welche das ist.
Ich habe eine Partei, durch die ich mich sehr gut vertreten fühle.
Das ist meine Entscheidung.
Ihr trefft eure Entscheidung und wir gehen das hier einfach nur ganz neutral
durch und besprechen, was eben gesagt wurde. So, das wollte ich nur ganz kurz erwähnen.
Rätselraten. Er hat eine Partei, die er überzeugt wählt, aber er sagt uns nicht
welche. Finden wir heraus, welche das ist?
Anhand von zwei Clips. Der eine von Hob, der andere von Hoss. Fangen wir mal an.
Also die sind alle so, also ja, du siehst einfach nur, die Nerven liegen blank und das ist halt,
Schau mal, ich sage, eine Partei wie die AfD, die braucht keinen Elon Musk,
um Werbung für sie zu machen, denn das gesamte Land macht jeden Tag Werbung
für die. Jetzt alleine an Silvester.
Was glaubst du denn, für wem das Zulauf gibt?
Mehrere Tote, Dutzende Verletzte, bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände,
die von der Polizei exakt so benannt werden.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Bürger das sagen, die Polizei sagt,
nein, das war gar nicht so. Nein, die Polizei, die sind alle überfordert.
Dutzende Verletzte, alles am Arsch.
Nur noch, du hast, wenn du die Interviews, was heißt Interviews,
also so von mutigen Reportern, die da auf der Straße standen und dann kamen
die Tallerhunds und haben gesagt, die Polizei hat hier nichts zu sagen.
Wir haben die Kontrolle. Ja, ist absolut korrekte Einschätzung der Situation.
So ist es. Polizei hat nichts zu sagen, Talaons haben die Kontrolle.
Und wundert sich da einer, wie das aktuell in den Umfragen aussieht.
Also ich finde, das ist doch scheißegal, ob der Elon Musk da was sagt oder nicht.
Der bestätigt nur das, was viele Leute denken.
Und das ist eine Wahlwerbung nachher. Und wer hat diese Wahlwerbung zu verantworten?
Die Leute, die diese ganzen hunderttausende Leute ins Land gelassen haben.
Das ist doch eine ganz simple Sache.
Hättest du eine Idee, wen er wählt?
Nee, ich komme wirklich gar nicht drauf. Also welche Partei könnte das wohl sein?
Ja, wir hören jetzt Hoss, der uns noch eine, wie man heute Neudeutsch in der
Politikwissenschaft, in der praktischen Politikwissenschaft eine Erlaubnisstruktur gibt.
Also im Sinne von, ja, AfD und ich weiß, dir sagen die Leute,
das geht nicht und so, aber doch, vielleicht geht es doch, denk nochmal drüber nach.
Am Ende sollte es doch allen Menschen nur darum geben, allen,
dass die Gesellschaft vernünftig funktioniert, dass die Wirtschaft vernünftig
funktioniert, dass es landsicher ist, dass man sich wohl fühlt.
Und egal, wer das am Ende durchsetzt oder auch dafür spricht und wem man das
auch irgendwo so ein bisschen abkaufen kann, weil er das nicht in Vergangenheit
massiv missbraucht hat, den kann man doch mal wählen und dann gucken,
was passiert. Wir haben doch eine Verfassung.
Es ist doch nicht so, dass jemand gewählt wird und plötzlich,
keine Ahnung, das Land explodiert.
Es wurden doch damals, als Hitler an die Macht gekommen ist,
danach Maßnahmen unternommen, damit sowas nicht nochmal passieren kann.
Ja, da müsste ich jetzt auch nochmal drüber nachdenken. Wer könnte denn da jetzt?
So, jetzt hören wir AOC. Sie war im Podcast mit Jon Stewart.
Auch dann ein großes Publikum. 3-4 Millionen Abrufe oder so, allein bei YouTube.
Und was ist jetzt zu tun? Es wird ja auch so ein bisschen bemängelt.
Wo sind denn die Demokraten? Was passiert denn da?
Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, hey, das hat jetzt alles Zeit.
Also, was wir nicht brauchen, ist jetzt Personal.
Also, ich brauche jetzt nicht Nancy Pelosi, die immer noch mal erzählt dass
Trump wirklich evil ist oder Chuck Schumer oder so.
Wir brauchen irgendwie etwas anderes.
Sie geht erstmal auf diese neurechten Botschaften ein.
Wenn du an die Frage nach, wie zum Beispiel Putin in Russland operiert hat und die Art,
wie sie Dinge übernehmen können, in diesen Oligarchien, diesen Kleptokrasien,
sie betrachten auf diesen exakten,
on that exact logic, on that exact predicate, which is that everyone's corrupt and it's all corrupt.
And so who gives a fuck? Sorry. Right.
Yes. How dare you? At long last, have you no decency?
And you might as well just get yours. And the problem with that is that we just
entirely give up on a better world.
Like that is the, that's the crux of it.
Ja, also jedes Mal, wenn Hopf da irgendwie in seinem Podcast sagt,
kümmere dich um dich, halte dein Zimmer in Ordnung, geh ins Gym,
lies mein Buch, ist das ja im Grunde die Botschaft,
gib auf, hör auf Ansprüche zu stellen, frag nicht nach dem Staat,
frag nicht, was der Staat für dich tun kann, es wird keinen Staat geben,
kümmere dich um dich, also man muss die Botschaft dann sozusagen übersetzen.
Und eigentlich müsste im CDU-Programm auch stehen, wir haben Ihnen nichts anzubieten.
Wir könnten, wenn Sie möchten, Ihre rassistischen Ressentiments bedienen,
da hätten wir fünf Vorschläge, die wir auch ohne Kompromiss gerne umsetzen.
Aber Ihr Steuergeld wollen wir nicht, wir entlasten Sie um 100 Milliarden Abgaben.
Wenn Sie aber nicht viel Geld haben, dann könnte sein, dass Sie nochmal ein
bisschen mehr zahlen müssen, um den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland zu stützen
und den Sozialstaat noch aufrecht zu halten.
Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, gut wären jetzt tolle Personen mit super Programm.
Also irgendwer aufstrebend kommt und sagt, ich habe die echten fünf Punkte, wie auch immer.
Jetzt sagt AOC, nee, jetzt mal Schritt für Schritt, es fehlt was anderes.
Was ist der Prozess, dann, von Redefining was das Party ist,
was es represents moving forward?
Und sind there leaders there? Es ist sclerotisch.
Es ist ein Party in in real confusion.
And I don't know, I can't put my finger on, it reminds me of the Republicans
in 2012 where there was just, when Trump came into that first 2016 primary,
I mean, he just like flicking his finger, not Jeb Bush, yeah, nice, boom, done.
And I think the Democrats are vulnerable to that.
So what is the process of redefining und recapturing was this party is.
Well, I think we need a real agenda. If you've noticed, the Democratic Party
has not really had a platform with any sort of new- I have noticed. Yeah.
There's no platform. I mean, there's technically a platform that gets voted on.
This is the crux of it. If you ask a working class American or just any normal
American, what is a Democrat? What do they stand for?
Ja, wir brauchen eine Agenda, ein Ziel,
kein ausformuliertes Programm, sondern so eine Idee, die ja lauten könnte,
der Staat könnte mal wieder für mich da sein, ohne dass ich jetzt bitte die
Aufgabe der Politiker erledigen soll.
In welcher Form, in welcher Höhe, wie viel Geld, für was und so weiter.
Das können ja dann die Profis klären.
Jetzt erstmal eine Agenda und damit ist nur eine Idee gemeint.
So eine Agenda, von der wir alle meinen, nur Agenda ist jetzt ganz wichtig,
keine Agenda haben, free of agenda, free agenda, wie sie die ganzen Kanäle heißen.
Einfach erstmal eine Idee in den Raum stellen, wie zum Beispiel,
der Staat könnte mal wieder für dich da sein.
Irgendwer wird schon irgendwelche Ideen kommen und dann gibt es einen demokratischen
Prozess, Da stellt man sie gegenüber, aber der Staat könnte mal prinzipiell wieder für dich da sein.
Du musst ihn nicht als Feind begreifen, die Politiker als deine Gegner,
wie auch immer, sondern sie tun mal etwas für dich. Fragen wir uns natürlich,
hat das irgendeine deutsche Partei im Angebot?
Wir grasen den Journalismus dazu ab, beginnen beim Deutschlandfunk.
Dort gibt es einen Podcast, Der Tag, dich zu verwechseln mit der sehr guten
Sendung, Das war der Tag, also Deutschlandfunk, Der Tag, gibt einen Überblick
über die Programme und Agendas der politischen Parteien, die zur Wahl stehen.
Dann kommen wir mal von den Entlastungen zu den Belastungen oder beziehungsweise
Belastungen klingt immer so negativ.
Belastung klingt immer so negativ, weißt du? Das ist doch nicht gut,
wenn es jetzt hier um Belastung geht.
Jedenfalls zu den Vorschlägen, einige Gruppen doch ein bisschen stärker ranzuziehen.
Die sind nicht so zahlreich, wenn ich mir ihre Tabelle angucke, aber es gibt ein paar.
Stichwort Erbschafts- und Vermögenssteuer.
So, Stichwort Erbschafts- und Vermögenssteuer. Sie hat einen Gesprächspartner,
der hat eine ganze Tabelle.
Also alles, was zur Wahl steht, Sie gehen das jetzt mal durch.
Wagt sich daran und wie ambitioniert? So richtig ambitioniert,
weiß nicht, ob da eine Partei sich wirklich zeigt.
Aber was man sagen kann... Da müsste man vielleicht dann doch nochmal ins Wahlprogramm
der Linken reingucken, nehme ich an. Das mag dann in der Tat sein.
Ja, hat man irgendwie nicht gemacht.
Ach so, das hört man einfach mal aus.
Also ich habe so eine Tabelle, ich mache mal eine Analyse. Ja,
also bei Erbschaftssteuer sollte man vielleicht doch nochmal bei den Linken reinschauen.
Also was ist denn das bitte? Scheiß, das versteht doch niemand.
Wir müssen über innere Sicherheit reden. Wir können jetzt nicht anfangen mit Erbschaftssteuer.
Das Politikteil der Zeit. Sie reden auch über die Angebote der Parteien,
zum Beispiel hier über das von BSW.
Okay, bleibt noch das BSW.
So im Sinne von bleibt noch, so als Letzte gucken wir jetzt mal bei der BSW.
Da sieht man immer Wagenknecht und dann zwei Slogans, unser Land verdient mehr
oder unser Land wünscht sich mehr.
Und dann kommt Frieden, Rente, Wohnungen, Lehrer und Ärzte, weniger Migration.
Und dann immer, aber die alten Parteien haben versagt.
Das ist fast noch aggressiver in Richtung der sogenannten etablierten Parteien, oder?
Ich finde es vor allem interessant, wenn man es mit den Plakaten der Linken
vergleicht. Die sind ja wirklich quasi schamlos, hemmungslos, linkspopulistisch.
Wenn du zu viel Miete zahlst, dann ist das der Vermieter schuld.
Wenn dein Einkauf zu teuer ist, dann bereichert sich ein Konzern.
Also die wenden praktisch, das ist eine klassische Neidkampagne,
Die eben gegen den, ich sag mal, den Antagonisten wenden.
Warum ist die Zeit so blöde? Das gibt es doch gar nicht.
Also wer profitiert denn sonst von höheren Mieten außer der Vermieter?
Das ist einfach nur, das ist ja nur Betriebswirtschaft.
Also man kann jetzt sagen, ich möchte gerne, dass die Vermieter reich sind.
Dann soll man das sagen. Dann sagt das bei der Zeit. Sagt einfach,
wir wollen Politik für die Vermieter.
Wir wollen, dass es den Vermietern gut geht, weil die unsere Zeitung für zu
viel Geld immer noch abonnieren. Dann sagt das doch einfach.
Aber das ist betriebswirtschaftliche Logik. Jeder würde so handeln.
Jeder würde in einer betriebswirtschaftlichen Logik sondern und deswegen ist
es auch gut, das auf das Plakat zu schreiben und wir haben gesehen,
wie die Lebensmittelkonzerne und die Konzernchefs ihre,
Einnahmen, ihre Gewinne verdoppeln konnten in den vergangenen Jahren im Zuge der Inflation.
Wir haben ja den Text von Isabella Weber, wir haben die Überschrift kritisiert, aber nicht den Inhalt.
Es gab Preisschocks in den grundlegenden Energie- und Rohstoffversorgungen.
Dieser wurde weitergegeben. Es gab eine Inflation im Supermarkt.
Dann ging dieser Preisschock in den Energie- und Rohstoffen zurück.
Und die Preise sind einfach hoch geblieben. Ab jetzt Gewinnmarge.
Also wenn ein Plakat hängt mit, an deinem Einkauf im Supermarkt bereichert sich jemand. Ja.
Und bei der Miete es ist das einfachste Vertragsverhältnis der Welt.
Es gibt einen Vermieter. Dann gibt es einen Mieter.
Und die Sache ist mit drei Seiten BGB geregelt. Da kommt keine Kommune dazwischen,
da kommt kein Land dazwischen.
Das ist einfach nur, du machst eine Bundestagswahl. Das ist das einzige Gremium,
das darüber entscheiden kann, was in Mietverträgen steht.
Und dann gibt es einen Vermieter und einen Mieter.
So, und der Wähler ist nun auf einer dieser beiden Seiten. Und wenn der.
Vermieter sagt… Und der Gewinn des einen ist der Verlust des anderen.
Genau, also es ist eigentlich eins plus eins ist zwei.
Ja, das ist so eine Sache.
Es ist wirklich verrückt, wie diese beiden, hier Deutschlandfunk und die Zeit einfach,
Da gucken wir gar nicht hin und wenn wir hingucken, sehen wir nur Linkspopulismus
und klassische Neiddebatte.
Das ist der Tenor, der hier ist. In diesen großen Fragen, die wir jetzt bis
hierhin heute geklärt haben, ist das die Antwort des Journalismus da auch.
Im Deutschlandfunk schiebt sie aber noch so einen Nachtrag hinterher.
Ihr ist doch im Gespräch dann doch so ein kleiner eigener Fehler im Handwerk aufgefallen.
Herr Henze, ich danke Ihnen ganz, ganz herzlich für Ihre Analyse und dass Sie
das mit uns geteilt haben. Vielen Dank. Sehr gerne.
Und zwei Ergänzungen noch zu diesem Gespräch. Erstens waren ja Die Linke und
das BSW nicht Teil der Analyse von Tobias Henze.
Aber die BSW immerhin Teil des Gesprächs noch.
Aber damit die nicht unter den Tisch fallen, habe ich nochmal nachgeguckt.
Auch Die Linke verspricht in diesem Wahlkampf eine Reform der Einkommenssteuer.
Da sollen grob alle, die weniger als 7000 Euro brutto im Monat verdienen,
weniger Steuern zahlen.
Dafür soll der Spitzensteuersatz auf 53 Prozent steigen und Superreiche,
was auch immer in dem Zusammenhang Superreiche heißt, sollen 75 Prozent Reichensteuer zahlen.
Das ist übrigens genau beziffert, was unter Superreich gemeint ist,
wer bei den 75 Prozent der Fall
ist. Ich habe die Zahl jetzt gar nicht im Kopf, sie steht im Programm.
Und ganz lustig ist, ja eigentlich müsste sie sagen,
Also ich würde davon entlastet werden.
Sie verdienen wahrscheinlich unter 7.000.
Und Sie, die hier alle zuhören, verdienen im großen Teil auch alle unter 7.000.
Sie würden ja offenbar davon entlastet werden. Das ist absurd.
Der Wahlkampf im Journalismus abgebildet ist unglaublich.
Also ich kann ja noch verstehen, wenn da irgendwelche Multimillionäre unter
Journalisten zusammensitzen, die sagen, uiuiui, da wird mir die Linke aber unangenehm.
Und deswegen verschweigen wir das. Aber dass jetzt auch diese Leute da,
die da irgendwie in der Zeit ein bisschen schreiben dürfen oder hier mal vor
das Mikro können, dass die sich so solidarisieren mit den Reichen.
Das ist ja dann wirklich so wie Hoss und Hopf sehen sich ja als die Kumpels von Elon Musk.
Und hier sagen sie, ach oh, die wollen die Superreichen, was immer das meint,
besteuern. Ja, du wirst nie davon gemeint sein.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man als Journalist 2025, einen Monat vor der Bundestagswahl,
das Wort Superreiche ausspricht und zu erkennen gibt, dass man selber keinen
Begriff hat, also kein Konzept hinter diesem Begriff hat,
dann muss man sich in Urlaub nehmen und nacharbeiten.
Also jeder braucht einen Begriff von Superreichtum. Wir haben Bücher, die heißen Superreich.
Oder Crazy Rich.
Crazy Rich. Und da wird es genau thematisiert. Also es ist wirklich ganz,
ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm.
So, Precht und Lanz haben ja auch einen sehr guten Podcast, finde ich.
Insbesondere, weil Lanz und Precht immer gut dagegen hält.
Und sie sind so in Plauderstimmung, die Precht dann mal kurz unterbricht,
bis Lanz feststellt, ach so, nee, nee, nee, stopp, stopp, so habe ich das nicht gemeint.
So, jedes Jahr werden in Deutschland zwischen drei und vierhundert Milliarden vererbt.
Weißt du, wie viel der Staat davon einnimmt? 10 Milliarden.
Das heißt, man kann in diesem Land sehr, sehr gut leben und zahlt dann auch
seine 25% Kapitalertragssteuer, wenn man ein so großes Aktienpaket hat,
dass man ausschließlich von den Gewinnen dieser Aktien leben kann,
beispielsweise oder auch Immobilienbesitz.
Und auch da, du zahlst, wenn du ein kleiner Immobilien, du hast ein kleines
Häuschen, das vererbst du.
So, dann wird die Erbschaftssteuer fällig. Wenn du groß genug bist und hast
so viele Immobilien, dass du daraus sozusagen ein eigenes Unternehmen gründen
kannst, so hast du nichts.
Dann wird einfach das Unternehmen sozusagen weitergegeben.
Dann sieht die Welt ganz anders aus. Das heißt, ich weiß jetzt,
welche Wahlempfehlungen du Menschen gibst, die die Linkspartei zu wählen.
Weil die möchten auf jeden Fall die Erbschaftssteuern erhöhen und die Schlupflöcher
machen und Vermögenssteuer vergrößern. Und Andrea, mir geht es um was anderes.
Mir geht es darum, dass wir schon, finde ich, ernsthaft, und das ist ja ein
Zusammenspiel, auch aus Medien und Politik und öffentlicher Wahrnehmung.
So schön. Nee, wir bleiben lieber im Gerede.
Mir geht es ja um was anderes. Ich wollte ja ernsthaft darüber reden.
Also, wenn in Deutschland jemand Milliardäre härter rannehmen will,
weil sie das Geld haben, das uns allen gehört, macht gar keinen Sinn,
dass der Kühne da in seinem Pool, Helena Steinhaus hat ja dieses Bild gezeigt
und mit seinem Getränk irgendwie 40.000 pro Minute verballert,
während man das Geld genauso gut in Infrastruktur, Schulen, was auch immer stecken könnte.
So, jedes Mal, wenn jemand an die Milliardäre ran will, gilt das als populistisch
und damit nicht mehr im Diskurs.
Weshalb es für mich nur eine Möglichkeit gibt, um alles zu retten,
diejenigen, die an die Milliardäre ran wollen und den Arsch in der Hose haben,
Zu wollen, obwohl ihnen von allen Seiten gesagt wird, das ist aber populistisch,
das geht aber in eine Neiddebatte, wie auch immer, genau diesen jetzt zu unterstützen,
weil der Diskursraum in diese Richtung verbreitert werden muss.
So, dass wir jetzt die Chance haben, den Diskursraum zu verbreitern,
indem wir einfach bei der Bundestagswahl eine richtige Wahl treffen,
ist ja, also das ist eine tolle Einladung. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen,
damit ist dann alles gelöst.
Es geht grundsätzlich um diesen Diskursraum. Wir können hier nicht Hoss und
Hopf überlassen und dem Bizeps und jeder Einzelne und hier und es ist ein Naturfakt
und so weiter. Geht einfach nicht.
Nur jetzt im Februar haben wir doch die Chance, einfach die Linke zu wählen,
die nur diese Idee in den Raum stellt.
Und es ist die richtige Idee. Und ich finde auch, es ist die einzige Idee,
um die es gerade gehen soll politisch. Ich finde ja schon, sehr viele Sachen
kann man auch jenseits der Politik regeln.
Ja, wir sind ja jetzt nicht hier
sitzen und sagen, wir wollen das ja alles staatlich geregelt bekommen.
Also ins Gym muss man tatsächlich selber gehen. Und das tut einem auch gut und
das ist auch zu empfehlen.
Sehr richtig.
So, das macht nicht der Politiker. Also das ist einfach nicht der Pizza-Lieferservice,
der dann sagt, du hast ein Sixpack bestellt? Hier.
Jens Spahn. Nee, das muss man selber machen. Aber an die Milliardäre,
also das kann man nicht selber machen.
Ja.
Da braucht man jetzt jemanden, der diese Idee dort, wo es heikel wird, vorträgt.
Man muss natürlich dann auch darauf hoffen, dass eine Bevölkerung überhaupt
sich noch für, wie du es nennen würdest, Mathematik interessiert.
Also sich dafür interessiert, dass 2 plus 2 4 zum Beispiel sind.
Ich will dir ein letztes Beispiel geben und zwar der allerletzte Clip,
den ich ausgewählt habe, der wurde mir geschickt von einem Hörer,
der sagte, er redet doch immer über die Fakten und dann wird aber so getan,
als sei das doch alles nur Meinungen beziehungsweise,
sind die Leute ja überhaupt nicht mehr für Fakten,
anfällig, sondern sagen, da lasse ich mich aber jetzt gar nicht drauf ein,
das ist ja, also wir haben jetzt eben gehört,
Milliardär bescheuert, das ist ja populistisch.
Wie ist es eigentlich so mit Rechnungen? Wir hören jetzt hier,
das ist irgendein Reality-Format, ich weiß nicht genau, was das ist.
Da ist ein Comedian-Kristall, der rechnet was vor und der Fußballer Mario Basler
antwortet jetzt darauf und ich würde sagen,
es ist tatsächlich unser Diskurs Deutschland im Jahr 2025.
Das interessiert mich nicht, die Scheiße. Kommt mit deinen intellektuellen Scheiß...
Ich denke immer, ihr spielt das.
Nein. Man muss aber dazu sagen, dass Mario dann schon auch Argumente liefert,
dass man sagt, ja gut, die verstehe ich dann auch.
Punkt vor Strich gibt es bei mir nicht, die Scheiße.
Das ist doch aber keine Entscheidung, die du triffst. Doch, das ist doch ein
Scheiß. Mit euer Punkt vor Strich hat es das früher gegeben.
Nein. Die Griechen haben das, glaube ich, erfunden. Interessiert mich,
Scheiß trägt ein Punktvollstrich. Punktvollstrich, ist mir scheißegal.
Hat es das etwa schon früher gegeben? Ja.
So, okay, das ist sehr gut. Man kann sich leicht verrechnen,
selbst wenn die Frage 2 plus 2 mal 2 ist. So.
Man kann sich auch politisch verrechnen, wenn man einfach das nicht beachtet,
wie die reinste Logik funktioniert.
Ich will das nochmal kontrastieren mit dem zweiten großen Angebot.
Nicht nur von Friedrich Merz, aber stellvertretend.
Alle stimmen im Grunde in diesem Tenor ein. Hauptsache nicht die echten Rechten regieren.
Wir wollen die rechte Politik machen.
Ich habe ja eben schon betont, in der Problemlage stimmen wir alle überein.
Schule funktioniert nicht, Bus fährt nicht, alles kaputt, alles scheiße.
Es könnte alles besser sein.
Wir stimmen hier mit Peter Thiele überein, mit Horst und Hopf,
mit David Grabber, mit mir.
Man kann jetzt auch andere Meinungen haben und sagen, nee, ich finde es geil,
wie es läuft, aber für den Fall, dass man diese Meinung teilt.
So, man kann jetzt sagen,
20 Billionen Privatvermögen, davon 16 Billionen bei den 1 Prozent.
Das macht irgendwie keinen Sinn. Wir könnten dieses Kapital nehmen,
um hier wieder was zu erarbeiten.
Oder, und das ist jetzt sozusagen der Gegenentwurf, man wählt einfach irgendeine
von diesen Parteien, die jetzt die Rechten kopiert, zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz.
Wir können mal reinhören, wie sich Merz zum Beispiel in Sachen Migration äußert.
Über drei Millionen Drittstaatsangehörige, die nach Deutschland kommen.
Wenn Sie diese Zahl sehen, dann kann man vielleicht noch etwas einfacher verstehen,
warum es uns im Augenblick nicht gelingt,
zum Beispiel im Bereich der Schulen für eine gute Bildung zu sorgen,
warum es uns nicht gelingt, im Bereich der Gesundheits- und Krankenversorgung
ausreichende Kapazitäten vorzuhalten und warum es uns auch nicht gelingt,
etwa im Wohnungsmarkt genügend Wohnraum zu schaffen.
Das ist einfach eine objektive Überforderung der Möglichkeiten unseres Landes.
Ja, dazu muss man sagen, das war jetzt nur eine Pressekonferenz,
die ja naturgemäß etwas gesitteter abläuft und auch der Ton ist dann ein bisschen gedämpfter.
Ja, gedämpfter Ton und gesitterter Ablauf.
Ist das jetzt die richtige Einordnung?
Ja, wenn Friedrich Merz es ernst meint mit, die nehmen uns die Zahnarzttermine
weg, dann ist es mir völlig egal, in welcher Form er das vorträgt.
Ob der gebrüllt hat oder geflüstert.
Dann ist das einfach eine 2 plus 2 mal 2 ist 8 Rechnung, bei der wir später
feststellen, nee geht nicht auf, macht keinen Sinn.
Also diese Mathematik stimmt einfach nicht. So und wenn dann die Antwort ist, ja minus 8 dann?
Ne, also wenn wir jetzt die Ausländer noch rausnehmen, geht erst recht nichts mehr.
Also dann haben wir erst recht keine Schulsysteme und Ärzte und was auch immer. Also Teufelsküche.
Hier ist eine jetzt grundlegende Entscheidung zu treffen.
Bitte nicht den Valomat bedienen, bitte nicht Programme lesen,
wer was verspricht oder so, sondern einfach nur diese eine zentrale Idee pro Partei.
Finde ich die gut oder nicht? Und dann trifft man seine Entscheidung.
Aber ich würde euch nicht sagen, wen ihr wählen sollt.
Ihr sollt selber entscheiden und dann ins Gym, ne?
Und dann ins Gym. Ja, natürlich. Oder wir gehen jetzt zum Schnitzel essen.
Willst du schon los? Okay. Wir hören Robin Alexander dann als Teaser nächste Woche. vorm.
Ja, oder dann spiel noch Robin Alexander. Wir haben ja noch was Zeit.
Ich finde es sehr gut, dass wir heute ein bisschen früher dran sind, weil ich habe Eile.
Aber es wird in diesem auch kurzen Monat viel passieren. Davon können wir fest ausgehen.
Wir haben den Journalismus schon genug gehasst. Wir können jetzt nicht noch
eine Schippe drauflegen. Nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche im Teaser geht es da nochmal rund und wir werden wie schon angekündigt
dann von Marc Schieritz das Buch lesen zu dumm für die Demokratie? Fragezeichen.
Wir sagen ja.
Mal schauen, welcher demokratietheoretische Ansatz da vorgestellt wird,
ob ich damit d'accord gehen kann.
Denn man kann natürlich auch mit einer solchen zu dumm für die Demokratie sehr
gut den Staat absichern vor der Bevölkerung, vor dem Volk.
Also von daher kann man das natürlich auch neoliberal auslegen,
was ich jetzt Marc Schieritz nicht gleich unterstellen will,
aber wir werden sehen und diskutieren, was da drin steckt.
Ich will mir mal noch offen halten, was ich sonst im Salon vorstelle.
Du wahrscheinlich auch noch oder hast du schon was im Blick?
Ich habe vor das Gemeinsinnbuch der Assmanns
jetzt mal mitzubringen. Also ich habe jetzt Zeit zu lesen.
Ich glaube, das wird vielleicht, also vom Titel und Thema her ist das Buch der
Stunde für mich und Aßmanns mag ich sowieso, beide.
Von daher wird das wahrscheinlich meine zweite, also der Rest dann mal gucken,
aber wir können ja mal gucken, was so kommentiert wird zu dem,
was heute im Bundestag geschah. Erst mal die Texte abwarten.
Und hier nochmal der deutliche Hinweis, wir freuen uns sehr,
wenn dieser Podcast geteilt wird.
Das muss gar nicht nur in den sozialen Medien geschehen, sondern kann natürlich
auch intern bei WhatsApp oder sonst wo laufen.
Wir freuen uns auch über gute Bewertungen auf den entsprechenden Plattformen.
Und ja, freuen uns, wenn wir vielleicht mit den einen oder anderen Argumenten,
die wir hier geäußert haben, auch bei Leuten Gehör finden, die uns noch nicht
kennen, beziehungsweise die vielleicht sonst da gar nicht so zugänglich für sind,
denn tatsächlich steht ja, wie wir jetzt in aller Deutlichkeit gesehen haben,
relativ viel auf dem Spiel.
Die Lage ist tatsächlich diskursiv
eher so, wie der Clip von Mario Barstow das jetzt abgebildet hat.
Oder noch ein Beispiel, ich habe mich unterhalten mit einer Dame Ende 50,
die sich sehr über den Rechtsruck aufregte, über Trump und AfD und besonders
Alice Weidel und überhaupt, wie sich alles weiter nach rechts entwickelt,
um dann herauszufinden.
Das Ganze zu schließen mit den Worten, haben Sie gestern die Tanur gesehen? Es war wieder so witzig.
Und dann merkt man natürlich, wenn man dann nochmal so zwei,
drei Nachfragen stellt, dass ökonomisch zum Beispiel so gut wie nichts verstanden
wird. Insofern ist da sehr viel zu tun.
Wir können einen kleinen Beitrag leisten.
Der Rest muss man sehen, wie das so geht. Wir freuen uns jedenfalls,
wenn der Podcast unterstützt wird.
Und wir freuen uns auch, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert.
Das ist, wie gesagt, möglich am einfachsten über Steady auf neue20er.de,
auf den goldenen Button, dann kommt man direkt zu dem Steady-Abo.
Wenn man uns über Spotify hört, kann man auch dort gleich sich rüberleiten lassen.
Apple ist auch eine Möglichkeit, um die Paywall zu durchschreiten und dann gibt es noch Pet.
Ich schreibe nochmal die Case-Termine unten rein. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht nochmal
nachgefragt, ob es noch Karten gibt. Das letzte Mal war ja noch das letzte Drittel offen.
Ja, genau. Die Termine von unseren Live-Auftritten, die findet ihr dann auch in der Beschreibung.
Die erste Case im März ist schon komplett ausverkauft. Ich vermute die im Juni auch.
Wir wollen aber im nächsten Salon auch noch einen Opern-Termin bekannt geben.
Und wir geben im nächsten Salon bekannt, wie unser Sommer, wann unser Sommer-Event sein wird.
Und was wir schon mal sagen können, wir werden dann keine Gäste haben aber Publikumsfragen
und ich habe ja eine Idee Fragen vom oder an das Publikum? Vom Publikum.
Wir werden Fragen beantworten des Publikums.
Wir beantworten Fragen des Publikums nicht nur, sondern in einem Teil und ich
werde dir gleich, wenn die Mikros aus sind, erzählen, wie ich mir das vorstelle,
damit wir möglichst viele Fragen beantworten können.
Wir auktionieren die Fragen.
Einen schönen Monat.
Bis dann. Okay, ich bin gespannt.